Vorher auf Freakshow.
Ja, das ist die 0118 999 881 99 911.
Okay, danke, das war eigentlich, danke, ich sehe, Sie haben verstanden,
Dankeschön, gehen Sie bitte vom Belüftungsgitter weg, wir machen die Tür auf.
Oh, Belüftungsgitter? Wo ist denn dann die Tür?
Hm?
Oh, what the fuck?
Hä? Okay. Ähm.
Ah. Ja, ist der da. Genau. Ich hatte schon ein bisschen Angst,
dass du uns hier gleich abklipst, äh, kappst.
Nochmal. Abklapst. Ja, auf sowas war ich nicht vorbereitet. Komm nochmal rein.
Genau. Nee, besser nicht.
Naja, weiß man ja nicht. Ich klappst dich nochmal richtig ab,
Letti. Aber, was ist das denn hier für ein Ohr? das sieht irgendwie aus wie
ein groß angelegtes, dauerhaftes Camp. Hacker-Prep. Hacker-Prep.
Wir verstecken die ganzen Top-Hacker für den Fall, dass die Cyber-Katastrophe
über uns herüberbricht.
Aber bis dahin haben sie auf jeden Fall Netz und Strom. Das ist doch schon mal ganz gut.
Und deswegen direkt nach dem Kongress, weil dann kann man die direkt alle mit einpacken. Ja.
Wegen der Autarkie und der Apokalypse und so. Ja, nice. Ja, ich schau mich dann mal um hier.
Hier ist noch der USB Stick mit dem Previously.
Und euch jetzt viel Spaß bei der Sendung, ist ja gleich 8, ne?
Einen letzten Kommentar! Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein,
nein, nein, nein. Kommt da der S-Key? Warte, hast du kurz? 20 Sekunden.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Du kannst ja Kommentare machen, wir fahren aber schon in die Schleife an. Mach das!
So, Clemens jetzt vielleicht.
Noch eine Anmerkung? Hat er nicht. Okay, egal.
Er scheint sprachlos zu sein. Clemens ist sprachlos.
Wir notieren das kurz im ewigen Kalender der Freakshow.
Clemens sprachlos.
Aber Letti hat die Stimme noch nicht final verloren.
Nee, noch ist sie noch ein bisschen da.
Ja, hallo Letti.
Hallo.
Du bist ein bisschen krankerlich.
Ja, also falls ich irgendwann abklappe, das muss so.
Das Kind schielt nicht, das muss so kicken.
Was?
Egal, du hast ja ein Backup, nämlich Thala.
Genau. Ich bin jetzt dein Backup, nein.
Mit Daten kennt die sich aus.
Ja, das fällt mir aber gerade auf. Ich kann nicht hübsch.
Was?
Ich kann nicht hübsch.
Du kannst nicht hübsch.
Visualisierung meinst du wahrscheinlich.
Ich mach den funktionalen Teil und Letti macht den hübschen Teil.
Wie wäre das? Du bist meine Standardfreundin. Standardabweichung.
Aber du willst doch damit nicht sagen.
Dass Letti nicht funktional ist.
Letti ist extrem funktional. Nur vielleicht braucht sie gerade einen Backfix. In diesem Moment.
Ich glaube, wir sollten mit diesen Allegorien und Assoziationsketten schleunigst.
schlag ich es ein Ende finden.
Naja, anyway, auf jeden Fall schön, dass du da warst und bist.
Bist, bist.
Danke, dass du da warst.
Du kannst jetzt wieder gehen.
So funktioniert das mit dem Backup.
Kurzer Einsatz, aber wichtig.
Die Koten-Taler.
Ich wollte sagen, ich habe zwei Sätze zusammengeworfen.
Ich wollte nur kurz festhalten, ihr Beine wart ja auf dem Kongress. Das meinte ich.
Clemens war tanzen, stimmt's?
Ich war auf meinem Kongress.
Du warst auf deinem Kongress. Wie heißt die Veranstaltung nochmal gleich?
Snowball.
Weißt du noch aus dem Kopf, in welcher Freakshow wir uns mal so ausführlich
darüber unterhalten haben?
Ich hab mich sogar mal angerufen von der Party. Video. Das stimmt,
da waren wir auf dem Kongress.
Da wart ihr auf dem Kongress und habt da Show gemacht und ich war dann da auf
dem Partyfloor und hab dann da mit FaceTime oder sowas mal angerufen.
Worüber ich immer noch sehr neidisch bin, dass du aus dem Flieger hier angerufen
wurdest und als ich im Urlaub war, durfte ich nicht dazu geschalten werden.
Aber du, du hast aus dem, aus dem Singapur, als du nach Singapur geflogen bist,
warst du ein Flieger, ja.
Ja, aber das waren auch Beispiele dafür, warum das eine schlechte Idee ist.
Ich bin auch mal zugeschaltet worden, das war auch eine scheiß Idee.
Das ist einfach, das funktioniert so nicht. Ja, man muss sich einfach.
Zum Winken war ja nicht gedacht für eine Sendung.
Ja, man muss sich, ich finde beim Podcast muss man sich einfach tief in die Augen schauen können.
Verstehe Alles klar Können wir das jetzt mal auch hinschreiben so wie Clemens
ist wortlos beim Podcast muss man sich die T-Shirt anschauen können Schreiber
notiere dies Schreiber notiere dies Anyway.
Das ist die Freakshow Nummer 254 55 45 Ja Also diese ganzen,
Jubiläumsartigen Zahlen malen die Rasen auf uns zu.
Warte mal, welche Sendung ist?
2, 4, 5.
Ja, okay. 2, 4, 6 steht heute in dem Kalender und in allen weiteren Folgen im
Google-Kalender ebenfalls. Deswegen...
Sehe ich keinen Ernst. Doch, ernsthaft.
2, 4, 6, 2, 4, 6, 2, 4, 6.
Ja, aber die letzte war doch 2... Warte mal.
Ne, letzte war 2... Ich hab da wieder eine ausfallen lassen, weil da...
Weil so viele ausgefallen sind, aber ich dachte, ich hätte das schon längst korrigiert.
Oder hast du die letzte zur Sendung. Du hast doch eins zu eins das Workflow.
Du hast recht. Und ich ändere das sofort. Bevor das noch jemand merkt.
So, jetzt stimmt's.
Ja, 12.
Ach.
Da bin ich jetzt wieder aus der Spur. Also das ist auf jeden Fall die 254.
Nein, ihr müsst mich vorstellen.
Oder weiß ich nicht, keine Ahnung. Hast du mal einen Vorschlag?
Wir machen das jetzt hier schon fast seit Seit mehr als zehn Jahren,
aber wir haben immer noch kein Modell dafür gefunden.
Du bist halt so gut, dich selber vorzustellen.
Ich mache das aber immer nicht. Ich vergesse das immer.
Hallo Tim. Es ist schön, dich da zu haben.
Hallo Tim, es ist schön, dass du auch wieder in der Sendung bist,
dass du den weiten Weg in deine Meta-Ebene gefunden hast. Ach ja.
Ihr wisst die Strapazen zu schätzen, die ich da auf mich nehmen muss.
Durch Schnee und Eis.
Mindestens eine Straße dazwischen.
Das ist schon hart.
Normalerweise stelle ich mich ja immer vor. Also in den anderen Sendungen mache
ich das immer ganz automatisch. Aber hier ist es irgendwie anders. Ich weiß nicht warum.
Weil jedes Mal hast du irgendwelche anderen Gäste oder sonst was bei den anderen.
Du hast halt nicht das Gefühl, du müsstest dich uns gegenüber vorstellen.
Liegt das daran, dass es alleine anderen bis auf Logbuch vielleicht Interview-Konzepte sind?
Genau, bei Linus stellst du dich auch nicht vor.
Na ja, indirekt guten Morgen Linus, guten Morgen Tim, ist ja schon quasi eine
kleine Vorstellung, aber die anderen sind ja mehr so diese Interviewformate,
wo man jetzt sagen könnte, man weiß ja nie, ob jemand gerade erst zuschaltet,
dass das erste Mal hört oder durch Zufall hört, wo man mehr so einen formelleren Aspekt hat.
Also ich meine, formell kann man jetzt unsere Angelegenheit jetzt hier nicht sehen.
Wenn du in deinem Wohnzimmer Gäste hast,
dann stellst du dich den Gästen ja auch nicht vor. Das ist halt hier die Dynamik.
Das kann gut sein, ja. Davon hat es was.
Ja.
Ja, was machen wir da jetzt?
Also ich habe schon mal die Schuhe ausgezogen, weil im Wohnzimmer sollte man
ja nicht mit Straßenschuhen rumrennen.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Tee ist auch da.
Tee ist auch da.
Ja, also über euer Benehmen gibt es ja überhaupt keinerlei Auseinandersetzung.
Die Frage ist nur, sollte ich mich jetzt selber vorstellen oder solltet ihr mich vorstellen?
Ja, aber dieses... Mein Name ist Tim Pridler.
Das bringt's doch auch nicht.
Oder?
Nee, das passt ja eben nicht. Das ist ja genau das Dilemma.
Ja, aber wir können trotzdem sagen, dass du da bist.
Vielleicht bist du auch einfach die große Unbekannte, die Stimme aus dem Off.
Genau.
Also wahrscheinlich ist das ein bisschen anmaßend, aber ich fühl mich irgendwie so implizit.
Ja, gibt's denn Freakshows ohne dich?
Nee, gab's noch nie und wird's wahrscheinlich auch nie geben.
Doch, Mobile Max gab's einmal. Einmal hast du dich getraut, ne? vor meiner Zeit.
Nee, da hab ich angerufen.
Ach, da hast du angerufen?
Da hab ich angerufen.
So viel zum Thema direkt gegenüber und face to face.
Ja, das war ja auch eine scheiß Idee. Ich hab auch mal eine ganz alleine gemacht.
Ah, okay.
Weil keiner kam.
Also waren halt alle nicht da.
Ja gut, aber wenn es jetzt keine Freakshow ohne dich gibt, dann bist du die
Freakshow. Du bist das Inventar.
Wir könnten das ja auch mal, also ist ja nicht so, dass das der Tim nicht mitbekommen
würde, wenn ich die Freakshow ohne ihn machen würde.
Du hast ja den Fehler getan, um mir deinen Schlüssel zu geben.
Ja, aber nur für die Tür, nicht für die Server.
Fuck the Server.
Ich muss mir jetzt...
Du bist der Einzige, der einen Server betreiben kann, wo man Podcasts hinschmeißen kann?
Scheinbar brauche ich nur den Clemens, mir einen laden und das läuft.
Ach, du meinst, der routet dann auch meine ganzen Domains um.
Das ist der Einzige, dem ich das zutrauen würde. Nicht der Einzige,
aber einer von denen, dem ich das zutrauen würde. Na ja.
Hallo Tim, wie geht es dir?
Ungelöste Probleme, wie geht es mir?
Du hast Sauerteig am Chemisett.
Ich bin in der Tat mit Sauerteig überzogen,
weil ein Familienmitglied auf die Idee kam, man müsste doch jetzt mal den Sauerteig,
der da jetzt schon seit Tagen angesetzt wurde, dann auch final mal in ein Brot gießen.
Das ist natürlich unmittelbar vor dieser Sendung.
Und ich so, okay, alles klar, machen wir das halt. Und ich wusste nicht,
ja, es ist so schön, wer nie sein Brot im Bett aß, weiß nicht, wie Krümel pieksen.
Und wenn ich das auf Sauerteig übersetzen darf, ja, also, man klebt das Zeug
an allem. Also erstmal an den Fingern und dann an einem selbst.
Spätestens wenn man sich, wie man das so macht als gepflegter junger Mann,
die Hände an den Jeans abwischt. Und,
ja, die Erfahrung habe ich dann jetzt auch durch. War jetzt auch nicht so schlimm.
Mal gucken, vielleicht kommt ja sogar ein richtiges Brot bei raus.
Das war zumindest das Ziel der ganzen Aktion.
Das bäckt jetzt, während wir hier parlieren.
Ich gehe davon aus, ja.
Wer beobachtet das?
Andere Familienmitglieder.
Verstehe.
Das heißt, du kannst nächstes Mal berichten, wie das Brot geworden war.
Das könnte ich tun, ja. Aber du hast doch auch irgendwie vorhin erzählt,
du hast irgendwas mit Sauerteig gefilmt.
Nee, meine Mama hat einen Hermann. Oder hatte einen Hermann.
Einen Hermann?
Ja, einen Hermann.
Aber was ist denn ein Hermann?
Entweder ist es ein Hefeteig oder auch eine Art Sauerteig. Jedenfalls hat man
eine Anfangskultur, die aus irgendetwas besteht, der dann immer weiter zugefüttert wird.
Dann nimmt man irgendwie, wenn genug da ist, eine Hälfte ab und macht halt Brot draus.
Das ist ein Wikipedia-Eintrag dazu.
Das ist natürlich ein Wikipedia-Eintrag dazu.
Ja, macht man halt auch Brot draus. Also es ist sowas ähnliches wie ein Sauerteig.
Milchsäurebakterie. Das ist ein lebender Organismus.
Ja, genau.
Deswegen hat er doch einen Namen.
Hermann, auch Glückskuchen, Glücksbrot und Vatikanbrot genannt.
Das kannte ich nicht.
Also es ist ein Sauerteig.
Aha, aber aus Weizenmehl.
Ja, und dann füttert man halt immer so ein bisschen den an.
Und wenn man in den Urlaub fährt, es ist halt wie ein Haustier.
Das heißt, es gibt andere Leute,
die sich um diesen Hermann kümmern müssen und ihn am Leben erhalten.
Womit muss man den füttern?
Mehl. Mehl.
Einfach nur Mehl.
Ja, und ich glaube ein bisschen Zucker oder so.
Und das Viehzeug da drin, die Bakterien in den Hefen, machen den Rest.
Genau.
Aber deswegen musst du den dann auch irgendwann mal produzieren,
sonst hast du nämlich einen Hermann, der ist so groß wie dein Zimmer.
Deswegen musst du den halt immer wieder teilen und irgendwas draus backen und
so. Und mit der anderen Hälfte den fütterst du weiter.
Ist ähnlich so wie das Andreas Puck hat heute mal erzählt mit seiner weißen Hefe.
Die wird ja auch dann immer gefüttert und und dann nimmst du einen Teil davon
zum Brauen und den Rest fütterst du weiter, dass sie sozusagen weiterlebt und
sich weiter multipliziert.
Aber warum heißt denn das Ding so? Im deutschsprachigen Raum ist der Name Hermann
Teig spätestens seit den 70er Jahren bekannt.
Über die Ursprünge des Namens ist jedoch nichts Zuverlässiges bekannt.
Wenn man einen Etymologen brauchst, ja.
Okay.
Spannend, dass er als Kettenbrief weitergegeben wurde.
Ja, das ist wie so Tupperparty.
Man hat dann von Freunden Anzucht.
Meine Mutter hatte auch so ein Ding. Erinnere mich daran.
In der Schule. Also ich würde auch meinen, in der Schule gab es einige,
die das immer hatten und das dann hin und her geschenkt haben.
Also in der Schule gab es bei uns.
In der Schule warst du?
In einer komischen Schule in Ostdeutschland. Es war kein Dorf.
Es war immerhin ein Städtchen.
Okay. Aber das hatten viele irgendwie das, ich glaube das hatte mir auch irgendjemand
mal zum Geburtstag oder so dann geschenkt.
Meine Mutter war davon dann irgendwann sehr genervt, weil sie sich natürlich
immer drum kümmern musste.
Und so sonderlich gut hat der nicht geschmeckt, hatte ich in Erinnerung.
Ja, es gibt ja verschiedene davon. Wie mit diesen Brauereihäfen.
Du musst halt mal einen guten Hermann erwischen.
Ja, und was du dann halt auch sonst noch in das Brot rein machst. Also...
Ich bin auch nicht so ein Freund von, aber ich bin auch nicht so der Brotesser.
Ja, ich finde Brotbacken selber ja schon ziemlich geil. Das habe ich eine Zeit
lang ja schon sehr intensiv auch betrieben,
dass ich irgendwie relativ einfaches Dinkelweißbrot nur gebacken habe,
aber deswegen habe ich mir die Küchenmaschine gekauft, damit ich den Scheiß
nicht immer selber kneten muss.
Das war so der initiale Zünder, mir eine Knetmaschine zu kaufen,
weil ich irgendwie so zwei Kilo Brot dann einfach immer gebacken habe.
Den Incentive habe ich auch gespürt heute.
Ja, also genau. Ich weiß nicht, die meisten von euch werden ja so ein Handrührgerät
haben. Das probiert man genau einmal, dann ist das Ding kaputt.
Ja, genau.
Das habe ich auch gemacht, die Erfahrung. Nee, da braucht man Power.
Das muss anders gehen, ja genau.
Deswegen, ich bin mir nämlich nicht sicher, weil in dem Zusammenhang habe ich
die KitchenAid nämlich auch recherchiert.
Vielleicht haben wir, wir haben ja ganz viele Hörer, die auch so küchenaffin
sind wie wir. Vielleicht gibt es da mal ein paar Meinungen zu einer KitchenAid,
weil ich bin, aus meinem Freundeskreis habe ich nie was Positives über KitchenAid und Kneten gehört.
Ja, aber ich brauche nichts direkt zum Kneten. Also ich hatte jetzt während
des Kongresses die Freude mal mit so einer kleinen Küchenmaschine zu arbeiten,
weil ich so vierfache Menge von Standard Waffelteig gemacht habe,
was halt einfach irgendwie 500 Gramm Mehl, nochmal 300 Gramm Speisestärke und so weiter sind. Ähm,
Und ich war aber von der Bosch nicht so richtig überzeugt, weil sie nicht so
richtig gepasst hat, weil sie auch relativ klein war, weil sie nicht gut zu
reinigen war und pipapo.
Und wenn ich jetzt aber so eine Heavy-Duty-Kitchen-Aid, also nicht die kleinen,
sondern die etwas größeren angucke, dachte ich mir schon, diesen zumindest besser zu reinigen.
Vielleicht gleich so eine Industriemaschine, wenn wir schon dabei sind.
Nehmen sich auch nicht mehr so viel. Aber das Problem ist, ich bin halt alleine.
Und wenn ich mal backe... Ja, aber du weißt.
Wie unsere Haushalte mittlerweile vermischt sind.
Das stimmt, aber wir kriegen auch zu zweit oder in einer Freakshow keinen ganzen Kuchen weg.
Ansonsten kriege ich irgendwann wieder eins auf den Rüffel, weil alle um mich herum dezent zunehmen.
Also ich habe mir dieses Thema Küchenmaschine ist so eins von denen,
die mich total fertig machen. Wir haben ja das Thema hier schon mindestens,
zweimal tangiert. Und es ist halt dann immer so, dass danach immer wenn ich
den Fehler mache, dass ich so eine Äußerung mache wie,
ich könnte mir vorstellen oder mich interessiert das gerade oder was würde man
denn haben wollen? Also sozusagen so ein Anbahnungsgespräch.
Naja, also es gibt auf jeden Fall extrem viel Feedback.
Erst so in den Kommentaren, das ist ja auch alles total Also schon im Chat,
dann in den Kommentaren, dann werde ich wochenlang und monatelang drauf angesprochen
und irgendwann schlägt das dann über in, was ich mir denn jetzt eigentlich gekauft hätte,
wo ich dann immer nur sagen muss, also nicht immer, aber oft so.
Ich konnte zu keinem Ergebnis kommen. Es war für mich einfach nicht abschätzbar.
Es war zu unübersichtlich. Und vor allem, also die Kernfrage ist ja,
was will man eigentlich?
Weil wenn man sich dann so mit beschäftigt, dann, das ist ja generell eigentlich
bei Dingen und Geräten so, du entdeckst so eine neue Kategorie.
Und was macht man dann als erstes, wenn man diese Kategorie zur Kenntnis genommen
hat, dass das sozusagen gibt, dass es a thing ist?
Internet-Recherche.
Man nerdet sich dann erstmal sozusagen rein, Was gibt es denn da überhaupt?
Da muss doch noch was Geileres, Größeres, Rechtsunteres geben.
Und irgendwann hast du dann so das ganze Feld abgegrast und alle Optionen und
denkst dir immer so, geil, das geht auch noch und das geht auch noch und das geht auch noch.
Und dann bin ich dann irgendwann bei diesen Küchengeräten, die halt dann auch
selber kochen können, also darüber hatten wir ja auch eh schon gesprochen,
zum Beispiel dieses Kenwood Monstrum oder was Bosch so am Start hat und das sind dann so Apparate,
da habe ich mir dann so Küchenvideos auf YouTube angeguckt, wo dann irgendwelche
Goldelsen da stehen und mit so einer säuselnden Stimme die Vorzüge erzählen.
Ja, und diese Maschine hat mir schon viel Freude bereitet.
Und was auch sehr praktisch ist. Und meinen Kuchen mache ich immer so.
Und dann immer so, oh Gott, womit beschäftigt ihr euch den ganzen Tag?
Seid ihr nur am Essen die ganze Zeit?
Nee, nee, ich mache ja zwischendurch noch Videos für Nähmaschinen.
Hey.
Das sind dieselben.
Nein, nein, nein.
Meine Freundin hat sich neulich eine Nähmaschine, hat sich vorher die YouTube-Dinger da angeguckt.
Ja, aber nichts gemacht.
Aber nicht gemacht.
Nee, nicht gemacht.
Also die, die diese Videos machen, die sind ja da voll drin.
Und auf jeden Fall wusste ich dann irgendwann überhaupt nicht mehr,
brauche ich jetzt eigentlich überhaupt eine oder brauche ich einfach nur so
etwas, was mir das Rühren abnimmt und ich bin schon glücklich?
Oder muss es jetzt irgendwie all features on sein und ich muss mir nochmal drei
neue Küchenschränke installieren, um diese ganzen Zubehör da reinzubekommen?
Oder nochmal umziehen.
Das Chat fragt gerade, ob es eine Makita-Küchenmaschine gibt.
Das, was ich auch das erste Mal hatte, war, ich hatte auf dem Kongress eine
Makita-Bohrmaschine an Hand und bin dezenter begeistert.
Noch begeisterter als von einer Küchenmaschine.
Das ist ja auch auf jeden Fall klar, warum man das ist, direkt auf dieser Seite da gelandet.
Also ja, bei Küchenmaschinen tatsächlich ist mein Ansatz, auf die IFA zu gehen.
Wenn ich weiß, was ich grob will und brauche, gehe ich hin, die haben da so
viel Auswahl und dann gucke ich mir das Ding an,
hab es in Händen, probiere es teilweise aus und dann ist es halt zum einen schon
eingegrenzt in das, was ist tatsächlich irgendwie vor Ort verfügbar,
wo kann ich mir einen eigenen Eindruck machen.
Und wenn dir was zusagt, gehst du am letzten Tag hin und kaufst es für sehr wenig Geld.
Das haben schon die einen oder anderen halt auch gemacht. Also wenn die IFA
für eine Sache gut ist, dann Küchengeräte.
Kann man echt sich vieles anschauen. Ich glaube, das ist auch der einzige Grund,
warum ich nochmal hingehen würde.
Ich entdecke auch gerade einen ersten Aspekt, warum mich die IFA überhaupt mal
wieder interessieren könnte.
Da gab es auch ganz viele Staubsauger, Roboter.
Oh, das sollten wir vielleicht nochmal, kannst du nochmal das Video raussuchen von,
das ist ein bisschen off-topic, aber weil wir Saugrobotern sind hier,
iRobot hat unter anderem einen, nehmen wir es auch, Saugroboter entwickelt,
um invasive Arten aus dem Meer zu angeln.
Die Feuerfische, die ja so eine Pest sind im Atlantik mittlerweile,
was mal als Tierfisch wahrscheinlich in Florida irgendwie gelebt hat und dann ins Meer...
Im Ernst jetzt?
Genau.
Und Hala hat mir ein Video geschickt über invasive Arten und wie man sie mit
kreativen Lösungen wieder losbekommt.
Und iRobot hat halt in der Tat so einen... Saugroboter für die Feuerfische gemacht?
aber es war nicht der geilste von denen.
Also, Thala schmeißt es mal in, oder soll ich es nennen?
Ich hab's grad ins Workflow hier geschmissen und ich hab's dem Tim direkt geschickt.
Das ist halt ein Video über... Ist das nicht in Slack?
Nee, ist ein neuer Rechner. Ich muss es ja noch...
Du brauchst ja Memory noch für was anderes.
Mach das mal los, richte dir das mal ein.
Ja, aber nicht...
Warte, dann schmeiß ich den in Slack.
Und das ist halt im Prinzip die Spezies 2. Und das Problem bei Feuerfischen
ist halt, dass die relativ viel tief tauchen und dass die auch...
Die haben von nichts Angst, die haben keine Fressfeinde.
Richtig, richtig.
Genau, und iRobot war halt sehr kreativ.
Und das funktioniert oder ist das nur so ein Werbevideo von ihnen?
Nee, das ist von denen gar nicht, das ist noch nicht auf dem Markt.
Genau, ist noch nicht im Einsatz, sondern ist quasi in der Erprobung und das
ist so ein kleiner Tiefseeroboter, der schwimmt, denen einen kleinen Elektroschock
gibt, weil die halt nicht wegschwimmen.
Sondern so Aber wie erkennt er die denn? So mit AI und so?
Ja.
Ich glaube, die sind nicht so schwer zu erkennen.
Die Viecher.
Also wenn man dieses...
Also die machen dann im Prinzip Machine Learning auf den Fischen und wenn die
dann sehen, so hier, Feuerfisch.
Dann macht Blitz Dings.
Dann sind sie gestandt und dann macht Pfff und sie sind eingesammelt.
Oder ein Tourist mit Feuerfisch-Tattoo.
Ist bei der Tiefe glaube ich auch schwierig.
Wo schwimmen die so rum?
Tiefer als das, was man tauchen darf.
Feuerfisch.
Feuerfische.
Genau.
Das, was man tauchen darf?
Ja, ich glaube, dass es eine Tiefe ist, wo du aufgrund des Druckes nicht mehr klarkommen wirst.
Achso.
Also die gehen wohl richtig tief, die Fischchen. Genau, sorry,
das schmeckt mir auch gut.
Genau, das haben sie dann halt auch gesagt, dass sie halt gut schmecken,
also die, die man rausholt, kann man dann halt immer noch sinnvoll verbrauchen. Genau.
Dem ist dann also auch Tiefseesaugstaub Roboter auf der IFA,
um den Bogen zu schließen.
Genau. Aber das fand ich auf jeden Fall sehr lustig.
Aber das bringt mich gleich noch auf ein anderes, vollkommen unrelated Topic.
Du hattest Angst, wir hätten nicht genug Themen.
Hab ich immer.
Machst du das jetzt zum ersten Mal?
Ja. Ich bin noch neu hier. Ich bin der Neue.
Deswegen haben wir ihn dir vorgestellt.
Das ist Tim, der ist noch neu hier, der ist noch etwas schüchtern.
Na, ich hab das schon länger auf der Liste, aber man braucht ja auch mal einen
guten Grund, warum man irgendwas mal anspricht.
Aber jetzt, wo du jetzt gerade so mit diesem Saugroboter zur Weltrettung kommst,
habt ihr schon mal von dem Projekt The Ocean Cleanup gehört.
Habt ihr das irgendwie näher verfolgt? Wir haben auch dieses Internet.
Echt?
Da steht ja recht viel drin.
Das stimmt. Aber dir ist schon klar, dass wir tendenziell schon eine ähnliche Filterblase haben.
Ähnlich.
Das kommt jetzt sehr überraschend. Aber ich weiß ja nicht, wie intensiv du das verfolgst.
Sorry. Sorry for interrupting. Go ahead. Please.
Naja, auf jeden Fall, die Ocean Cleanup kann man ja vielleicht nochmal zusammenfassen,
für die Leute, die das nicht wissen, die sich außerhalb unserer Filterglase
befinden, die bestimmt alle hier gerade zuhören,
Ocean Cleanup ist so ein Projekt von so einem jungen Holländer,
wie hieß er nochmal gleich Moment, ich hab's gleich,
Bojan Slat Klassischer holländischer Name Ja, der hat irgendwie so ein...
der hat so ein, ich glaube so ein TED-Talk mal gehalten irgendwie als Kit und
hat dann so angekündigt, so hier,
Big Garbage Patch im Pazifik, die Ozeane ersticken in Plastik,
alles ganz schlimm und wir müssen jetzt hier mal was machen.
Was ich ja mal total super finde.
Er hat gebastelt, ist rausgefahren und ging nicht. Zunächst.
Er hatte eine Idee und das finde ich halt irgendwie ganz geil,
weil auch dann alle so meinten so, ja, hast du es noch alle und das funktioniert
ja nie und das hat dann eigentlich im Wesentlichen auch erstmal nicht so richtig funktioniert,
aber er hat es halt geschafft, da relativ viel Geld einzutreiben,
wenn ich das richtig mitbekommen habe und was sie da so gemacht haben, ist so eine Art,
Sammelwurst, also irgendwie so eine große Schwimmnudel, die sie da irgendwie in den Pazifik
schieben wollten, haben sie erstmal viel zu groß gebaut, so,
dass das irgendwie alles nicht handelbar und viel zu kompliziert war,
da haben sie es irgendwie kleiner gemacht, im Prinzip hat das wohl auch irgendwie
funktioniert, aber der Der Durchsatz war so, naja,
damit werden wir jetzt die Welt so schnell nicht gerettet bekommen.
Und jetzt aber vor kurzem haben sie dann so ganz Steve Jobs mäßig mal was vorgestellt,
was dann wiederum ganz cool ist.
Nämlich ein Projekt, was sie so parallel vorangetrieben haben.
Und jetzt muss ich kurz mal gucken, wie hieß das nochmal gleich?
der Gott,
Wie heißt denn das Scheißteil? Also sie haben im Prinzip ein autonomes Schiff gebaut.
Das, was sie in die...
In die Flüsse, genau. Also die Erkenntnis war sozusagen, wir brauchen der Interceptor.
Genau, der Interceptor. Den haben sie nämlich gebaut.
Und das finde ich irgendwie eine relativ coole Sache. Also erstmal,
sie haben sich intensiv mit dieser Problematik beschäftigt.
Sie haben verschiedene Lösungsansätze verfolgt, die waren nicht unbedingt alle
erfolgreich, aber sie haben sich auf jeden Fall intensiv damit beschäftigt,
sind damit natürlich auch mit allen möglichen Leuten in Kontakt gekommen und
irgendwann haben sie es mal anders gemacht.
Dann sind sie losgegangen und
haben geschaut, was kommt eigentlich rein in den Ozean und haben dann an,
sehr vielen, ich weiß nicht, ich glaube über 100 Flüssen, den größten Flüssen
der Welt, die so einerseits sehr groß waren oder generell im Verdacht standen,
relativ viel Plastik in diese Meere zu schieben.
Da haben sie dann Kameras an Brücken installiert, haben das irgendwie mit Machine
Learning Software bestückt, also
haben halt irgendwie ein Trainingsding gefahren, um Plastik zu erkennen.
Was jetzt, wenn man sich das mal so anschaut, was Machine Learning heute so
kann, so Plastikteile im Wasser erkennen, würde ich sagen, passt schon,
das kriegt man irgendwie hin, das kann man irgendwie gut trainieren und da kriegst
du dann irgendwie einen brauchbaren Score raus.
Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass da so sehr viele andere Sachen da entlang schwimmen
in so einem Fluss. Das ist auch nicht schlimm.
Wenn jetzt irgendwas Falsches erkannt wird.
Genau, also wenn da irgendwas ist, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass es da nicht hingehört, relativ gut.
Du musst also eigentlich nur zwischen Wellen, Booten, Menschen und everything
else unterscheiden. Nein. Und dann haben sie halt einfach gecountet und einfach
mal geguckt so, aha, okay.
Und dann haben sie, wenn ich mich jetzt richtig erinnere, sowas in der Größenordnung
wie die Top Ten Flüsse sind für 95 Prozent der Plastikeinleitungen oder Mülleinleitungen
generell in die Ozeane verantwortlich.
Also allein, was da so aus dem Yangtze irgendwie rauskommt, also wenn du den
abschaltest, dann hast du nur noch die Hälfte. Also wirklich krass.
Und das Hauptproblem ist Asien, nicht nur, aber vor allem Asien.
So, und dann hatten sie halt diese Daten und dann haben sie irgendwie gesagt,
okay, alles klar, vielleicht verhindern wir erstmal, dass noch mehr Scheiße
überhaupt hinkommt, weil könnte ja sein, dass es da viel einfacher ist,
weil du musst nicht auch so mehr rausfahren, so,
weil, was hilft dir das?
Also ein bisschen Ufer mit Strom rechts und links und so.
Genau, und was hilft dir das auch, wenn du so auf dem Ozean bist und sammelst
den Plastik ein, dann musst du den ja irgendwie wieder wegkriegen.
Das ist auch alles extrem energieaufwendig und gefährlich und teuer und was auch immer.
So kann man es jetzt unten aus dem Fluss rausholen, auf den Laster schmeißen,
er fährt ihn wieder hoch, schmeißt wieder in den Fluss.
Genau, so was könnte man machen. Kann man auch anders machen.
Und dann haben sie halt diesen Interceptor gebaut
und davon sind jetzt schon drei real im betrieb und motto kam das ist im prinzip
so eine art ja schiff so katamaran schiff was also auf zwei kufen einfach im
fahrwasser gehalten wird das ist also am land verteut,
auf der einen seite gibt so eine schwimmnudel die quasi das ganze plastik zumindest
von der einen seite des flusses zu diesem schiff vorne zum maul treibt der anderen seite ist natürlich
noch Platz, weil irgendwo müssen ja auch noch die anderen Schiffe vorbeifahren,
also sie müssen sich quasi eine gute Stelle,
suchen auf diesem Fluss vor der Mündung, wo sie möglichst viel abfangen können.
Naja, und dann wird das so auf die Front dieses Schiffes zugeleitet und dort ist so ein.
Gitterbestückte ähm,
Conveyor Belt, also so ein Fließband, wo einfach das Plastik aus dem Wasser
genommen wird, alles was nicht Zeug ist, das fließt da halt einfach durch Und
dann wird es so nach oben gefahren und landet hinten in Müllcontainern.
Und das ganze Schiff ist komplett ohne Besatzung, die haben da Software für
gemacht, das meldet sich irgendwie über Internet und sagt, hallo,
ich bin voll, kommt mal einer vorbei, holt mich mal ab und dann fährt da halt
so ein Typ mit so einem Boot hin,
holt sich den vollen Container, bringt den an Land und schiebt den leer wieder
rein und das Ding läuft 24-7 und macht die ganze Zeit leer.
Und sie holen, weiß ich nicht genau die Zahl, aber es war irgendwie eine verdammt,
hohe Zahl an Menge, die da rausgefischt wird.
Sowas finde ich geil. Einfach mal Problem analysieren, mal machen,
Kohle reinholen, was Gutes machen und nicht irgendwie hier geiles Produkt und
so kann ich euch besser hinters Licht führen, sondern einfach nur so ja hier
einmal Welt verbessern, zack, bumm.
Ich finde das ganz interessant, weil Clemens irgendwie meint,
ja dann wieder oben wieder rein.
Also das Problem ja auch von Materialien, die irgendwie nicht so richtig zu
recyceln sind oder nur bedingt zu recyceln sind.
Ich stehe halt ziemlich auf diese ganze Tiny-House-Bewegung.
Und ich meine, ich würde gerne so ein Ding haben.
Es gibt halt ein paar YouTube-Kanäle, die halt so verschiedene Sachen vorstellen.
Und unter anderem viele, die so ein Earthship-Home haben.
Und da ist halt auch, ich werfe da mal den Wikipedia-Artikel mit dazu rein,
da gehen sie halt auch an, da so Materialien mit einzubauen.
Das heißt, es ist halt zum einen Reifen.
Also das Grundkonstrukt ist aus Reifen.
Glas wird da halt irgendwie mit reingebaut. und viele haben dann halt auch Sachen,
was halt einfach Müll sonst wäre, mit in dieses Haus reingebaut,
sodass es halt nicht irgendwo verschmutzt wird, die Landschaft,
sondern dass es gebunden ist.
Und das finde ich auch ein echt interessantes Konzept, dass man in sein Haus
eigentlich schon so das, was man nicht mehr recyceln vielleicht kann,
irgendwie so einbindet, dass es halt aber nicht wieder zu einem Problem wird
an anderer Stelle. Das nur noch mal...
Noch mit am Rande. Ich weiß nicht, ob es in Europa so viele gibt.
Earthship. Darunter machen sie es nicht.
Ja, das Prinzip ist halt auch meistens so ein bisschen, finde ich,
wie so eine Hobbit-Höhle.
Also die legen halt auch sehr darauf her, dass du halt einen energieeffizienten
Kreislauf halt auch hast, aber Hobbit-Höhle halt, weil es halt hinten in der
Regel dunkel ist. Also das ist halt wie so ein, ja, wie eine Hobbit-Höhle.
Also, ganz ehrlich, ich finde das ja ganz charmant, dass wenn man sich jetzt
so eine Behausung da schaffen will und so eine Hobbit-Höhle,
was sicherlich jetzt nicht gerade Marktführer ist.
Nee, absolut nicht. Geht ja auch nicht überall, also man muss ja erstmal Land haben.
Ja, dass man das dann total öko macht und so weiter, aber es löst halt die Probleme nicht large scale.
Nee, nee, aber ich meine, besser irgendwie im Kleinen irgendwas zu versuchen,
als sich zu sagen, gut, schalte ich drauf.
Das Schöne ist, es geht ja beides. Man kann sowohl im Großen die Welt verbessern
als auch im Kleinen und jeder kann seinen Beitrag leisten und man muss nicht
auf aber, das ist ja gar nicht effizient oder aber,
das wäre viel effektiver, sondern einfach, man kann überall gleichzeitig ansetzen.
Das ist richtig.
Ist aber auch schön, einfach mal zu sehen, wenn Leute einfach mal Dinge machen.
Ich hatte das kurz getwittert, war jetzt bei meinem Kongress das da oben,
wie sie jetzt eigentlich immer so einmal im Jahr, jetzt nicht jedes Jahr,
weil letztes Jahr war ich dann woanders, aber, und die Schweden setzten das
einfach mal da oben in Stockholm,
wo wir hier in Berlin uns die Köppe drüber heiß diskutieren,
mal so Straßen ein bisschen weniger Platz machen,
Radwege dahin machen und so und so diverse andere Innenstadt Konzepte,
von denen wir da so träumen, was vielleicht in Kopenhagen oder Amsterdam schon
da ist, wo wir ja auch immer die Bilder dann sehen an unserer Filterblase, aber in Schweden da,
in Neumheim, das ist so der Stadtteil von stockholm da machen die das dann einfach mal,
Und ich habe da keine Leichen rumliegen sehen von irgendwelchen Leuten,
das zieht die dann einfach mal durch.
Die sind schon untergepflückt, weil es guter Humus ist.
Das könnte sein, ja. Aber ich will jetzt gar nicht auf die Details,
weil jeder weiß, wie ein Fahrradweg aussieht.
Okay, die haben jetzt auch schöne breite Fahrradwege und ein bisschen baulich
getrennt durch einen amtlichen Bordstein, also nicht bloß durch einen hingemalten
Radweg, sondern so einen hingebauten Radweg, so wie man sich das vorstellt.
Aber darum ging es mir jetzt gar nicht. Da ging es mir darum,
dass ich mir gedacht habe, guck mal, vielleicht hatten die ja auch ewig Diskussionen,
so wie wir, aber die sind einfach daran schon vorbei. Die haben das jetzt einfach mal gemacht.
Ich meine, es ist ja auch ein bisschen wie in Oslo mit dem Verkehr unter die
Stadt bringen, dass die Stadt wieder an sich für die Menschen da ist und nicht für die Autos.
In welcher Stadt waren das, wo die halt auch einfach mal als Testprojekt,
also es muss ja dann gar nicht permanent sein, sondern wir haben einfach als
Testprojekt über erst mal drei monate bestimmte straßenzüge gesperrt und haben
geguckt wie sich das ganze verändert haben halt auch viel so street war gemacht und leute aufgeklärt.
Große großflächig gesperrt haben sie müssen für den durchgangsverkehr ist diese
diese barcelona barcelona haben sie doch dieses dieses großblock konzept gemacht
hier da war jemand in barcelona sagen sie mal was zum zum wie nennen die das superblock superblock,
Hast du das angeguckt?
Geht das? Ich habe die nicht so richtig entdeckt, um ehrlich zu sein.
Also Pressefake?
Ne, die scheint es schon zu geben, aber ich habe dann irgendwie zu spät den
Incentive bekommen, das auch mal konkret zu suchen, weil ich dachte,
ich würde da mehr oder weniger rein geraten.
Das ist ja der Witz, dass du da nicht reingehst. Die leiten den Verkehr halt drum rum.
Ich bin ja mit zwei Rad unterwegs gewesen.
Ist egal, die leiten den Verkehr drum rum.
Ja, aber den Eindruck hatte ich irgendwie nicht. Also es gibt schon auch noch weiträumige Bereiche.
Also das mag eine gute Maßnahme sein, aber es ist noch nicht so,
dass sie wirklich die ganze Stadt erfasst hat. Also Barcelona hat schon noch andere Probleme.
Du hast da noch keine Meinung dazu.
Ich finde generell diesen Ansatz
von Entschleunigung und Einschränkung von Autoverkehr ganz sinnvoll.
Also ich denke, das ist auch das Einzige, was uns wirklich weiterbringt,
weil umso mehr Angebote du machst.
Und ich muss sagen, es lohnt sich. Ich gehöre ja nicht zu diesen Radikalinskis,
die jetzt meinen, jeder Autobesitzer gehört sofort an den Mast geschlagen,
ans Kreuz geschlagen, aber mir gefällt das immer in Stockholm,
gefällt mir das immer sehr.
Mir fällt es dann erst auf, nach ein paar Tagen, wenn ich da so durch die Gegend
laufe, dass die, dass so, oh guck mal, hier riecht es eigentlich gar nicht nach
Busdiesel oder so, guck mal, hier kann man einfach mal über die Straße gehen,
ohne platt gefahren zu werden oder so.
Also, weil man da rechnet man jetzt nicht mit, ist nämlich echt krass Innenstadt
dort, ist wirklich dort in Laufweite vom Zentrum des Zentrums da und wo es halt
uns hier in Berlin oder so was, könnte es da nicht einfach,
klar kann man hier auch über die Straße gehen, aber es ist halt,
wir wissen alle, wie das aussieht.
Der Krieg tobt und den Busdiesel hast du auch noch in der Nase und das fällt
mir dann immer dort auf, dass das echt ein lebenswerter Faktor dort ist.
War mir so in der Theorie nicht so klar, aber wenn man dann da durch die Straßen
läuft, finde ich das, ah, guck mal, schön.
Ja, also ich denke, so ein Umbau und so moderne Konzepte für Habitate,
das ist so ein bisschen die Zukunft.
Und zwischendurch müssen wir uns halt noch darüber Gedanken machen,
wie wir den vierten Weltkrieg, dritten Weltkrieg verhindern.
Ist ja erstmal der dritte, ne?
Und dann müssen wir mal gucken, dass wir die nächsten Buschfeuer überleben.
Genau. Und überhaupt, das ist alles ganz schön schwierig.
Aber wenn wir mal optimistisch davon ausgehen, dass wir es schon noch irgendwie
20 Jahre schaffen, dann lohnt es sich ja auch noch, über ein paar Konzepte nachzudenken.
Auch für 20.
Du denkst nicht, dass wir noch 20 Jahre schaffen?
Ich bin absoluter Pessimist. Mich gibt es nicht in optimistisch.
Mein Kompromiss ist realistisch.
Und also selbst wenn du es 20 Jahre noch schaffst, es werden sicherlich nicht
alle 20 Jahre noch schaffen.
Aus verschiedensten Gründen.
Go on.
Nee, ist zu deprimierend. Wieso?
Wie du das machst, Letti, obwohl dein Mikrofon meilenweit weg ist.
Oh, Entschuldigung.
Das ist schon okay.
Dafür gibt es die Rolls-Bart-Taste.
Du wärderst auf deine Art. Du gnoopst auf deine Art.
Ich mute jetzt einfach die Letti.
Wenn ich mal ganz kurz da unterbrechen kann. Sie hat eben so mit so allem Papier
rumgerascht. Du hast doch immer aus irgendwelchen Hörergeschenk-Paketen für
NSFW irgendwie Schokoladen oder sowas.
Die Zeiten von NSFW-Hörergeschenkpaketen sind vorbei.
Ich habe ein einziges noch liegen oben in der Kiste, wo NSFW 100 draufsteht.
Na gut, das will ich dir nicht wegfressen.
Für den unwahrscheinlichen Fall.
Hast du keine Weihnachtsschokolade hier gekriegt?
Keine Schokolade für Clemens.
Schokolade hier rumliegen zu
lassen ist gefährlich, weil dann isst man die auf und dann wird man dick.
Verstehe. Okay.
Muss ich dann meine Süßigkeiten das nächste Mal wieder mit ankern?
Ich hab einmal den Fehler gemacht und hier Schokokekse liegen zu lassen und
Tim meinte, ja, ja, die sind beim nächsten Mal noch da.
Das wirst du mir ewig nachtragen. Außerdem hab ich das überhaupt nicht versprochen.
Doch.
Was?
Doch. Ich hab noch was Gesundes.
Nee, ich will dein Essen nicht wegessen. Ich hatte jetzt wegen deines Alu-Geknuspers,
da hatte ich jetzt gerade einen kurzen Jibber auf Schokolade.
Nein, nein, don't worry about it. Das ist gut.
Kurzer Nachtrag, weil es auch im Chat kam, fiel mir da in dem Moment auch wieder
ein, dass ja dieses Superblock-Konzept auch in Berlin ausprobiert werden soll.
Jetzt hier im Bergmann-Kiez in Kreuzberg.
Ich dachte, das ist ausprobiert worden. Und jetzt haben sie es wieder zurückgebaut.
Nee, sie haben was anderes zurückgebaut.
Ach, diese komischen, diese Parkinsel-Vollstoff-Inseln dort.
Die sie da gebaut haben, die haben sie jetzt wieder abgerupft.
Weil es so gut funktioniert hat.
Was ist diese temporäre Umwidmung von Parkfläche in was? Rumsitzfläche?
Also genau, du hast halt in der, es war nicht immer zugeordnet,
also du konntest einfach sitzen draußen, hast Bänke gehabt und die waren aber,
glaube ich, soweit ich weiß, auch nicht zu den Geschäften zugeordnet,
sondern es waren einfach freie Sitzbänke.
Also sie haben jetzt nicht mehr Office- oder Ladenspace gebaut,
sondern die haben sozusagen, wir stellen mal wieder eine Bank auf die Straße.
Genau. Und das konntest du halt benutzen und das haben sie aber rückgängig gemacht
und stattdessen haben sie wieder irgendwelche Steine hingelegt,
weil es ist ja jetzt vorbei die Phase.
War wahrscheinlich nur eine Testphase.
War es wahrscheinlich. Also Michi könnte da mehr zu erzählen,
weil wir hatten uns darüber unterhalten.
Ist auch mehr ihr Kiez.
Ja, ist ihr Kiez.
Ja, was ja auch ausprobiert wird, um vielleicht die Weltrettung doch noch irgendwie
einzuleiten, ist ja eine neue Fabrik, die hier vor den Toren Berlins gebaut werden soll.
ich hab mir das mal hab mir das mal angeschaut im Sinne von von oben angeschaut bist.
Du mit deiner 3D-Maus hingeflogen?
Mit meiner 3D-Maus da mal hingeflogen und mittlerweile gibt es auch ein paar
interessante Twitter-Accounts die die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Pläne,
posten und teilweise geht das ja dann auch durch die Presse und das ist schon
irgendwie da geht es mal richtig zur Sache, also ich glaube Elon Musk,
also für die Leute die nicht wissen wovon ich rede jede Gigafactory 4,
die vierte große Automobilproduktionsfabrik von Tesla,
soll jetzt nach Berlin kommen und bisher sieht auch alles danach aus,
als ob das tatsächlich stattfinden wird.
Offensichtlich haben sie aus irgendwas gelernt.
Die Rechnung noch nicht mit Berlin-Brandenburger Behörden gemacht.
Ich würde mal meinen, es könnte auch bedeuten, dass die Kinder hier so gebrannt sind,
dass sie jetzt alles dafür tun dass das nie wieder passiert,
weil ich meine dieses BER-Embarrassment das ist ja es ist ja World News also
ich meine Berlin ist so dermaßen dafür bekannt,
der große Planungsfehler zu sein das muss schmerzhaft wenn ich mir vorstelle,
ich wäre offizieller Vertreter dieser dieser Region,
und im Ausland würden mich alle jahrelang, acht Jahre geht das jetzt, ne?
Ich werde seit Jahren, jedes Mal bei jedem ITF-Meeting werde ich angegrinst
von irgendwelchen Leuten sagen, na, wie bist du hergekommen? Über den Berg geflogen?
Das hat jetzt schon ziemlich langen Bart, aber das kriege ich jedes Mal zu hören.
Wann sollte das Ding eröffnen? 13? 12?
Sechs Jahre.
Wir sind jetzt bei 20.
Zwölf sollte es sein.
Sieben, zwölf, sieben, acht Jahre.
Aber war zwölf nicht schon ein verschobener Termin sogar?
Ja, kann auch sein. Egal, jedenfalls.
Es ist auf jeden verlächerlich unendlich.
Übrigens, nur so nebenbei, wo du jetzt Gigafactory saßt, hast du Elon Musk über
den Bildschirm tanzen sehen?
Der hat sich ja den Steve Baumer gemacht, gestern.
Und ist da auch wie so ein von der Taranto gestochener da über die Bühne von
seiner Gigafactory 3 in China gehoppelt.
Und die Chinesen haben ordentlich vorgelegt. Die haben das Ding in einem Jahr gebaut und angeknipst.
Ich glaube nicht, weniger als ein Jahr.
Ich glaube nicht, dass Tesla auch nur lächerlich ohne Ende.
von irgendeiner Furzbehörde in Brandenburg kriegt für sein komisches Projekt
innerhalb eines Jahres, geschweige denn Fabrik.
Ja, das wird jetzt spannend, das zu sehen. Tatsächlich sind sie aber jetzt schon in Action.
Also die wollen jetzt bis Ende Februar den Wald weggehauen haben.
Ich hatte damit mich ganz am Rande zu tun.
Und die haben jetzt aber noch keinen Käfer gefunden, den finden sie dann?
Den finden sie dann, na klar.
Nee, die werden da glaube ich keinen Käfer finden.
Die werden tausende andere Gründe finden. Oder wir werden sagen,
wir brauchen hier ein bisschen Internet, um diese Fabrik zu versorgen. Tja, Alter.
Dann kommt die Telekom und sagt, ach, das reicht.
Nee, dann komme ich mit meinem Richtfunkstreif vom Alex. Ist das jetzt theoretisch.
Oder? Darf ich nicht sagen.
Seriously.
Du hast auch noch gar nichts gesagt. Also fast nichts.
Ich bin.
Ja, aber da entwickeln sich noch Dinge.
Okay, dann weißt du wahrscheinlich, wie groß das ist. Die Damen,
soll ich das irgendwie mal vergegenwärtigen? Also ich habe das mal verglichen.
Machst du es mal uns auf die... Ich bin schon dabei. Super.
Also das Ganze ist ja, wie heißt der Ort? Grün-Heide. Und Grün-Heide bei Berlin.
Also das ist wirklich direkt hinter den Toren Berlins.
Direkt am Ring.
Erkner, das ist so nach Osten raus,
so leicht etwas südöstlich und da beginnt dann eben die Gemeinde Grünheide und
zu der gehört relativ viel Wald, ein paar Häuser und ein Gewerbegebiet.
Und ein großer Teil, der da heute noch Wald ist, ist auch schon lange als Gewerbegebiet
ausgewiesen, auch wenn da jetzt noch Bäume drauf wachsen.
Aber das ist halt so, wie man so schön sagt, minderwertiger Wald.
Sprich, das sind einfach nur Fichten, Kiefernwald und nicht viel Biodiversität,
also irgendwas total durchgeforstetes.
Ja, der klassische Stangenwald.
Der klassische Stangenwald, den man sowieso eigentlich mal anders organisieren
sollte. Naja, auf jeden Fall gibt es dann diese...
Dieses Gewerbegebiet, an das sich nördlich eben so ein größerer Wald anschließt
und das ist dann so im Süden davon quasi die linke untere Ecke dieser ganzen
Fläche ist eine Autobahnausfahrt,
also es liegt direkt an der A10, ist schon mal ganz praktisch.
Und an der linken oberen Ecke hat man dann den Stich von der verlängerten S-Bahn Richtung Erkner,
also quasi die Bahnlinie, wo eben die S-Bahn bis Erkner fährt und dann geht es ja da noch weiter.
Das führt dann eben sozusagen direkt dahin und ist die nördliche Begrenzung
dieser Fläche und dann gibt es tatsächlich dann auch schon eine,
ich weiß gar nicht, ob die jetzt auch schon richtig in Betrieb ist,
auf jeden Fall gibt es halt diese Bahnlinie, die eben direkt in dieses Gewerbegebiet einmündet.
Also ich vermute mal, da ist jetzt schon irgendein Verkehr, ich weiß gar nicht,
wer da jetzt schon sitzt, da sind halt ein paar Unternehmen.
Naja, und diese Riesenfläche, die dadurch eingeschlossen wird,
da soll halt erstmal der erste Teil dieser Gigafactory hin, so direkt an die Autobahn quasi.
Und das ist schon irgendwie mal eine ganz ordentliche Strecke.
Ich habe es nicht genau nachgemessen, kann ich nochmal kurz machen.
Also das ist ungefähr, ja genau zwei Kilometer.
Also da kommt so ein Gebäude hin, was zwei Kilometer lang ist.
Und das ist schon eine Ansage.
Also das tatsächliche Gebäude wird ein bisschen kürzer sein,
sagen wir mal anderthalb Kilometer, aber sowas in der Größenordnung.
Weil da unten hast du dann noch Parkplätze und was weiß ich,
ein Pool für Löschwasser und so eine Geschichten. Und oben auch nochmal Parkplätze
und dann bauen sie da noch einen Bahnhof hin und all dieser ganze Gedöns.
Aber das eigentliche Gebäude ist schon mega groß.
Und das ist tatsächlich so groß und so lang wie das Volkswagen-Werk in Wolfsburg.
Ich habe das mal so verglichen und es läuft irgendwie auf dieselben Dimensionen hinaus.
Das ist schon echt massiv. Und vor allem, wenn sie das dann bauen,
also davon bauen sie jetzt im ersten Schritt erstmal die Hälfte und dann weiß
ich nicht, wann sie fertig sein wollen mit dem gesamten Gebäude,
aber es soll alles relativ schnell gehen.
Dann steht es da und dann haben sie quasi rechts daneben nochmal dieselbe Fläche
nochmal für ein zweites Gebäude.
Also es verdoppelt sich dann quasi nochmal. mal, dann wäre das irgendwie größer als VW.
Die brauchen auch noch Außenflächen, wenn ihr den Wolfsburg anguckt,
die haben ja Riesenflächen, wo sie die komischen Autos dann hin platzieren und all so Zeugs.
Ja, wobei ich glaube, die setzen da drauf, dass sie nicht so viele da rumstehen
lassen, sondern Direct Order und zack und ruff auf die Bahn und dann wird das
gleich irgendwo hin verschifft.
Auf die Bahn.
Genau. Und as we speak laufen da jetzt irgendwie gerade Leute durch den Wald
und sind schon dabei, die Ameisen zu verfrachten und andere Geschichten zu machen,
damit sie da demnächst alles roden können. Weil sie müssen jetzt irgendwie bis zum 27.
Februar müssen sie damit durch sein mit der Rodung.
Weil sonst ist es wieder Brutzeit und bla bla.
Genau, Vögel und so weiter, dann darfst du halt keine Bäume mehr fällen.
Und das Lustige ist, es liegen auch glaube ich gerade die Unterlagen aus und
Widerspruchsfrist ist so wie bis Anfang März.
Das ist dann so wie hier in Berlin mit der alten Melzerei.
Keine Ahnung, was ist damit? Was ist das?
Die wurde ja auch abgerissen, obwohl sie nicht abgerissen werden durfte.
Alte Melzerei.
Pufendorfstraße.
Also, dass dieser Wald da gefällt werden darf, das ist relativ klar.
Wenn sie ja vor allem schon als Gewerbefläche ausgewiesen war.
Das ist quasi Gewerbefläche, wo Bäume wachsen, aber das ist halt alles nur so
schnoddriger Kiefernwald, den keiner haben will.
Das wird halt irgendwie abgeholzt, so Ikea-Möbeln verarbeitet und fertig.
Und außerdem haben sie ja blumig versprochen, dass jetzt irgendwie die dreifache
Menge an Bäumen dafür neu gepflanzt wird. Wie schön.
Da wird Laminat draus gemacht bei uns in der Gegend.
Laminat?
Ja. Ja, wir haben jetzt, es gibt so bestimmte Straßen und zwar gibt es irgendwie
was oben an der Autobahn, noch ein Stückchen hinter Neuruppin oben oder noch
ein bisschen weiter nördlich,
da ist so ein Laminatwerk und seitdem die aufgemacht haben vor einiger Zeit,
vor ein paar Jahren oder so was, scheppern bei uns oben durch den Landkreis
täglich Dutzende, wenn nicht Hunderte von polnischen Baum-LKWs,
die aus der ganzen Gegend dort Bäume ranschaffen.
und zwar andauernd, kannst du ja wenn du in Rheinsberg zum Beispiel dich da
auf den Platz stellst vorne oder dann, da fahren die nämlich immer alle durch,
oder auch die anderen Städte da oben in der Gegend, durch Neuruppin scheppern
die auch durch und so und da ist irgendjemand saugt da, ist so ein schwarzes
Loch für Baum, ist dann so eine Fabrik mit Baum rein, Laminat raus.
Also da geht auf.
Jeden Fall was Die haben gar keine Zeit dazu Ikea zu bringen das ist gleich,
kommt gleich als Laminat wieder raus. Verstehe ja.
Ja, also mal gucken.
Dann können sie ihre Reifen ja auch gleich von Gegend gucken.
Keine Sorge, den Justizian in Ingolstadt, München und Stuttgart,
Sindelfingen wird schon noch Tipps einfallen für die Brandenburger Behörden,
worauf man das nicht gut finden soll.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob sie das nicht vielleicht sogar Also es gibt sicher die
ein, zwei Aspekte, die sie so ein bisschen scheiße finden.
Also wenn du gerade mal anguckst, wie VW hier händeringend Berlin plakatiert
mit dem Hinweis, dass ja der Weg mit dem ICE nach Wolfsburg gar nicht so weit
wäre und ob man sich denn nicht mal erwärmen könnte, bei denen zu arbeiten.
Das ist richtig krass. Weiß ich nicht, IT, glaube ich, suchen sie auch?
Die haben sich hier eine riesen Hütte gekauft.
Alles, glaube ich, suchen die.
Ich darf jetzt nicht laut sagen, wo, aber direkt in Mitte, Mitte,
Mitte hat sich VW eine riesengroße Hütte geklickt, mit mehreren Etagen,
die sie mit ihren IT-Töchtern vollgestopft haben. Könnt ihr mal selber recherchieren.
Aber die Leute dann doch nicht mit dem ICE fahren wollten, der Bahn Wolfsburg.
Du kriegst die Hipster nicht weggeworben aus Berlin, wenn du sagst,
jeden Tag anderthalb Stunden Bahn fahren geht nicht.
Ey, da musst du nicht mehr nach Wolfsburg. Es reicht schon, wenn du in Berlin
irgendwie länger unterwegs bist, da kriegst du ja die Krise.
Oder nach Potsdam raus musst. Das ist ja...
Oder Adlershof Unmenschlich Das ist so Oder nach Buch raus Das ist der Aspekt, den ich sehe Also,
die Pläne, die da ausliegen, die sind irgendwie von diesem Gigafactory4 Twitter-Account,
der die ganze Zeit da irgendwie rumläuft, im Wald und Fotos schießt und der
hat sich dann auch diese ausliegenden Unterlagen angeschaut und durfte die auch
alle fotografieren und twittern,
Ja und da ist Gestern, ja, das sind so richtig, ich weiß nicht,
was sie konkret motiviert, aber ich finde es ganz informativ.
Auf jeden Fall kamen da halt so Sachen raus wie, ja, wir haben da irgendwie
so ein Vierschichtensystem und 4000 Leute pro Schicht.
Also da wird schon richtig Personal an den Start gehen.
Und das wird natürlich diesen Automobilmarkt, also diesen Automobilproduktionsmarkt,
ordentlich unter Druck setzen, die Nachfrage.
Ja, weil sie halt eben auch Nasen einsammeln. Wer jetzt da arbeitet,
fährt nur erst recht nicht mehr nach Wolfsburg oder nach Ingolstadt zum Arbeiten.
Ich meine, man muss ja mal auch sagen, für was ist es denn gerade cooler zu arbeiten?
Für VW, die irgendwie Abgasmanipulation betrieben haben?
Oder sich irgendwie mit Tesla irgendwie zu rühmen, weil ich glaube für viele
ist Tesla schon nochmal der innovativere Arbeitgeber am Ende.
Ja gut, aber auf der anderen Seite, also das auf jeden Fall,
das mag für manche eine Argumentation sein.
Andererseits geht natürlich auch derzeit keiner der deutschen Hersteller so
krass auf Elektro ab wie VW.
Also den Turnaround haben sie ja jetzt schon halbwegs hinbekommen und es ist
klar, dass du da natürlich eine ganz andere Beschäftigungskultur noch hast in
so einem deutschen Konzern,
was so Planungssicherheit etc.
betrifft. Während halt Tesla sich natürlich letzten Endes auch deutschen Gesetzen unterwerfen muss,
aber wahrscheinlich sehr viel mehr mit so einer Higher-Fire-Attitüde unterwegs
ist, wie sich das dann hier konkret bahnbricht, das muss man dann nochmal sehen.
Die haben auch noch keinen deutschen Betriebsrat gesehen.
Viele Leute werden das auf jeden Fall ganz interessant finden und insbesondere
natürlich diese super innovativen, die wirklich die Herausforderung suchen.
Naja, so ist das nun mal hier in Berlin-Brandenburg. Hier wird die Zukunft gebaut.
Ich fand das sehr interessant, wie einige deutsche Medien darüber berichtet
haben, dass sich Tesla neben Berlin niederlässt und man hätte doch mal irgendwo
in einen anderen abgelegeneren Teil gehen können.
Da frage ich mich immer so, ja na klar könnte man das machen,
aber du willst ja auch Arbeitskräfte haben und ich meine, wenn Leute sich schon
nicht gewillt fühlen bis nach Wolfsburg in den ICE zu setzen,
wie viele Leute sind gewillt?
irgendwo an den Arsch der Heide zu fahren oder zu ziehen, wenn da nichts ist, außer die Arbeit.
Was die Gigafactory heißt jetzt.
Ja genau, die haben halt irgendwie gemeint, die hätte man ja auch in der Uckermark machen können oder so.
Ich glaube es war die Uckermark oder irgendwo in Brandenburg,
wo einfach sehr, sehr wenig ist.
Aber ich finde das immer so ein bisschen unrealistisch, auch als rein vom,
wenn ich die Person bin, die da rein investieren würde, dann würde ich mir ja
auch etwas suchen, wo ich meinen Arbeitnehmern irgendwas bieten kann.
Und nah an Berlin, ich meine ein kulturelles Angebot hast du da ja natürlich
noch in Löcher, bist du natürlich irgendwo, wo du sagst, ja hier kommen die
Leute auch wirklich hin, wenn sie für mich arbeiten wollen.
Ja, und sie ziehen natürlich auch genauso aus. Es mag ja auch Leute geben,
die sagen, da ist ja viel Platz, da Grünheide, da baue ich mir mal ein Haus.
Passt auch schon so, aber wenn ich unbedingt jetzt im Berliner Jet Set verhaftet
bleiben möchte, dann geht es halt auch.
Dann bin ich da mit der S-Bahn oder wahrscheinlich wird es dann wahrscheinlich
direkt einen Regionalexpress geben, der da direkt.
Mit deinem Model Y natürlich, wenn du da arbeitest. Oder halt mit dem Model 3.
Mit dem Y.
Ich habe das Ding noch gar nicht gesehen, angeblich bauen sie das ja in China,
da an der Gigafactory 3, aber ich habe das noch gar nicht live gesehen, oh mal so ein Ding.
Ja, wollen sie jetzt auch ausliefern, haben sie jetzt angekündigt,
aber sie haben jetzt erstmal die ersten Model 3s rausgeschoben,
die da sozusagen gebaut worden sind.
Ja, ja. Und irgendwann bauen sie vielleicht auch mal ein Fahrzeug,
was man bezahlen kann und was in der Lage ist, einen Wohnwagen zu ziehen.
Gibt es nicht für das Model 3 auch eine Anerherkupplung inzwischen?
Das Model X wäre das Wohnwagen mobil.
Bezahlbar. Also für mich bezahlbar.
Tja.
Ich habe gerade mal gebraucht, ich habe mal einfach nur mal so mobile.de,
Model X, was kriegt man denn da so?
Kannst du vergessen.
Kannst du komplett vergessen.
Die ganzen Tesla-Dinger haben relativ wenig Wertverlust. Wobei mir nicht ganz
klar ist, warum. Aber die fahren wie Sau.
Hält ewig. Ist nach wie vor cool. Und gerade die teuren Dinger haben immer noch
diese Supercharger-Optionen, die du ja mitverkaufst.
Und das ist einfach hochgradig attraktiv.
Also so ein 100er Model X habe ich nicht unter 80.000 gesehen. sehen.
Sie haben ja da unterschiedliche Ausbaustufen, das kann ich jetzt nicht einschätzen,
was das dann im Einzelnen gekauft hat, aber das wird noch ein bisschen dauern, bis Teslas...
Die müssen noch mehr raushauen, dass der Gebrauchtwagenmarkt ein bisschen mehr
saturiert wird, dass die Preise da nicht anpassen.
Ja, aber das ist natürlich auch ein extrem guter Grund, sich einen Tesla neu zu kaufen.
Ja, derzeit vielleicht noch.
Ja, also das ist quasi das, wovon du ausgehen kannst.
Wenn du dir heute einen neu kaufst, dann wirst du den in zwei Jahren nicht mit
diesem Mega-Abschlag verkaufen müssen, wie das eben bei anderen gebraucht worden ist.
Also wenn ich jetzt hier irgendeinen Verbrenner nehme, den zwei Jahre durch
die Gegend gurke, dann kriege ich nicht 80% des Preises dafür.
Während ihr euch hier gerade über Autopreise unterhaltet, haben wir Urlaub klar
gemacht und ich habe meinen Zugang zum Meta-Ebene-Slack wieder hergestellt. Auf neuem Rechner.
Erzähl doch mal von deinem neuen Rechner.
Erzähl doch mal von dem Urlaub.
Lala hat einen Mac.
Er wurde assimiliert.
Back to Mac.
Ja, ich habe ausreichend genörgelt, weil es mir auf die Ketten ging,
dass ich sie nie erreichen konnte, wenn ich bei meiner Mutter ohne meinen Rechner
bin, weil Adium nur auf dem Rechner läuft und sie keinen iMessage hat auf dem Rechner.
Ja, nein. Es begab sich eines schönen Tages,
Anfang Dezember, dass wir Forschungsarbeit AG Retreat an der Ostseeküste in
einem christlichen Jugendland heimgemacht haben, in dem es kein WLAN und ein Funkloch gibt.
und aus irgendwelchen Gründen hat sich mein lieber, kleiner geschätzter Razor
dazu entschieden, sein Ableben zu verkünden. Das heißt, ich war dann da.
Ich würde sagen, es war das richtige Jugendheim.
Ohne Internet ist der verhungert.
Ja, klar. Und da es mich so extrem genervt hat, dass man keine Ersatzteile für das Ding bekommt,
weil er war quasi genau drei Jahre alt, was nicht alt ist für einen Laptop,
selbst wenn ich ihn täglich mehrere Stunden nutze und mit mir rumschleppe,
ist halt ein...
Drei Jahre und es gab keine Ersatzteile dafür?
Ich hätte ihn jetzt einschicken müssen. Also ich habe ja schon Probleme gehabt,
irgendwie als einen Monat vorher die Batterie schon wieder nach einem Jahr ein
Ableben verkündet hatte oder sich gebläht hatte.
Das war ja schon schwierig, eine neue Batterie zu kriegen. Und ich habe keine
Originalbatterie bekommen, weil die halt ihre Ersatzteile nicht vertreiben.
Es gibt keine irgendwie wie bei Mac Gravis, wo ich den einfach in Reparatur
geben muss, sondern ist nur Vertragshändler. Das heißt, es muss über Razer gehen.
Und ich hätte den jetzt quasi wieder einschicken müssen. Und ich habe kurz recherchiert,
ja irgendwie Motherboard wechseln, 850 Euro haben Leute geschrieben.
Und da dachte ich mir so, nee.
Dafür, dass ich auch nicht weiß.
Ob er gleich wieder abstürzt.
Ja, also vor allem, ob er wiederkommt und wie lange es dauert.
Weil als ich letztes Jahr die Batterie getauscht habe,
hat sich das halt auch insgesamt zwei Monate gezogen mit hin und her,
weil die haben halt noch nicht so viele, so viele anscheinend,
also die mussten selbst erstmal gucken, wo der jetzt eigentlich hin muss und
die hatten noch nicht so die Fälle und Routine.
Was ist denn das überhaupt für eine Bude? Ich hab das noch nie gehört.
Das ist halt eine Gaming-Bude.
Ach so, so eine Gamer-Bude. Die machen primär Mäuse, Tastaturen.
Am Anfang, jetzt machen sie Laptop, Handy, inzwischen haben sie auch einen Router
angekündigt, einen WLAN-Router für ordentliches Internet-Streaming.
Aber ja, ich trauere ihm sehr hinterher und mal gucken, was da noch passiert.
Er liegt noch mit offenen Eingeweiden bei mir zu Hause rum.
Aber ich brauchte halt akut einen Laptop, weil ohne Laptop funktioniere ich nicht.
Und es hat sich glücklicherweise ergeben, dass ein Bekannter einen gebrauchten Mac abzugeben hatte.
Und jetzt habe ich halt einen 2016er 11 Zoll Mac.
Zwölf.
Zwölf?
Ja, das ist zwölf. Okay.
Wenn ich irgendwelche Zölle unterschlage.
Er ist ein bisschen kleiner als der Razer, aber nicht viel.
Und ich bin jetzt quasi wieder dabei, mich neu an Mac OS Catalina zu gewöhnen,
weil ich irgendwie bei Schneeleo damals auch ausgestiegen bin. Und Schneeleo war toll.
Ja.
Und da kam irgendwie Mountain Man und das war furchtbar.
Kann mich gar nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Ja. Damals. Und ja, jetzt bin ich halt dabei, einfach dieses Endgerät zu evaluieren und zu gucken.
Und tatsächlich, eins der Probleme ist irgendwie Passwortmanager.
Ich meine, wenn man halt nebenbei noch weiter Windows-Geräte hat,
braucht man irgendwie zuverlässige Passwortmanager, die auf beiden Plattformen funktionieren.
Da muss ich mir erst mal gucken und mich irgendwie mit Dingen anfreunden.
One Password.
Und ich dachte, das neue One Password hätte irgendwelche Macken.
In der Tat politisch amatschen. Sie wollte ich halt eben, ja, genau.
Achso, ja, das zum einen, weil ich dachte, der wäre noch gut.
Kann ich aber mitleben, muss ich sagen. Also, es gibt natürlich auch andere Sachen.
Ich habe mich extrem an One Passwort gewöhnt. Ich finde, die sind einfach sehr
schnell und extrem Mac-like und das ist, also ich habe wenig dran auszusetzen.
Es gibt eigentlich nichts, was es nicht kann. Ja.
Also mir wird überhaupt nichts einfallen, was mir da fehlt. Einfach voll featured
und sieht auch noch ordentlich aus.
Ja, also ich habe ihn jetzt seit Mitte Dezember.
Wir haben den Kongress wunderbar zusammen überstanden und ich kann auch halbwegs an ihm arbeiten.
Wie findest du ihn von der Größe her? Das würde mich mal interessieren.
Du hast ja als Arbeitsgerät auch den, ein, ist das auch ein 15 Zoll?
Ja, 15,6 Zoll Dell Precision M3800 oder so.
Wie findest du da den Unterschied jetzt? Weil das würde mich mal interessieren.
Der Dell ist halt ein Schlepptop. Das ist halt ein großes Arbeitsgerät,
da kann ich meine Kinects dranhauen und meine drei bis vier externen Festplatten. Ja, das ist okay.
Aber ich meine so vom wenn du entwickelst her, ist es dir zu wenig?
Ich entwickle halt nicht, also ich entwickle keine Software auf dem Mac.
Weil da brauche ich vermutlich einen zweiten Bildschirm.
Ja oder Datenanalyse. Ich meine, Python läuft ja trotzdem drauf.
Genau. Datenanalyse, JupyterLab, Jupyter Notebook, einfach so Python,
alles total okay, einfach aufzusetzen, hat von Anhieb funktioniert,
mit der Shell komme ich auch soweit klar, oder Terminal, ja,
das ist relativ entspannt.
Für so Datenanalyse kein Thema.
Da ist halt echt das Problem, nur ein USB-C-Port und ich habe halt teilweise
so zwei Festplatten mit Daten.
Das ist so ein bisschen schwierig, das dann irgendwie unterzukriegen.
Aber bis jetzt mache ich halt auch noch keinen Heavy-Load damit.
Wie ist das jetzt für dich? Wie lange hast du jetzt mit Windows so als Primary-System gelebt?
Seit immer.
Nee.
Du hast doch schon mal einen Mac gehabt.
Ja, ich hatte schon mal einen Mac.
Aber da hatte ich trotzdem einen Tower nebenbei. Ich bin immer zweigleisig gefahren.
Also ja, das war mein Primary, weil viel am Laptop. Und Laptop ist meistens Hauptgerät.
Aber ich musste immer mit beiden Betriebssystemen klarkommen. Also 2000.
Aber ist das nicht ein Megaschmerz, wenn man irgendwie so ein Primary-System,
was so komplett anders ist, dann irgendwann mal verlässt?
Es fällt mir tatsächlich nicht so schwer.
Ich muss mich halt wieder reinfinden. Das Komplizierteste ist tatsächlich irgendwie
im Unterbewusstsein und im
automatischen Nicht-Hinsehtippen die unterschiedlichen Tastaturbelegungen.
Aber ich habe jetzt schon Windows-Tastatur Deutsch, Amerikanisch plus jetzt Mac.
Also da bin ich immer schon so hin und her geswitcht und das funktioniert trotzdem
großen Teils blind zu tippen.
und jetzt ist es wieder, ich muss, also das Coole am Mac ist halt wirklich,
Sonderzeichen sind genial, weil irgendwie alles belegt ist und bei Windows ist
das ein bisschen umständlicher.
Das heißt, da liebe ich diese Mac-Tastatur einfach.
Aber ansonsten ja, so Switch zwischen deutsch-englischer Tastatur und jetzt
hier Windows, das ist, äh, Mac, das ist noch das größte Problem für mich gerade.
Und was würdest du sagen, ist so, dass,
Was ist das Angenehmste und was ist das Unangenehmste an dem Wechsel?
Das Unangenehmste ist, ich habe halt zwei Systeme mit zwei dedizierten Programmen drauf.
Das heißt, Programme, die ich auf dem einen System habe, kann ich teilweise
nicht auf dem anderen nutzen oder müsste mir eine neue Lizenz kaufen.
Und einfach so, es ist ein Migrationsaufwand.
Ich weiß halt, beide Betriebssysteme für ihre eigenen Sachen testen.
Das ist jetzt eher so, wie mache ich was auf dem einen und wie kann ich das
auf dem anderen kompensieren.
Also ich habe jetzt halt auch nicht so hardware-nahe Sachen auf dem Windows
einfach gemacht, sodass ich sage, okay, das hat mir viel, viel Schmerz unter
Windows-Nutzung bereitet.
Ich freue mich aber tatsächlich extrem, dass ich jetzt ein Endgerät habe,
was Bluetooth mit Python unterstützt.
Windows und Bluetooth geht nicht aus API-Sicht.
Ich erzähle irgendwann mal, wenn ich mit meinem einen Spaßprojekt halbwegs zufrieden bin.
Damit kannst du jetzt die Drohne spielen.
Ja, ich kann jetzt endlich mein Drohnenprojekt. Ich habe eine kleine Drohne,
eine Spielzeugdrohne, die man über Bluetooth steuern kann und ich habe tatsächlich,
vier komplette Code-Rewrites auf Windows hinter mir von diesem Projekt über
drei Jahre plus jetzt drei Jahre, wo das Projekt geruht hat,
weil ich nebenbei so dachte, Promotionshobby ist nicht cool.
Aber da freue ich mich drauf, dass ich das wiederbelebe und dann...
Was ist denn das für eine Drohne?
Eine Parrot. Eine Parrot Nighthawk oder so.
Und die kann?
Die kann einfach nur fliegen.
Bluetooth und die ist dokumentiert, wie man mit der spricht?
Ja, gibt's eine Python API.
Ich verspreche, dass ich irgendwann nochmal dediziert über dieses Projekt rede,
weil das würde jetzt zum einen ausarten und zum anderen möchte ich das wirklich
in einem Stand haben, der irgendwie halbwegs aktuell ist und nicht drei Jahre
alt und ein Erfolgserlebnis verknüpfen kann, weil das ist einfach nur Frust.
Ist das noch, ist die überhaupt noch, kann man die überhaupt noch kaufen?
Ja, kann man glaube ich noch kaufen.
Ich sehe die gerade hier irgendwie noch nicht.
Nighthawk. Ja.
Bist du sicher, dass die noch gibt?
Also wenn jetzt Parrot nicht.
Also Parrot gibt es natürlich, aber ich sehe überhaupt nichts mit Nighthawk.
Die Mambo oder so sollte es auch noch geben.
Das sind halt die Mini-Drohnen.
Aber Nighthawk? Airborne? Irgendwie so.
Anafi? Nee. Gibt es gerade? Bebop? Mambo?
Bebop ist die größere Version. Ja.
Ich gucke, ich gucke. Ich war auch schon ewig nicht mehr drauf.
Also ich habe von der Nighthawk noch nie was gehört, aber Pirate.
Also ich habe die Jumping Sumo, das ist die WLAN-Drohne, die funktioniert,
die rollt halt und funktioniert ohne Probleme.
Da habe ich halt eine kleine Kinect-Steuerung gebaut als Spaßprojekt.
Das heißt, ich kann mit der Kinect meine Bewegung aufnehmen und dann kann ich
mit meiner Bewegung die Drohne steuern und sie springt und sie dreht sich und
sie macht lustige Sachen.
Die rollt auch?
Die rollt auch.
Was meinst du mit rollen?
Das ist so eine kleine Knutschkugel mit Rädern, die dann auf dem Boden, also keine Flugdrohne.
Die sind lustig.
Also du musst ja jetzt noch nicht alles darüber erzählen, aber mich hätte jetzt
einfach nur mal interessiert, ob das überhaupt noch aktuelle Technologie ist,
die man kaufen kann, beziehungsweise ob diese ganze, ich steuere das Ding mit
Bluetooth, eine Option ist, die noch besteht. steht.
Ich glaube, das, was der noch am nächsten kommt und gerade kaufbar ist, ist die Parrot Mambo.
Mhm. Mambo gibt es, glaube ich, in meinem Haushalt auch noch irgendwo.
Ja, also das ist, glaube ich...
Aber von Bluetooth war mir da noch nie was bewusst. Es wird aber jetzt auch
nicht so offen beworben, ne?
Nö, also kannst du halt mit deinem Handy steuern, die Drohnen und das ist dann meistens Bluetooth.
Bluetooth, ja gut, aber dass es dokumentiert war, vielleicht ist es ja auch
nur reverse-engineert, ich weiß nicht.
Nö, nö, ein Teil der API ist offen und einer der Entwickler von dieser API hat
halt so eine Python-Schnittstelle gebaut,
die ich mir dann wieder genommen habe und also ich hab tatsächlich,
das war mein erstes Projekt, wo ich halt auch so ein bisschen die Binary-Communication
mir angeschaut hab und so ein bisschen reverse-engineert habe,
das war so mein Einstieg dazu. zu.
So, hier wird im Chat gerade Parrot Airborne Night McLean.
Ja, irgendwie so.
So ein Nachtsichtteil. Sieht aber böse aus.
Ja, sie schaut schon so aus. Hätte ich jetzt den Zugang hier schon auf meinem
Git eingerichtet, GitHub, könnte ich vielleicht einfach nachgucken.
Das ist das Wichtigste, was man zuerst einrichtet.
Ja, das Lustige, in der Kontrolle hab ich's.
This product is no longer sold steht hier und auf den Produkt Produktfotos steht
hier sogar extra noch Police auf den Drohnen drauf.
Scary.
Das steht aber bei deiner nicht drauf, oder?
Nee, kannst du selber draufklicken. Es ist halt ein Spielzeug, also das ist...
Habt ihr diese Silvesterfeier in Singapur oder Shanghai?
Ich habe es gesehen und dachte mir so, yep, that's the future.
Das ist jetzt auch nicht komplett neu, das gibt es jetzt schon eine Weile.
Wovon wir reden ist Drohnen statt Feuerwerk,
die in wirklich erklecklicher Zahl unterwegs sind und in Realtime gesteuert
werden, beziehungsweise sich selber steuern.
Ich schätze mal, die sind mehr oder weniger autonom unterwegs und werden von
außen nur noch getriggert.
Ja, da sitzen jetzt keine 500 Chinesen an den Kotelern.
Nee, das eh nicht, aber man hätte ja auch sagen können, da gibt es jetzt eine
Fernsteuerung, aber für mich sah das eher so aus, als ob die wirklich schon
ziemlich abgefahrene Software drin haben.
Also, was die da gemacht haben, vielleicht kann der Chat nochmal kurz dieses
Video raussuchen, das dürfte sich relativ leicht finden lassen hier.
Damit könnte man von Herr der Ringe das Feuerwerk von Gandalf nachbauen.
Das Feuerwerk von Gandalf?
Mit dem großen Drachen, der auf die Hobbits niedergeht.
Das gab diese eine Szene. Ich weiß gar nicht, in dem Buch ist es nämlich,
glaube ich, nicht ein Drache.
Aber die haben das, glaube ich, in dem Film gehabt, wo dann dieser Drache so
hoch geht und sehr echt nach unten stößt.
Natürlich wusste die Filterblase sich wieder darüber zu beschweren,
dass das in Shanghai natürlich nicht an Silvester passiert ist,
sondern dass sie das vorher aufgezeichnet haben.
wäre aber jetzt auch mein Approach gewesen, weil wir wissen,
dass Chinesen auch einen relativ lockeren Umgang mit Schwarzpulver haben und
wenn ich da, keine Ahnung, ein paar hundert Drohnen am Start habe,
mache ich das vielleicht nicht, wenn andere zwölf Millionen Leute um mich herum
mit Schwarzpulver hantieren.
Aber okay, das wäre jetzt ick jetzt.
Außerdem, wie gesagt, wir Deutschen sollten da eher die Klappe halten.
Bei uns wird ja die Silvestershow seit dem es Fernsehen gibt,
wird die Silvestershow im öffentlich-rechtlichen Fernsehen auch auch mal 14
Tage vorher aufgezeichnet. Also von daher, pff.
Ernsthaft?
Schon immer.
Ja, dann können sie es jetzt halt noch mit Drohnen aufnehmen,
dann ist doch auch noch was.
Ja, ich sage nur, weil es viele Leute gab, oh, die Chinesen haben mich geschummelt,
die haben sie vorher aufgezeichnet. Ja, wie gesagt, würde ich auch machen.
Ja.
Was man übrigens auch gut sehen kann, weil es ist nämlich sonst keine Rakete
weiter und breiter unten, die da am Start ist.
Gibt es denn in China sonst Feuerwerk? Ist das so ein Feuerwerk-Country, oder?
Wollte ich gerade sagen. Vielleicht, also die haben ja einen anderen,
die haben ja einen anderen New Year.
aber trotzdem denke ich die nutzen jede Gelegenheit zum Knallen.
Also ich saß witzigerweise an Silvester da gibt es auch ein schönes Dinner da
am Snowball, hatte ich zwei Leute aus Shanghai am Tisch,
und hab die auch gefragt, was geht denn jetzt bei euch so und die so,
naja eigentlich ist ja unser Neujahr ein bisschen später, das variiert ja auch, aber trotzdem,
die feiern auch alles was im Westen gefeiert wird, Hauptsache es gibt einen
Grund zu knallen, von daher Ja, ja. Gippie.
Vielleicht nochmal zu dieser Drohnen-Animation. Ich finde das wirklich bemerkenswert
und ich habe auch ehrlich gesagt nicht den Hauch einer Ahnung,
wie sie das eigentlich genau machen, die Dinger so optimal zu platzieren.
Denn das ist ja nicht so ganz einfach, die eigene Position zu bestimmen und
so gut getimt auch aufeinander abzustimmen.
Also dass sie alle die richtigen Abstände zueinander haben.
Und ich frage mich, wie sie das eigentlich machen. Und jetzt kommst du, Thala.
Das hättest du auf der IFA sehen können. In irgendeinem Jahr,
meine ich, war das auf der IFA, wo Parrot auch einen Stand hatte.
Die haben so ein abgezäuntes Netzgerät gehabt und da hättest du so irgendwie
fünf, sechs Drohnen tanzen sehen können.
Und im Prinzip ist das alles vorher eintrainiert. Die haben halt keine richtigen
Abstandssensoren, die hatten Markierungen auf dem Boden.
Ja, dass das funktioniert, ist mir ja klar. Ja, so habe ich das akademisch schon
viel gesehen in so Defined Spaces, aber die sind über dem Wasser im Hafen,
was weiß ich, 100 Meter in der Luft,
da ist nichts drumherum zum Orientieren.
Du kannst ja mit GPS oder Baidu oder GLONASS oder Dingsenspeichern.
Du brauchst ja im Prinzip nur die Eckend-Freunde.
Aber hier geht es um relative Abstände. GPS, selbst GPS, das ist ja das Älteste
von den Dingern, ist bei relativen Dingern ziemlich geil.
Wenn du zwei GPS-Empfänger nimmst, sagst du, mir ist scheißegal,
wie ich absolut bin auf der Welt, ich möchte jetzt den Abstand von den beiden
Dingern nehmen und nimmst zwei identische GPS-Empfänger, die du jetzt aneinanderpappst
und auseinanderziehst, kommst du auf Zentimeterauflösung schon.
Also jede Drohne hat tatsächlich ein GPS an Bord.
Ist ja mit jeder Drohne so, heute, die du kaufen kannst. Warum die nicht?
Und wertet das auch genau dafür aus, die Abstände untereinander?
Nein, die rechten, die haben alle dieselbe Software drauf, denselben Empfänger
und kriegen durch dieselbe Atmosphäre gestört, dasselbe Signal.
Das heißt, deren Absolutgenauigkeit, wenn du das jetzt unbedingt auf deine Google
Maps projizieren willst, das mag halt da ein paar Meter links und rechts hin und her eiern.
Aber dadurch, dass die alle dasselbe Signal durch dieselbe gestörte Atmosphäre
kriegen, ist die Relativgenauigkeit der Dinger untereinander ziemlich hoch.
Die müssen unter Umständen gar nicht wissen, wo die anderen Drohnen sind,
sondern sie müssen nur wissen, zu welchem Zeitspunkt sie an welcher Stelle sein sollen.
Ja, und man sollte vorher mal die einzelnen Flugfahrten mal berechnet haben.
Aber was ist denn euer Eindruck von diesen Videos, von was für Abständen zwischen
einzelnen Drohnen wir hier sprechen?
Also sind die so im Meterbereich oder sind die im 10 Meter Bereich oder kommen
sie doch teilweise doch extrem nah? Ja.
Ich glaube, der einzige Kniff daran ist, also die Dinger da hinzutun,
wo sie hingehören, das halte ich für nicht das Problem, weil wie gesagt,
die Relativgenauigkeit von all diesen Optiken, wobei du oder GPS oder so, das ist scheißegal.
Was ich viel spannender finde, ist, dass die sich ja jetzt nicht bloß dahin
platzieren und ihre Lampe anmachen, sondern die fliegen auch durch die Gegend
mit angeschalteter Lampe.
Das heißt, du siehst, dass die, während sie eine Figur bilden, sich bewegen.
Und da vorher die Flugpfade so zu koordinieren, dass die sich nicht treffen.
Das finde ich viel spannender, als dafür zu sorgen, dass jeder Pixel da ist, wo er hingehört.
Ja.
Plus natürlich irgendein von den 100 Dingern fällt immer aus und fällt dann
vielleicht drunter und reißt dann vielleicht nach anderem mit in die Tiefe oder sonst irgendwas.
Da muss man sich natürlich auch überlegen, was man da macht oder so.
Aber jetzt da einfach nur Pixel hinzumalen, das halte ich jetzt für relativ banal.
Selbst wenn die nur einen Meter auseinander sind. Man muss natürlich auch mit
anderen Sachen rechnen.
Die erzeugen natürlich auch, ähnlich nicht wie Flugzeuge, erzeugt natürlich
auch so einen dinken Luftstrom und,
also ein Sog unten auf der einen Seite, ein Geblase auf der anderen Seite,
das musst du alles mal mit einberechnen, aber wenn du das drin hast,
dann siehst du jetzt nicht so das Problem, die Dinger mit Satelliten zu steuern.
Also für unsere Audience jetzt gerade nicht so schön zu sehen,
ich repete jetzt hier gerade mal so den letzten Teil dieses Videos,
auf das wir die ganze Zeit blicken und da seht ihr, da sind so diverse Sternschnuppige
und Pixelfehler unterwegs.
Also es scheint schon etwas...
Es gibt ja auch noch so was wie Wind.
Ja, ja, es ist schon so die eine oder andere Desorientierung am Start,
aber dadurch, dass sich natürlich alles so schnell bewegt und so vielfältig
ist, fällt das natürlich im Großen und Ganzen überhaupt nicht auf.
Genau, da ist eine abgehauen. Da siehst du aber auch, wie sie sich wieder fängt
und zurück an ihre Position geht.
Ja, ja.
Das ist trotzdem mega.
Das ist schon geil.
Das ist wirklich großartig und eine tolle Idee.
Vor allem stinkt danach nichts.
Ja, stinkt danach nichts.
Muss nur ein paar Drohnen aus dem Wasser fischen.
Muss ein bisschen Plastik aus dem Wasser fischen und so, aber...
Muss man eh. Kommt der Interceptor und sammelt die Drohnen da hin.
Kommt der Interceptor und pflückt die Drohnen.
Kann man machen. Wer sich dafür mal interessiert, ich habe gerade,
ich gucke, dass ich die mal wieder finde, Ich finde, jetzt diese ganze GPS-Geschichte
ist ja inzwischen auch so ein bisschen zu so einem Nerd-Zeugs geworden,
vor allen Dingen, weil es eben nicht nur GPS gibt, sondern es gibt ja inzwischen
funktionierend auch schon lange auch GLONASS und es gibt Galileo von den Europäern
und es gibt halt Beirut von den Chinesen und die Japaner bauen auch irgendwas.
watscht. Das interessiert aber hier keine Sau, weil das hier nicht hersendet.
Und da gibt es so einen Freak, so einen Holländer, das ist so einer auch aus
der Open-Source-Szene, der Bert von PowerDNS, der macht gerne auch mal Sachen
nebenher und der hat mal vor ein paar Monaten mal so ein,
Community-Ding aus dem Acker gehoben, aus der Taufe gehoben und wo er sagt,
wir sammeln mal weltweit mit irgendwelchen Hobby-GPS-Empfängern und so sammeln
wir mal Daten über diese ganzen Satellitensysteme und schmeißen die mehr zusammen in eine Database.
Wenn du so willst, vom Prinzip technisch, naja, egal, aber vom Prinzip so,
weil die Flightradar halt nur für dieses ganze Zeugs.
Das heißt, wo man dann eben auch mal die Dinger gegeneinander abgleicht und
so, weil die haben nämlich durchaus auch Schwankungen und fallen aus und hin und her.
Und der hat da jetzt ein Open-Source-Projekt gemacht, wo man schön diese ganzen
verschiedenen Biester von den verschiedensten Navigationssystemen mal visualisieren
kann und sich Daten angucken kann von den Dingern. Und es gibt auch sehr schöne
Blogartikel dazu, die mal erklären, wie sowas funktioniert.
Da gibt es nämlich so ganz subtile Unterschiede, wie zum Beispiel,
dass die GPS-Dinger, die ticken alle nach derselben Uhr. Ich glaube, Galileo auch.
Und zwar diese, so eine Ur-Ur. Und die GLONASS-Dinger ticken gnadenlos nach
Moskau-Local-Time und all solche anderen Geschichten.
Das ist da sehr schön erklärt da drin. Ich such mal den raus und dann kannst
du den mal irgendwo in den Schleck feuern. Aber das fand ich mal ganz interessant.
Einfach nur mal, der hat auch so eine schöne Visualisierung so mit Karten,
wo du sehen kannst, welche Satellitensystem ist jetzt eigentlich wo gerade am
Start und deckt welche Gegend gerade ab und wo funktioniert und wo funktioniert es nicht.
Du kannst das auch selber in unseren Slack reinbauen.
Nee, kann ich nicht.
Doch, das ist ganz einfach.
Alter, ich habe bloß 16G in meinem Lai-Laptop. Ich kann kein Slack starten.
Das ist nicht mehr so. Das ist definitiv nicht mehr so. Das haben sie wirklich gewinnt.
Gewinnt sie.
Das ist ganz einfach. Einfach runterladen, installieren, läuft.
Ich habe das drauf, aber ich starte das nicht, weil ich normalerweise meinen
RAM für andere Dinge brauche.
Ja, aber doch nicht während der Sendung.
Was meinst du, würde ich die ganze Zeit machen? Ja. Wollte ich zuhören?
Nicht Slack starten.
Ja, was denn? Terminal oder was?
Was?
Oder berechnest du gerade irgendwelche Flugbahnen von Drohnen über Shanghai?
Nee, aber so ähnlich.
So, so. Ach, du Mythos, du.
So, jetzt kommen wir aber mal hier auf den Elefanten im Raum. Moment, ich such's.
Es war Kongress.
Ah.
Letty, du bist schon ein bisschen krank jetzt, oder?
Nee, es sah einfach nur so aus, als würdest du auch was anderes anspielen.
Ja, habe ich auch versucht, so rüberkommen zu lassen.
Ja.
Es gibt ja viele Elefanten. Es gibt viele Elefanten im Raum.
Ja. Auch in der Metaebene.
Auch wenn sie klein ist, man findet viele.
Ah, kurzer Nachtrag.
Da ist er.
Drone-Show-Software wird hier gerade im Chat gepostet. Gibt wohl auch schon
irgendwie die fertige Software dafür.
Wenn das so ist, dann brauchen wir das auf jeden Fall auf dem nächsten Kongress.
Es gab dieses Jahr ein Drohnenareal.
Ja, das gab es noch letztes Jahr schon.
Aber es gibt keine Tanzdrohnen. Wo ist unsere Chaos?
Warum ist die Eröffnungsveranstaltung nicht sowas?
Nee.
Wie nee? Nee.
Du willst nicht 17.000 Leute dazu motivieren, zu gucken, wie sie diese Drohnenflugshow stören können.
In der Halle.
Warum nicht?
Wieso?
Wenn man vorher keinem davon erzählt, kann man das ja beim Opening irgendwie
trotzdem machen. Man muss ja nicht mal 3D-Videos machen.
Man kann ja auch mal 3D Drohnen-Getanze machen.
Könnte man?
Ja, könnte man. Aber auf Sachen mit könnte man mal und müsste man mal,
werde ich eh noch zu sprechen kommen.
In meiner Kategorie, ich habe tolle Ideen, was unbedingt mal getan werden muss,
aber ich bin natürlich selber viel zu faul oder nicht in der Lage, das selber zu tun.
Diese Kategorie ist treffend benannt. Ich bin jetzt schon begeistert.
Da bin ich ganz groß drin.
So, dann lass uns doch mal den Elefanten näher betrachten.
Genau, also Kongress, der 36.
Chaos-Communication-Kongress fand statt in Leipzig vom 27. bis zum 30.12.
2019.
Und ihr wart mit dabei, kennen wir jetzt nicht, aber ihr wart da.
Und noch viele andere Leute, wie schon erwähnt, 17.000 Leute ungefähr,
mehr oder weniger, wahrscheinlich mehr als weniger.
Und wie war's?
Schön.
Zwei Tage dunkel und dann hab ich in der Sonne gesessen. Ich hab die ersten zwei Tage geheraldet.
Und da bist du natürlich zu der Zeit, also dadurch, dass ich immer die erste Schicht hatte.
Ich hab dich nur in Streams gesehen.
In Streifen.
In Strömen.
In Strömen, ja. Ja, ich habe dieses Mal auch ganz rebellisch nicht das Engel-Shirt
getragen und auch keine Farbe wieder. Das ist mir zu blöd.
Farbe?
Das ist dann einfach nur der schwebende Kopf.
Genau. Naja, als Herald musst du ja eigentlich schon darauf achten,
dadurch, dass der Hintergrund schwarz auch ist auf der Bühne zum Teil,
dass du ja überhaupt erstmal hervortrittst aus dem Stream.
Also es kann halt durchaus schwierig sein, wenn du was anhast und du eins mit
der Leinwand wirst, dass du halt einen Kopf hast, der da schwebt.
Und wir haben eigentlich letztes Jahr die Ansage bekommen, ey,
tragt bitte nicht unbedingt immer schwarz.
Und ich so, so war der Deal nicht.
Aber letztes Jahr habe ich den, die Herald, also als Herald ist man immer der
Luxusengel, weil man am Anfang schon das Engelshirt bekommt,
um es eigentlich auch auf der Bühne zu zeigen.
So hier, wir sind, oder wir haben ein Engelshirt für alle unsere Helfer.
Ich finde das, also ich weiß nicht, ich trage das aber immer nicht so gerne
auf der Bühne. Ich trage immer lieber die Sachen, die mir gehören.
ne genau und deswegen ist es halt so, wenn du da die ganze Zeit im Dunkeln bist,
diese Messehallen an sich sind halt einfach dunkel und du siehst die Sonne nicht.
Ich weiß nicht das war Tag 0,
Wo ich die erste Laufschicht hatte. Also ich war wieder zart unterwegs und habe
viele Laufschichten gemacht, vor allem als die Hallen noch relativ leer sind.
Aber es war echt das Problem, du kamst aus den dunklen Hallen in diese helle
Glasreile und das Licht brennt einem ins Gesicht.
Ich muss ja sagen, ich habe das dieses Jahr schon so ein bisschen gefeiert.
Also ich habe das eigentlich schon seitdem wir in Leipzig sind gefeiert,
dass du auf einmal Sonnenlicht hast, weil ich brauche das echt. Ich brauche Licht.
und die ersten zwei Tage habe ich das richtig gemerkt, dass mir das gefehlt
hat und die letzten zwei Tage saß ich dann immer mal so für ein,
zwei Stunden einfach in dieser Glashalle in der Sonne im T-Shirt und das war
dann schon so ein bisschen so ich meine, hätte noch jemand so einen kleinen,
Strand davor gesetzt und eine Palme hingestellt Da hättest.
Du zum Kidspace gehen müssen, die haben dieses Kinect Projektor Ding mit dem Sand Ja.
Das haben sie immer, aber da Kidspace und die Lautstärke das sind so Dinge,
da mache ich einen großen Bogen drumrum.
Wir könnten das nächste Mal einfach das Sandbecken dezent in die Glashalle setzen.
Die Frau hätte einfach gerne einen Privatstrand.
Nee, das ist das ja nicht. Also ich meine, ich habe ja immer da mit Alex und
Marlies auch in der Glashalle rumgelümmelt.
Einen öffentlichen Strand.
Einen öffentlichen Strand. Nee, das wäre total fein.
Das ist eigentlich eine gute Idee. Sieht ja sowieso so ein bisschen aus.
Wie heißt nochmal gleich das Ding hier?
Tropical Island.
Tropical Island, genau. Was wir brauchen ist Tropical Island.
Wir notieren das als eine Sache, die unbedingt auf dem Kongress passieren muss.
Ich glaube, mindestens eine Person hört gerade zu und bekommt latent einen Hals über diesen Vorschlag.
Oh, mehrere Leute, aber das Ding ist ja, wenn das dann einfach jemand macht, dann ist ja auch okay.
Naja.
Wir gebären jetzt einfach 10 bis 20 coole Ideen, also Ideen,
die wir cool finden, ja, und die Hälfte der Zuhörenden ist so irgendwie so,
oh. Und die anderen so, hm.
Und irgendjemand findet es geil. Und wenn man Glück hat, dann kommt so dieser
Zufallsfaktor mit rein.
Eigentlich könnte man, die Fairy Dust steht so gut. Eigentlich hätte man so
diesen Strand um die Fairy Dust bauen können.
Die Fairy Dust in den Strand rein, die Beachstühle daneben, Palmen hinstellen.
Hätte man einen Strandkongress am Strandkongress wieder.
Oder ihr macht die Version wie dieses rollende Bällebad.
ihr baut den Strand in einen fahrbaren Untersatz.
Ja, okay, dann hast du aber auch das Camp gefüllt gleich wieder.
Bällebad ist für mich immer noch das 2015er Camp mit dem Wagen.
Ich glaube, das mit dem Strand, ich habe gerade mal ein bisschen drüber nachgedacht.
Also Strand in der Glashalle.
Das wäre schon verdammt geil.
Das wäre schon cool, aber es würde wahrscheinlich gehäuft zu Unfällen führen.
Auf jeden Fall. Aber dann hätten wir nicht mehr Schnittwunden,
sondern inzwischen Prellungen beim Zert als Hauptproblem.
Oh, weißt du, wie viel Dreck da reinkommt, wenn du auf dem Camp Camp.
Dieses Gesicht. Was? Sie hat sehr begeistert geguckt. Wir sollten das Thema wechseln für Tim.
Das stimmt ja.
Nein, das meine ich nicht. Das leckere Blutsandgemisch.
Diese Glashalle ist natürlich auch ein 1A-Racetrack.
Da sind auch immer meine Kids dann irgendwie mit meinem Elektro-Scooter unterwegs
gewesen und wenn dann dieser Sand sich da verteilt.
Dann hast du halt für dich Also auch wirklich so mit, ja, das geht wahrscheinlich
nicht so gut, aber mit so einer Barriere.
Ich finde das Ding halt auch, also das ist auch als Racetrack super mit den Inlineskates.
Ich finde es auch immer schade, dass dann die Leute so abrupt stehenbleiben
und ich mir dann denke, ey, bloß nicht, bloß nicht, nicht auf dieser Strecke.
Ja, mit Inlineskates wirst du dich dann auch bedanken, wenn da alles mit Sand vorgeht.
Ja, ja, klar.
Muss man so ein Gitter drumherum machen oder sowas.
Ja. Ich meine, ich habe mir auch extra neue Inlineskates ja für den Kongress
geholt, weil meine alten einfach zu klein waren.
Also ist denn das überhaupt zugelassen? Ich denke, da ist eh alles verboten.
Da ist ja schon zu schnell gucken verboten in der Halle da.
Also Sie können, naja, Sie sollen mir doch mal hinterherlaufen.
Mir ist niemand hinterhergelaufen. Niemand hat versucht, mich zu halten.
Die Laufschichten sind angehalten, freundlich zu ermahnen, dass irgendwie motorisierte
Geräte sich bitte an Schrittgeschwindigkeiten zahlen.
Na, motorisiert bin ich nicht.
Bio-Motor zählt nicht.
Und es darf nicht strahlen.
Es darf nicht strahlen.
Das ist die Hauptdevise, inoffiziell und offiziell vom Konzert.
Staubsaugerengel, das ist großartig.
Super Idee.
Wie den Strand in den Zaum halten.
Ja, total unterfordert.
Ja, ich finde auch.
Ja doch, könnte man machen. Irgendwie ein paar Ei-Robots drum rum kreisen lassen
um die Insel, die den ganzen rausgeschleppten Sand wieder einsammeln und den
können sie gleich wieder abkippen.
Immer dann, wenn der Fänger voll ist, fährt er einmal auf die Insel,
kippt es ab und dann weiter. Das wäre dann mal innovativ.
Das ist dann die neue Art von Drohnenshow, da kann man dann auch im Kreis fahren.
Ja, hier dein Interceptor. Dann hast du einen Sandinterceptor,
der dann da rumkreist um die Sandinsel und sich wieder einsammelt.
Ja, ich habe übrigens gegen einen kleinen Roboterpark, der irgendwie schräge Sachen macht.
Da fallen mir noch ein paar andere Sachen ein. Oder wo wir gerade dabei sind,
da gibt es gerade am Ende der Glashalle gibt es noch so einen anderen Bereich,
der einfach unfassbar unbewirtschaftet ist und ich prangere das an.
Da gibt es nämlich Nämlich, wenn du ganz durch gehst, hast du hinten nochmal
so einen Raucherbalkon. Also diese Raucheterrasse.
Also halt eigentlich eine Terrasse, aber halt da draußen eben auch der Raucherbereich.
Und dem ist dann angeschlossen so ein Wasserbecken.
Oh ja, stimmt.
Und in diesem Wasserbecken war nichts.
Doch ein toter Fisch.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, Michi erzählte doch irgendwas von Fisch.
Nichts war da drin. Ein Fisch?
Also Michi hat ja von ihrem Fisch erzählt.
Aber war das nicht das Wasserbecken unten am CCL?
Ich habe ja im September da ein paar Tage verbracht und das war eigentlich ganz
lustig, aber da schwamm der ein oder andere tote Fisch rum in dem Wasserbecken.
Ja gut, die kann man ja dann auch rausnehmen, wenn einen das stört.
Oder essen.
Nein, wir essen keine toten Fische, die schon länger im Wasser schwimmen.
Das Zert freut sich nicht.
Nein.
Ist ja auch Wurst. Auf jeden Fall finde ich, ist die Abwesenheit von robotisch,
autonomen Schwimmfahrzeugen finde ich irgendwie eklatant. Und absolut anprangungswürdig.
Also gerade, da da so viel dunkel ist, könnte man da halt auch wunderbare Lichtspiele machen.
Also einfach so kleine, also wie diese Drohnen, aber halt quasi in Wasser gefährt.
Gibt es das eigentlich auch schon?
Es gibt nur so Boote, aber so autonom irgendwie, weiß ich nicht.
Ich warte auf meine Spielzeuge zum Aufziehen.
Nee, aber du weißt schon mehr, was mir vorsteht. Also halt irgendwas,
was so leuchtet oder andere lustige Dinge macht. Das kann ja auch rauchen zum Beispiel.
Unterwasserrauch?
Das ist ja eh Raucherterrasse. Da können die Schiffe auch rauchen.
Das stimmt natürlich.
Ja. Ja.
Irgendwas, auf jeden Fall, ich hätte da ganz gerne ein bisschen Entertainment
und ich denke, das ist eine Herausforderung.
Es ist vor allem nicht klein, also da ist richtig viel Wasser,
da kann man sich ordentlich austoben. Es ist nicht nur so eine Badewanne.
Ist da nicht auch irgendwas in der Mitte? Ich habe da so dunkel was in Erinnerung.
Da sind so Säulen in der Mitte.
Ich dachte, da wäre sogar noch ein Gebäude in der Mitte.
Gebäude in der Mitte? Nein, da ist kein Gebäude in der Mitte,
das ist halt einfach nur so.
Das ist kein Löschwasser oder sonst etwas Medizierter.
Nein, das ist kein Löschwasser. Das ist einfach so Wasser.
Nee, ob es ein Löschwasserteich ist.
Nein, das ist kein Löschwasserteich. Überhaupt nicht. Das ist ja viel zu flach.
Den meinst du, den kurz vor Dresden?
Und selbst wenn.
Nicht so schnell. Ich meine nicht den vor dem Gebäude, außerhalb,
sondern der im Gebäude ist.
Aber der vor dem Gebäude ist auch so ein kleiner Mindfuck. Da gibt es ja diese Verbindung.
Ja, dieser Weg, der einmal schräg durchgeht da hinten.
Und du denkst dir so, Alter, stehst du im Wasser? Ja. Und das ist ja wirklich
mehrmals, bis ich dann geschnallt habe, ne ja, da ist ja dieser Weg.
Ja.
Das ist ein bisschen unfair. Ist da ein Segelboot drauf?
Ne, das ist eine Fontäne.
Achso, okay.
Da ist so ein kleines Wasserspiel. Das sehen wir halt im Winter alles nicht.
Naja.
Also da könnte man natürlich dann auch Dinge tun, Aber ohne eben das Kongressgebiet
zu verlassen, hätte man halt einen wunderbaren Wasserspielplatz da so hinten
raus und ich denke, da müsste was gehen.
Die Stadt Leipzig könnte mal den Fußweg neu asphaltieren, so aus Rollersicht.
Wir sind jetzt schon wieder so sehr in dem, was man anders, besser,
schöner neu machen könnte. Was noch unbespielt ist.
Wir steigern uns da gerade rein, bevor wir überhaupt erzählt haben, was schon da war.
Richtig, und was toll war, genau. Das ist mein Punkt. Wollen wir nicht erstmal
sagen, was uns gefallen hat?
Können wir machen. Was hat dir denn gefallen?
Na gut, es ist,
Es war halt mein erster Zert-Einsatz beim Kongress.
Das heißt, ich habe jetzt sowohl den Unterschied gesehen, mal ein Zuhause auf
dem Kongress zu haben, versus einfach nur so rumlaufen, Vorträge gucken.
Was echt einen Unterschied macht. Und ich kann jetzt verstehen,
also gerade so eine Assembly oder eine Homestation zu haben,
ist halt echt cool, wo man einfach so sein Zeug droppen kann und dann entweder
dort ist oder mit Menschen was macht oder halt nicht.
Ja, ich kann mir das gar nicht anders vorstellen. Die einzige Möglichkeit zu existieren.
Das war halt so zwei Jahre lang nicht mein...
Du bist also zwei Jahre ferngesteuert durchgegangen.
Nein, nicht ferngesteuert, aber ich hab mir irgendwo eine Position gesucht und
hab dann da vor mich hin gewerkelt, Dinge gemacht, gecodet oder bin dann zu
irgendwelchen Vorträgen und Workshops gegangen.
Das geht auch, aber es ist halt was anderes.
Aber ich hab auch nichts. Ich hab das nicht, so eine Homebase in der Tat,
wo ich dann hinfahre auf dem Kongress. Außer der Punk-Späti.
Ja. Aber da würde ich jetzt, also du kannst deine Sachen halt zum Beispiel im Zert einfach lassen.
Und ich hab meine Sachen halt immer am Start. Also so Schuhe,
falls ich die erinnere, jetzt geht's dann doch mal aus hier.
Aber so eine richtige Homebase, das stimmt. Das war bei dir halt echt cool,
dass man da die Sachen einfach mal droppen konnte. Ja.
Oder man hat sich einfach mal in die Küche...
Wir hätten dich gerne aufgenommen, Letti.
Wo denn?
Am Sendezentrum.
Als Podcasterin bist du da auch befugt.
Aha.
Da gibt es Tische.
Ablageplätze, alles nette Leute. Ich lasse meine Sachen nicht irgendwo in einem offenen Raum liegen.
Also das ist halt so, das mache ich prinzipiell. Aber das mache ich prinzipiell
halt nicht, weil ich da nicht also das.
Das Problem ist bekannt.
Genau und deswegen aber trotz alledem das war auf jeden Fall cool,
eure Homebase da im Zelt.
Und man hatte eine Küche. Man hatte einen Waffel.
Waffeleisen.
Ich hatte zwischenzeitlich vier Waffeleisen.
Gibt es da nicht die C3 Waffel?
Ja, es gibt das VOG. Aber wir hatten tatsächlich irgendwie im ZERT und von angegliederten
Organisationen plötzlich da vier Waffeleisen stehen. Unter anderem eins von mir.
Und dann habe ich mich einfach hingestellt und losgewaffelt.
Ihr hattet ordentlich eine Waffel.
Ja.
Im Camp haben sie irgendwie ja Materwaffeln gemacht.
Die Wok-Waffeln sind mit Mate.
Verstehe.
Das ist Standard.
Ja.
Verstehe.
Das Rezept ist auch Open Source.
Ja klar, steht auf GitHub, ist mir vollkommen klar.
Gibt es auch in der veganen Variante mit Bananen.
Veganer Mate, was?
Haben sie dieses Jahr die veganen Waffeln hinbekommen?
Das weiß ich nicht, ob sie sie hinbekommen haben. Ich habe nur gesehen,
dass es auf der Webseite verzeichnet ist.
Genau, also der letzte Status vom Camp war, dass der vegane Waffelteig so ein
bisschen schwierig ist.
Bestimmt. Ich habe da auch versucht, meine eigenen Experimente mitzumachen.
Aber für Massenproduktionen waren die bis jetzt noch nicht geeignet.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie es dieses Jahr hinbekommen haben. Ich hatte keine Zeit,
mich beim Wok anzugliedern.
Ist auch keine Hafermilch drin. Wie soll denn das was werden?
Ohne Hafermilch kann gar nichts werden.
Nee, Hafermilch funktioniert an der Stelle. Also das ist nicht das Secret Ingredient,
was plötzlich alles besser macht.
Warum nicht?
Also meine Waffel-Experimente sind das Problem,
dass entweder der Teig zu klebrig ist oder zu stark am Eisen haftet und du hast
dann so viel Aufwand, den Teig vom Waffeleisen runterzukriegen,
weil das nicht so stark refettet.
und mein größtes Problem ist tatsächlich diese Bindemöglichkeit vom Ei so zu
substituieren, dass die Waffel fluffig bleibt und trotzdem nicht zu klitschig
ist, wie bei zum Beispiel Chiasamen.
Ich wollte auch keine Hefewaffeln machen, weil Hefewaffeln bäh sind,
aber Hefe würde halt auch das so ein bisschen zusammen...
Das Ei ist das Problem.
Nicht bäh.
Weil Hefe nicht so meins ist.
Verstehe.
Vom Geschmack her.
Ja, vom Geschmack her.
Okay, wollt ja nur als Nicht-Waffler.
Hefewaffeln sind halt nicht dieses Standard-Waffelrezept, was ich mit jetzt
in Anführungszeichen traditionellen Waffeln. Also das ist anders.
Deine Festtagswaffeln, die du mir mal aufgewaffelt hast.
Ja, ich habe halt mein Standardrezept von meiner Oma mit Ei und Schmand und Mehl, Speisestärke.
Die sind so richtig was für die Hüfte.
Ja, die sind wirklich gut. und bis jetzt ist es halt daran gesteitert,
das in ein veganes Rezept umzubauen,
aber das neue Jahr kommt und es werden neue Bio- und Chemiewaffelproduktionen angestrebt.
Also du hattest auf jeden Fall Waffeln und Spaß und du hast Waffeln und du wusstest
sie zum Einsatz zu bringen.
Ja.
Warst mit Waffelschein ausgestattet.
Genau, genau. Und ansonsten, es war halt relativ schön.
Ich bin halt eher so ein Frühaufsteher und ich hab dann halt die Morgenschichten
von sechs bis zehn so Laufschicht und Raumschicht gemacht und sechs bis acht
Laufschicht, die Hallen sind großenteils leer. Sechs?
Kannst du das nochmal sagen?
Sechs bis acht.
Morgens.
Hast du eine Schicht gemacht?
Ja. Wie? Das Zert ist rund um die Uhr besetzt.
Ja, ja, klar, aber wie kannst du von sechs bis acht besetzt sein?
Indem ich einfach um um fünf aufstehe, wenn der Wecker klingelt und 5.30 Uhr
drüben in der Messe bin, gucke, wie ich mich nützlich machen kann und dann...
Das ist in meinem Kongress übrigens auch so.
Aber wann schläfst du denn dann ein, damit du um sechs Uhr wach sein kannst?
Neun spätestens.
Ja, es war dann zwischen zehn und elf. Also von zehn, elf schlafen bis fünf.
Was eigentlich total okay ist. Hat auch super für mich funktioniert.
Okay, das ist super. Ich finde das auch toll, wenn Leute sowas können.
Ja.
Ich gehöre nicht dazu. Ich war eher um sechs dann.
So weit, dass ich dann auch mal.
Aber das ist halt genau, also das fand ich halt so angenehm.
Du hast dann halt einfach eine leere Halle, kannst gemütlich durch die Gegend
laufen. Sticker-Stationen sind leer.
Man kann sich mal dezent gucken, was da gedroppt wurde.
Acht bis zehn Raumschicht ist halt so gut wie nichts los. Aber die haben halt
auch einfach bis, die haben halt auch.
Das heißt, du hast eine Schicht gemacht, wo auch nichts los ist.
Genau. Das heißt, du hast auch nichts zu tun.
Na, Laufschicht, du läufst ja trotzdem rum und guckst, aber du hast halt nicht massiv Stress.
Laufschicht, das sind die mit den Rucksäcken?
Ja.
Du warst so zweit unterwegs und so und dann guckt ihr sozusagen,
ob da Leute, die liegen, ob sie da liegen.
Weil sie schlafen oder weil sie ein Problem haben. Ja, oder wir werden irgendwo
hingeschickt. Also es gibt ja die Medical Section und die Technical Section.
Technical Section guckt halt auch, sind die Lötkolben aus, brennt irgendwas,
muss man vielleicht… Aber ihr seid auch Brandwacht.
Nicht nur… Also mehr Feuerwehr als medizinisches Team.
Nee, nee, es gibt beides.
Ja, also zärt ist beides und du warst aber im Medical.
Ja, ja. Okay. Genau.
Worauf hast du dann so geachtet?
Ja, liegen Leute irgendwo, wo sie nicht liegen sollten, atmet alles noch und
also die Morgenschichten sind halt wirklich entspannt.
Aber da hast du es im Wesentlichen mit so Schlafenden zu tun.
Ja, ja. Also das Lustige ist auch, glaube ich, alle, die die Nacht über Probleme
hatten, sind dann auch da schon raus.
Die kommen dann eher bis sechs.
Das solltest du vielleicht gar nicht so laut sagen, sonst kriegst du keine Schicht mehr nächstes Mal.
Ja, ich glaube, die Morgenschichten sind immer noch so ein bisschen,
also wir haben aber inzwischen echt, also ich bin ja jetzt auch relativ neu,
aber wir sind inzwischen ein echt großes Team und die meisten Schichten sind
gut besetzt und sind halt auch echt überall fähige Leute, nette Leute.
In den letzten Jahren hat das Zettel auch ganz schön gelitten unter der neuen
Größe. Hat sich das irgendwie gebessert?
Ich glaube, es bessert sich. Aber das Problem ist einfach immer noch die Führungspositionen,
also Dispatcher zum Beispiel, die brauchen halt echt krasse Anforderungen,
die die ganze Organisation macht und die Führung selbst vom Zert,
da gibt es halt nicht so viele, die das irgendwie abpuffern können.
Und das heißt, du hast dann halt trotzdem irgendwie Ärzte, Dispatcher,
die einfach viele Schichten fahren müssen und lange Schichten fahren müssen,
weil die sich untereinander gar nicht so So sehr absolut.
Ja, abwechseln können. Aber da sind jetzt auch gerade dieses Jahr irgendwie
viele neue, auch aus irgendwie lokal von Leipzig wohl welche dazugekommen.
Also das klang jetzt eigentlich ganz gut, ohne dass ich da jetzt so viel… Tiefe Einblick hätte.
Ja.
Genau und auch nicht… Bist ja auch noch neu. Ja, ich bin neu.
Du gehörst ja auch zu den Verbesserungen.
Ja, vielleicht könnte man das so formulieren. Nee, aber auf jeden Fall nette Truppe.
Und der Unterschied ist halt einfach so, acht bis zehn Raumschicht hast du drei
Leute oder fünf Leute, die reinkommen und so Nachmittagsschicht 16 bis 18 Uhr
hast du alle zwei Minuten jemand, der reinkommt.
Vielleicht muss man auch nochmal, für die Leute, die eigentlich vielleicht auch
noch nie auf dem Kongress waren und schon gar nicht auf diesem Kongress waren
und die trotzdem noch zuhören gerade,
weil das ist jetzt glaube ich doch wirklich so das Kapitel, was so ein Kandidat
ist, übersprungen zu werden, auch wenn ich weiß, dass viele Leute das dann immer
so hören und sich dann so denken, so, ah, ah, nächstes Jahr gehe ich auch hin.
Nee, die waren schon alle da.
Nee, nee, nee, es ist einfach immer noch, auch dieses Mal, das hat man beim
Opening auch wieder gesehen, da sitzen dann 4000 Leute und es wird gefragt,
wer, für wen von euch ist das jetzt hier der erste Kongress und 75% sagt, da ist er mal dabei.
Also es ist wirklich immer wieder. Ist es immer noch ein Problem Karten zu kriegen?
Also immer noch limitiert? Mit 17.000.
Teilnehmern immer noch. Wobei man sagen muss, das vielleicht mal auch so als Tipp,
ich kann das jetzt nicht konkret quantifizieren, aber es gab früher Früher mehr
gestresste Leute zum Kongress hin,
die noch versucht haben, Tickets zu bekommen und es war dann irgendwie nichts möglich.
Das war in Hamburg und Berlin am Ende schlimm.
In Leipzig hast du das auch, aber ich habe das Gefühl, das Angebot auf Twitter
von frei werdenden Tickets ist sehr groß.
Und ich habe bisher niemanden getroffen, der wirklich probiert hat,
Tickets zu kriegen und sie dann auch bekommen hat.
Also alle, die irgendwie noch auf der Suche waren, sind irgendwie auch fündig
geworden, weil am Ende einfach so viel durchrotiert wird von Leuten mit,
die dann nicht können oder doch keinen Bock haben oder krank sind oder was weiß
ich, es gibt ja immer tausend Gründe.
Und von daher, wer jetzt sozusagen vorhat zum Kongress zu kommen und dann nicht
in der Ticketlotterie gewinnt,
wird mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit danach mindestens in den zwei,
drei Wochen vorher fündig werden.
Und das kann man dann auch schon mal für planen.
Gott, hoffentlich schlägt mir das nicht wieder ins Gesicht nächstes Jahr. Anyway.
Aber es war schon erstaunlich, wie viele Tickets am Ende doch wieder frei geworden sind.
Ich hatte halt auch gehört, dass wirklich auch viele Krankheitsfälle waren. Klar.
Ist Winter.
Und inzwischen sind dann auch teilweise ganze Familien krank.
Das heißt, da werden halt plötzlich vier Tickets frei, anstatt nur zwei.
Womit ich das jetzt erwähne, also Also ich begleite ja dieses Kongress- und
Campwesen schon ein bisschen länger und habe vor allem immer mit großem Interesse
die sich so über die Jahre hin entwickelnden Gruppen,
also die Ochs, Ochs und Zerz,
so wachsen gesehen.
Und diese Medizin- und Feuerwehrabteilung, das ist so ein Segment,
das hatte ich einfach am Anfang auch überhaupt nicht auf dem Zettel.
Basteln auch mit so Dingen rum, wie Blut und so.
Ja, auch unabhängig vom Blut, aber sagen wir mal so,
wir haben jetzt, ich weiß nicht, 2000 Engel oder so irgendwie am Start gehabt
auf diesem Kongress, die sich halt um alles mögliche kümmern und alles mögliche
ist so viel, also es ist ja sozusagen.
Jeder organisatorische Aspekt dieser Veranstaltung, wird von Freiwilligen gemacht.
Mit ganz, ganz, ganz wenigen Ausnahmen wie zum Beispiel dem Security-Team,
also dem richtigen Security-Team, die sozusagen nur gerufen werden,
wenn wirklich ein Problem ist, so was wir,
mit unseren normalen Mitteln so nicht bekämpfen können.
Aber ansonsten alles sind irgendwie Engel und diese Gruppen organisieren sich selber.
Und als wir mit diesem ganzen Gewäse angefangen haben und die Veranstaltung
überhaupt erstmal so groß wurde, dass sowas wie, man hat da ein eigenständig agierendes Team,
was sich um so einen größeren Bereich mehr oder weniger selbstständig kümmert.
Als das irgendwie so aufkam, fing es ja irgendwie so mit diesem Engelwesen an.
Also dieses generell überhaupt erstmal Helfer verwalten, organisieren, einen Ort dafür haben,
wo sie sich treffen können, so so der Heaven wurde geboren und dann aus diesem
Engel-Ding kam dann relativ schnell so diese Ausgründung des Zert.
Und das kam für mich extrem überraschend zu sehen.
Also erstmal hat es natürlich damit zu tun, dass ich jetzt selbst weder im Feuerwehrwesen
noch im Medizinwesen, wie du dir vorstellen kannst, gar keine Heimat habe und hatte. Ähm.
Und das für mich dann irgendwie aber auch nicht automatisch so mit Nerdtum verbunden
war, aber eines Besseren belehrt wurde.
Natürlich dieser ganze Feuerwehrbereich, wo dann auch die ganzen Funkamateure
natürlich auch noch mit dran hingen, das war natürlich mega stark.
Und das hat nicht lange gedauert und das war so eine eigene Abteilung,
die aber dann auch noch durch diese Prägung natürlich, durch das Arbeiten in
der Feuerwehr, aber eben auch das Arbeiten in so Notdiensten auf eine Art und
Weise militärisch aufgestellt waren.
Militärisch ist die falsche Bezeichnung, aber wohl organisiert.
Also einfach ein Gefühl und eine Vorstellung und Wertschätzung für diese innere
Organisation hatten, weil sie wissen, dass das zu tun nur funktioniert,
wenn man so gut organisiert ist.
Also militärisch nein, überhaupt nicht, nicht mal ansatzweise, falsche Wortwahl.
Ja, sehr organisiert, sehr professionell, also selbst wenn untereinander viel
Spaß ist und irgendwie auch Spaßprojekte gemacht sind.
Also es wurden jetzt zum Beispiel im Zert haben sich Leute hingestellt und eigene
so isotonische Getränkemischungen in Großpackungen zusammengerührt vorher.
Das heißt, wir hatten dann hinten im Medikamentenlager größere Mengen von so
isotonischem Getränkepulver, was wir einfach nur mit Wasser anrühren mussten
und dann halt auch teilweise an die Bar ausgeliefert wurde oder was man sich
beim Zert abholen konnte.
weil das halt so gegen Dehydration ganz gut funktioniert und bei Kater und bla.
Also trotz so,
Spaß, sind die einfach wirklich gut in dem, was sie machen und sind halt auch
irgendwo offizieller Ansprechpartner und sorgen dafür, dass man halt nicht externe
Feuerwehr überall drin hat oder externe Sanitäter.
Und nebenbei bleibt halt trotzdem noch Zeit für Fortbildung,
für interne Vorträge, für kannst du mir mal zeigen, wie jetzt das funktioniert.
Das ist eigentlich das Krasseste an dem Ganzen.
Wie funktioniert das eigentlich in den deutschen Verwaltungswald?
Gibt es da nicht so welche Leipziger Feuerwehr, die sagen, mir doch scheißegal,
weil ihr dafür Hobbyisten anschleppt, wir machen das hier.
Die haben einen offiziellen Status. Also dieses Jahr waren wohl Feuerwehrmänner
noch extern, die mitpatrouilliert haben.
Aus Leipzig, weil aus Gründen, weiß ich nicht, stecke ich nicht drin.
Aber wenn es, also wir haben halt zum Beispiel Ärzte, die können Privatrezepte
ausstellen über das Zert.
Das heißt, wenn es Medikamente gibt, die dringend notwendig sind,
gibt es halt da eine Möglichkeit, das über das Zert zu machen.
Die müssen dann halt privat gekauft werden, weil keine Kassenleistung und so ist klar.
Und das Zert wird halt auch keine Diagnostik machen und auch keine Impfung und so weiter.
Stell es dir vor, Du hast dein Online-Artsystem für den Kongress und kannst
erst mal schön gepflegt deine Untersuchungen machen.
Das ist einer der Running Gags. Es wurde auch auf dem Zert-Twitter-Account so gepostet.
Prime-Kunden, Prime-Zert-Kunden können sich den 5-Uhr-Tee abholen lassen.
Da gibt es ein sehr schönes Foto.
Aber ja, halt trotz so kleiner Späße echt coole Leute.
Ich finde es halt interessant, wie viel ihr Fortbildung halt nebenbei,
also du hast halt eigentlich diesen Kongress und dann hast du nochmal diesen
Mini-Kongress im ZERT eigentlich.
Ja, oder medizinische Fortbildung.
Ja klar, aber genau.
Das wäre schon ein Das sind unsere eigenen kleinen Vorträge und Vortragsthemen.
Also von irgendwie, wie Ultraschallt man über Placebo und Nocebo,
über der Benjamin von den Autis hat halt einen Vortrag gehalten über Autisten
und deren Wahrnehmung und wie man am besten mit denen in Stresssituationen und
Unruhsituationen umgeht.
Ich habe gelernt, wie man Medikamente über die Nase geben kann,
wann man merkt, dass das Ketamin, das man über die Nase gegeben hat, gut dosiert ist.
Natürlich nur für medizinische Zwecke.
Nur für medizinische Zwecke.
Oder Ausbildung oder für die Forschung.
Ich darf es nicht geben, aber ich habe jetzt die Theorie dazu.
Verstehe.
Also, nee, wirklich, ich bin echt, echt begeistert.
Aber man muss halt auch sagen, der Zertjob insgesamt ist einfach nicht,
ohne dadurch, dass die so viele Schichten haben, dass die halt wirklich von
im Prinzip Tag 0, minus 1 geht's bei denen,
Minus 2 war ich da, da hab ich angefangen mit aufzubauen und im Prinzip ab minus
1 kommen so Patienten rein.
Die Aufbaupatienten, die Abbaupatienten, dann irgendwie am 31.
haben wir abgebaut und am 2., 3.
waren halt immer noch Leute vor Ort und also das ist schon Das ist schon echt
ein harter Job und da bin ich Hut ab und total begeistert.
Sowohl was Projektleitungen, SECU, LOG, einfach was alle leisten,
aber bei denen sehe ich das halt einfach,
wie viel die da reinstecken und dass Leute mit teilweise nur drei Stunden Schlaf
trotzdem Meetings mit der Feuerwehr durchziehen müssen, weil muss jetzt halt sein.
Ja so geschichten gibt es
wirklich viele diesmal mehr
am in den aufbau tagen
teilgenommen als bisher so nicht nicht sonderlich viel aber am anfang ein bisschen
lkw gefahren so ein zwei tage so ein bisschen das geschehen begleitet als es
so richtig alles los ging und das ist ja auch irgendwie schon irre dass so am
12 dezember so die zeit rum,
Also viele Leute tun auch vorher schon Sachen und auch das, was da getan wird,
muss alles vorbereitet werden.
Aber dann geht es halt irgendwann so richtig los, dass halt so diese Lagerbeschickung anfängt.
Es gibt ein großes Lager in Berlin und das muss dann auch erstmal in Shape gebracht werden,
dass man überhaupt erstmal weiß, was zieht man jetzt hier irgendwie alles raus
und schon mal alles vorbereiten und irgendwann kommen dann die großen Lastwagen
und dann zieht die ganze Karawane nach Leipzig und fährt den ganzen Stuff dahin.
und das ist ja auch einfach so viel Zeug.
Was ich auch krass finde, ist die Dedication von manchen Leuten.
Also zum Beispiel der Arl, der war ja auch mal hier in der Sendung.
Ich weiß keine Ahnung, wann der da hingezogen ist.
Am 6. Dezember war er, glaube ich. Am 6. Dezember oder sowas.
Und der ist jetzt, ich habe jetzt gerade, weil ich nachher eine Sache mit ihm
am Chatten hatte, habe ich jetzt ihn mal angechattet, so gestern,
so mal, Alter, was geht denn so?
Und er, ja, ist jetzt gerade jetzt wieder vom Kongress wieder gekommen. Okay.
So 30 Tage irgendwie in Leipzig abhängen, muss man natürlich auch erstmal drauf haben.
Und auch zeitlich.
Er ist nicht der Einzige. Aber das muss man schon sagen, Hut ab,
was da an Dedication von den Leuten noch passiert.
Also die Leute, die wirklich am längsten da sind, sind halt die Leute,
die dieses Lok, also das Lager fahren.
Weil die wirklich vom ersten LKW, der da aufschlägt,
also erstmal aufmachen, Halle in Betrieb nehmen, Halleninspektor grüßen, Tralala, Platz,
schaffen, vorbereiten, schon mal die erste Struktur machen, die ersten Container
werden angeliefert, Büro einrichten und dann kommt halt irgendwie ein Lasser
nach dem anderen, der da koordiniert werden muss und für alles nochmal Fahrer
gefunden werden muss und es muss alles irgendwo hingestellt werden, es muss alles irgendwo,
ankommen und es muss alles verzeichnet werden und es ist irre,
was ich also schon in diesem Segment, also ehrlich gesagt am Anfang und das
ist schon fast ein bisschen peinlich, aber,
ich hab so irgendwann gehört, es gibt jetzt einen Lok, da dachte ich mir so, ja, ja irgendwie,
Ock for everything was für ein lustiger Joke, weil mir selber überhaupt nicht
klar geworden ist, wie sehr zu dem Zeitpunkt so eine Logistik schon,
diesen Kongress, also klar, es gab schon immer irgendwie Logistik,
aber dass da sozusagen auch nochmal so eine.
Ausgewachsene große Community sogar um so etwas herum entstehen würde,
die dann so hauptamtlich diesen ganzen Kram über so einen langen Zeitraum betreut,
da musste ich mich dann auch erstmal wieder so ein bisschen schütteln.
Und ja, dementsprechend dem Team, wie so vielen, ist halt da auch besonderer
Dank entgegenzubringen, damit dieser ganze Organismus überhaupt erstmal ins Rollen kommt.
Wir könnten jetzt mit allen Operation-Centern weitermachen, die Liste ist endlos.
Deswegen lassen wir das vielleicht mal bei unseren unmittelbaren Eindrücken.
Letti, du hast ja dann quasi beim Herald-Team gewirkt.
Genau, ich bin letztes Jahr im Herald-Team dazu gestoßen.
Und das war auch eine verdammt coole Vorbereitung. Ich weiß nicht,
ob ich das das letzte Mal erwähnt hatte.
Wir hatten letztes Jahr vor dem Kongress ein Training quasi für auf der Bühne rumhampeln.
Also so wirklich von einem, also Youssef, der bei uns im Team mit ist,
der macht Improv-Theater.
und hat auch letztes Jahr den Poetry, warte mal, wie hieß das?
Der Slam, den Chaos-Slam hat er auch gewonnen.
Genau.
Und hat uns halt so ein bisschen einfach beigebracht, wie man auf der Bühne
steht, wie man präsentiert, was man so machen muss, was seine Rolle ist.
Und das hat super viel Spaß gemacht und auch so ein bisschen die Bühnenangst genommen.
Aber was ich halt dieses Jahr auch gemerkt habe, war, wenn man ein ganzes Jahr
lang keine Vorträge hält Und diese Bühnenpräsenz nicht hat.
Einfach nur so dieses, okay du gehst jetzt hoch auf eine Bühne,
stehst vor Leuten, sodass du da nicht mehr zu nervös bist.
Nervös werde ich glaube ich immer sein, wenn ich auf eine Bühne gehe,
weil ich perfektionistisch bin. Ich will immer alles perfekt machen.
Aber so dieses, nicht mehr so einen krassen Respekt, der dich einschüchtert zu haben vor der Bühne.
Das hat mir nicht gefehlt, aber ich habe direkt gemerkt, so Mann,
ärgert mich, dass ich nie auf einer Bühne so gestanden habe wie das Jahr davor.
Was hast du denn da gelernt? Hand?
Zum einen, also wirklich so
dieses ganz normale so auf Ad-Hoc-Situationen irgendwas sagen zu können.
Was hast du denn da üblicherweise? So Spiele mit Bällen zum Beispiel,
dass du so nicht weißt, wer als nächstes drankommt und dann musst du halt aus
den Wortketten, die vorher gebildet werden, was Neues bilden.
Also wieder eins hinzufügen.
Oder halt einen Spaß und das ist auch wirklich, wenn man so ein Namensidiot
ist wie ich, total toll ähm Du hast einen Kreis von 20 Leuten.
Und je nachdem, wo du stehst und wann du dran bist, musst du den,
wir hatten dann so dieses Spiel, einen Beibot und den Namen von der Person,
also Lazy Letty zum Beispiel, also immer was ich.
Wie so ein Ubuntu-Name.
Genau, so ein Ubuntu-Name, so eine Alliteration am Ende hast,
die musstest du dir von deinen Vorgängern merken.
Von allen.
Von allen. Das war natürlich fein, wenn du am Anfang warst, aber ich war halt
relativ am Ende. Und das waren dann halt auch so Dinge, wo ich dachte, boah, fuck.
Oder halt, also du hast halt wirklich so gemerkt, mit deiner Konzentration musstest
du dann auch sehr aufpassen, also dass du dich so immer konzentrierst und wenn
du aber eben nicht weißt, was du gerade sagst, dass du halt ad hoc irgendwas auf die,
also irgendwas sagen kannst, was vielleicht auch sogar lustig ist,
ohne zu denken, ach scheiße, ich hab's verkackt, sondern blöd,
ich hab's vergessen, mir fällt jetzt schnell was Neues ein, dass du halt immer
so einen, nicht stecken bleiben hast im Gespräch oder in den Gesprächen.
Worten. Und dann halt viel so ein bisschen Bühne hochgehen, wie steht man vor
Leuten? Einfach so, wie steht man auf einer Bühne?
Halt nicht, dass du irgendwie hier Affenarme so nach innen gezogen hast,
sondern schön, ich bin jetzt hier.
Ja, immer mit Tada.
Tada, genau.
Haltung, nicht die Haltung.
Ja, genau, Haltung. Also genau, wie stehst du, wo stehst du auf der Bühne?
Wo stehst du auf der Bühne, damit du vom Licht gut getroffen wirst?
Du gehst genau dorthin, wo dich alles blendet, dann stehst siehst du richtig,
weil dann siehst du ja auch eh niemanden mehr.
Mikrofon richtig benutzen.
Mikrofon richtig benutzen, gut, das finde ich jetzt auch nicht so schwer. Hast ja schon Übung.
Aber das ist manchmal so ein Elend, wie die Leute an ihren Mikrofonen vorbeireden.
Genau, aber was zum Beispiel auch dann der Unterschied ist, also ich habe halt
die erste Moderation war auf der zweiten Bühne und nicht sonderlich gut gepennt,
keinen richtigen Kaffee gehabt, weil dieses Hotelkaffee ist ja jetzt nicht so
das, was man Kaffee nennen kann.
Die Hotel nicht gekämmt?
Nee, zum Glück nicht.
Kommt mal noch drauf.
Und hab halt schon so gemerkt, dass ich so ein bisschen nervös geworden bin,
weil die Speaker erst nicht aufgetaucht sind so.
Und die Speaker sind halt wirklich zum Zeitpunkt, wo sie eigentlich dran gewesen
wären, aufgetaucht erst.
Und normalerweise solltest du als Herald zum Beispiel auch Zeit überbrücken können.
Das ist mir an dem Tag...
Da bin ich überhaupt nicht gelungen. Da habe ich mich danach so geärgert.
Aber Jörn meint halt auch sehr, wenn es jetzt nicht passt und dann so auch dieses,
du guckst die Leute an und denkst dir so, es ist gerade um elf oder um zwölf,
ihr seid alle auch noch nicht so lange wach, ich soll euch jetzt irgendwie bespaßen
vor meinem ersten Kaffee.
Das ist halt so, das schlägt halt auch mal schief. Also mir ist das halt voll
fehlgeschlagen so. Und mit solchen Sachen musst du halt irgendwie auch umgehen.
Lazy Letty.
Lazy Letty, da war sie nicht vorbereitet genug. Genau. Also genau,
das hat mich auch voll megamäßig geärgert.
Aber im Prinzip, du kannst dich halt den ganzen Tag darüber ärgern oder dann
halt versuchen, das beim nächsten Mal besser zu machen.
Und es wird ja dann auch immer besser, wenn du dann auch erstmal wieder oben
stehst. So vor dieser Bühne habe ich mittlerweile keine Angst mehr.
Auch so, das ist mir dann bei dem Vortrag, den ich letztes Jahr gehalten habe, aufgefallen.
Dadurch, dass ich ständig hoch, runter, hoch, runter auf diese Bühne vor Leuten
stehe, ja du bist dran, red noch was, du noch mal.
So bei der ganzen Q&A hast du gar keine Angst mehr vor den Leuten und vor der Bühne.
Was ist denn das für eine Angst? Ich kenne dieses Gefühl ja nicht.
Keine Versagensängsten.
Lampenfieber.
Lampenfieber ist vielleicht noch nicht so richtig.
Bühnen machen mich geil. Also ich habe das schon immer gemocht.
Im Rampenlicht zu stehen.
Ja, und zwar, weil es mich fordert. Also weil es mich in Echtzeit fordert.
Deswegen mag ich das. Das ist ja auch wie mit Podcasts.
Mikro an und Und dann musst du einfach funktionieren und dann rattert bei mir das einfach alles mit.
Aber sag mir mal, ich muss in 20 Minuten was tun.
Ja, dann bin ich Prokrastinierer vor dem Herrn. Also mich prokrastiniert keiner aus.
Auch wenn deine Buchhaltung ruft?
Das ist natürlich jetzt was anderes.
Nee, aber so wichtige Dinge und so, ich kann es immer alles nur in Echtzeit
und deswegen sind Bühnen für mich irgendwie eher so eine Hilfe immer gewesen.
Also ich hab die immer so gesehen. Der Unterschied ist eventuell.
Dass du, also ob du selbst die Kontrolle hast, was gesprochen wird,
wie, ob du jetzt einen Vortrag hältst oder ob du von vielen anderen Faktoren abhängig bist,
also um dich herum wuselt und es wird jetzt halt, du hast weder eine konkrete
Vorgabe, was jetzt gesagt wird, du kannst dich nicht an irgendwas festhalten,
weil alles spontan sein muss.
Es kann alles mögliche schief gehen, es geht teilweise was schief.
Das ist ja das Tolle, das finde ich ja gerade so geil. Also wenn alles total
schief geht, dann kannst du ja machen, was du willst.
Ja, aber wenn du dann noch auf Englisch irgendwie, also das ist zum Beispiel
was, das habe ich dann halt auch gemerkt, dass das mit dem auf Englisch dann auch noch…,
War dann halt so ein Faktor mehr, der dann diese Unsicherheit.
Das sehe ich, das sehe ich.
Warte mal, bis jetzt demnächst Mandarinen dazukommt.
Hätte ich dort einen Vorteil definitiv gehabt, bei dem Talk.
Ja, aber dann zum Beispiel der letzte Talk von diesem Blog war irgendwie von
Kai Bielmann und Maha der Talk, der auch sehr zu empfehlen ist,
da kommen wir nochmal später drauf.
Und da habe ich dann auch, da habe ich dann gemerkt, so ja okay,
kann ich was zu sagen, es war halt so vom Thema her halt auch irgendwie gut
vorher eh beschrieben, was da in dem Vorschriebs von denen steht.
Das nehme ich halt auch meistens um so ein bisschen so eine nicht so,
naja, Intro-Geschichte ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel, aber dass man halt
nicht so ein zu steifes Intro da einfach fährt, sondern ein bisschen was aus
den Texten mit rausnimmt.
Und da hab ich dann halt auch gemerkt, so das hab ich dann einfach so runtergeschüttelt.
Aber das war halt auf Deutsch, da war ich dann irgendwie auch wirklich wach.
Und das hat dann wieder richtig geflutscht, auch die ganze Also gut,
Q&A finde ich eh einfach, aber so der erste Teil, eben wenn zu viel Ungewissheiten
kommen, fand ich dann in einigen Stellen so ein bisschen so.
Habe ich gesehen, war ich auch ein bisschen stolz auf dich.
Echt?
Ja.
Wie wird man denn Herald-Engel? Da muss ich speziell drauf bewerben,
weil ich gucke ja diese Vorträge jetzt nur remote, also nicht remote,
sondern aus dem Archiv raus. Und viele von den Heralden, die da sind,
die kenne ich halt irgendwoher.
Das sind irgendwie auch irgendwelche Podcaster, also werden da Leute präferenziell
genommen, die schon mal ein Mikrofon gesehen haben?
Na klar. Das heißt, du musst jetzt nicht sagen, ich will da mal stehen und mir
einen Hampelmann machen, sondern brauchst schon irgendwie. Also es gibt beides.
Es geht beides. Also du hast sowohl, also je nachdem, wenn wieder neue reinkommen
sollen, also es ist glaube ich jetzt auch gerade nicht offen gewesen,
dass wir neue reingenommen haben, weil das halt auch ein großer Aufwand für
Eon und Lindworm halt ist, die neuen einzuarbeiten, zu gucken, ob es passt.
Und meistens haben sie dann so viele Bewerbungen von Leuten,
die sie nicht kennen, was halt einfach irgendwie 100 Leute zu quasi Bewerbungsgespräche,
doof gesagt, zu führen, ist natürlich echt ein bisschen gerade.
Und viele Sachen, genau, Holger ist da ja auch drin, der hat ja schon mal so
das eine oder andere Mal ins Mikrofon gesprochen und so kam das bei mir eigentlich
auch, dass ich die LNP...
das wollte ich gerade mit Holgi sagen, mit Henning moderiert habe, die Pre-Show für euch.
Und dann kam ja schon irgendwie sehr positives Feedback von dieser Moderation
zurück. Und dann dachte ich mir so, ja, vielleicht ist das ja was, was sein könnte.
Dann habe ich halt Lindworm gefragt und er hat mich halt nur angeguckt und meinte
so, ihr habt das als Bewerbung aufgenommen.
Du bist angenommen, so nach dem Motto. Wir haben nochmal kurz darüber gequatscht.
Aber er meint halt schon so, das fällt natürlich einfacher, jemanden reinzunehmen,
den man schon mal auf einer Bühne gesehen hat, wo man schon mal sieht,
so okay, da passiert was und ich meine, nicht bei jedem läuft immer alles perfekt,
das wissen die halt auch, das kennen die auch von sich so, aber,
so ein bisschen auf der Bühne nicht zu sehr Angst zu haben, ist schon mal ganz
gut und ich meine, zu sehr Angst würde ich jetzt auch nicht sagen,
habe ich, aber ich würde da nicht so sagen, dass ich da komplett unbeeindruckt bin.
Ich finde das ehrlich gesagt ganz interessant, wie sich dieses Herald-Ding wirklich
zu so einer neuen Kunstform entwickelt auf dem Kongress, weil das war sagen
wir mal, früher gab es das gar nicht. Irgendwann.
Doch, man nannte das mal MC.
Nein, es wurde einfach, Talks begannen einfach.
Achso, ja.
Niemand war da auf der Bühne, um das irgendwie anzukündigen oder so.
Ich weiß auch gar nicht mehr so ganz genau, wann das angefangen hat.
Das ging eigentlich so richtig erst in Hamburg, glaube ich, los.
In Berlin kann ich mich da, oder?
Ich weiß nicht mehr so ganz genau, also auf jeden Fall in den letzten zehn Jahren
hat sich das erst herausgebildet und ist gerade so in den letzten Jahren,
Also unter anderem, ich weiß wie viel Aufwand er da teilweise getrieben hat,
also wirklich so Interviews mit jedem Einzelnen geführt vorher,
im Vorfeld des Kongresses, Wochen vorher und die Leute so ein Bewerbungsgespräch
quasi wirklich geführt, um einfach zu merken, okay alles klar,
das ist auch was für dich.
so und ja jetzt kriegt das langsam so einen Drive, wo man merkt die treten auch
so als Team, wieder so als OK,
auf so, die haben sich irgendwie abgesprochen über einen bestimmten Style und
bestimmte, auch sagen wir mal so eine,
ich sehe, dass immer mehr Antworten gegeben werden auf diese Frage mit,
was soll das eigentlich, also was ist quasi die Dienstleistung die hier an den Kongress,
getan wird und das ist natürlich für Stage Management einfach schon mal sehr wichtig.
Ist jemand da, der irgendwas kommunizieren kann für die Teilnehmer,
ist irgendwie dadurch auch immer klar, so jetzt geht's los, jetzt ist so dieser
Punkt auch gekommen und dieses Jahr.
Muss ich sagen, habe ich auch bisher zumindest noch nichts gesehen, was mir zu doof vorkam.
Also es waren in den letzten Jahren schon so ein paar Ausreißer,
wo ich mir manchmal dachte, so das muss Musste jetzt aber auch nicht unbedingt sein.
Es hat jetzt schon so teilweise so,
Züge gehabt, wo wie sagt man das so ein bisschen so Fremdschämen mäßig,
weil es dann eigentlich dem Talk nicht, sich dem Talk zu sehr aufgedrängt hat. Sagen wir es mal so.
Und das scheint zu verschwinden und durch was anderes ersetzt zu werden.
Und das finde ich eigentlich ganz cool, weil,
das trägt auch einfach nochmal also mittlerweile, am Anfang war ich skeptisch
aber mittlerweile trägt es dazu bei dass einfach über die Aufzeichnung natürlich
dann später dieser Kongress einfach nochmal einen Zacken runder.
Rüberkommt als er es ohnehin schon tut ich meine, es ist einfach wenn ich irgendwas
wirklich geil fand schon immer auf dem Kongress und was mich in den letzten
Jahren nahezu erschlägt ist dieses,
diese ganzen Hacker im allerweitesten Wortsinne eint ja so ein Grundgefühl.
Nämlich dieses, das muss doch besser gehen.
Egal was es ist, es muss immer alles noch besser gehen.
Und das geht jetzt seit Jahrzehnten und insbesondere so im letzten Jahrzehnt.
Ist das der totale Wahnsinn. Ja, also was da alles besser werden kann.
Da werden dann einfach komplett neue Ox gegründet, die man vorher irgendwie
gar nicht auf dem Zettel hatte, dass es irgendwie so was überhaupt gehen könnte.
Ja, bis hin zum Waffel-Operation-Center, die sich halt einfach um die perfekte
Ausgabe von perfekten Waffeln kostenlos kümmern. Warum auch nicht?
Ja, das ist eher eine Stilblüte in diesem ganzen Zirkus. Aber diese ganzen anderen
Gruppen, die wir teilweise schon besprochen haben, die alle irgendwie was finden mit,
hier müsste man doch was besser machen können und hier könnte ich ja mal meine
Skills einbringen und dann wird es einfach getan und am Anfang denkt man sich
so okay, mal gucken, was dabei rauskommt so,
und dann treibt es aber dann irgendwie nach zwei, drei Versuchen auch,
eigene Blüten und irgendwann wird da wieder was geiles draus und dann passieren
da wieder andere Sachen drauf und das nimmt irgendwie alles überhaupt gar keinen
Ende und ich finde das total mega, dieser ganze Kongress hat diesen inneren
Anspruch, der von allen getragen wird,
einfach schlicht und ergreifend die geilste Veranstaltung zu sein,
die man sich nur vorstellen kann.
Mit genau keinem Sponsor und keinem Werbeplakat und keinen überhöhten Preisen,
sondern sozusagen aus dem Nichts,
zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr innerhalb von wenigen Tagen entsteht so ein
gigantischer Raum, der mittlerweile ein komplettes Messegelände findet. Das ist einfach absurd.
Das ist wirklich wirklich absurden, sprengt mein Hirn.
Großartig. Was Uwe Faller hier auch nochmal anspricht, dass man dem,
als Herald dem Speaker eine Sicherheit gibt.
Ich würde auch sagen, nicht nur eine Sicherheit, sondern auch so ein bisschen eine Würdigung gibt.
So hier, das ist jetzt deine Bühne, du kündigst ihn einfach auch an und nicht
nur so, der nächste Talk ist und dann kommt der Titel, sondern irgendwie versuchst
du da noch ein bisschen was draus zu machen.
Das finde ich halt total wichtig, weil das auch so ein bisschen eine Würdigung
ist. so ey, du bist jetzt gerade derjenige, der auf die Bühne kommt,
du erzählst der Masse jetzt hier irgendwas.
Wir können sogar deinen Namen richtig aussprechen.
In der Regel kann man das ja, genau, in der Regel geht das.
Nee, und das ist, wir sind halt auch schon letztes Jahr und jetzt halt dieses
Jahr auch wieder, dass dann auch wirklich Speaker am Ende ankommen und sagen, danke.
Und ich bin dann eher so ein bisschen perplex und denke, wofür gerade? Was, was?
Aber dass die sich halt auch einfach freuen, wenn man denen so ein bisschen
die Sicherheit gibt, sich ein bisschen um sie halt auch kümmert.
oder ich meine, wenn es halt auch Lampenfieber zum Beispiel gibt,
es gibt ja auch eben, Youssef ist halt außerdem auch der Lampenfieberbeauftragte
und kann sich dann halt auch irgendwie ganz herrlich um einen kümmern.
Deswegen ja, das macht auf jeden Fall schon Spaß.
Ja, in der Chat bestätige ich auch nochmal meine Vermutung, dass auch Nick Farr,
dieser amerikanische Gast, den wir uns irgendwann eingetreten hatten, so 24,
25, C3 herum, erheblich dazu beigetragen hat, so das eine oder andere zu starten,
gerade was so diese Ansprache auf Bühnen betrifft.
und jetzt wird es hier auch gerade nochmal erwähnt und ich will das auch nochmal
erwähnen, weil es einfach auch dieses Jahr wieder so mega cool war ist dieses
Chaos-Post-Ding das ist wohl so eine ursprüngliche Idee kommt ja von Burning Man,
also da beim Burning Man diese Riesenparty da in der Wüste in Nevada,
da gibt es halt auch so ein Post-Office und irgendwie fand das dann so auch
seinen Weg, diese Idee auf einem Kongress und wurde dann halt zur Chaos-Post.
Ich glaube, als wir über das Camp gesprochen haben, haben wir auch schon über
die Chaos-Post gesprochen, aber auch da, das ist jetzt auch wieder ein gutes Beispiel,
für so ein Projekt, was so damit anfing, dass ein paar Leute Postkarten ausgetragen
haben und mittlerweile, ich weiß nicht, habt ihr das mitbekommen?
Es gab das ja in diesem dezentralen war das da?
War das da auch die Chaos-Post? Nee, wo war denn das? das. Egal,
auf jeden Fall, Infrastructure, genau, Infrastructure Talk am Schluss war irgendwie
auch nochmal die Chaos-Post. Und es gab.
Postkarten, es gab geheime Botschaften, es gab ein gesungenes Telegramm.
Man konnte Leuten ein gesungenes Telegramm wie bei Brasil ein Film,
den du unbedingt gucken musst.
Das sagte mir ein gemeinsamer Freund von uns auch.
Ja, genau, also wer bei gesungenen Telegramm nicht sofort an Brasil denkt,
muss unbedingt Brasil sehen, der einer der tollsten Filme überhaupt ist.
man konnte Post nach außen aufgeben, also man konnte die Chaos-Post tatsächlich
dazu benutzen, einen frankierten wie ich nehme, Annehmerbrief einfach in die Welt zu schicken.
Du darfst keine Post-Wertzeichen dort haben. Das ist mir auf dem Camp aufgefallen.
Ich bin da hin, hab gesagt, würde gerne was nach außen schicken.
Sagen sie, ja, wir können dir eine Briefmarke schenken. Du kannst gerne was,
spenden, aber du kannst keine Briefmarke bei uns kaufen.
Achso. Aber gegen eine Spende kann man eine Geschenk-Tote kaufen.
Ich hätte auch nicht spenden müssen. Also war ernst gemeint.
Ihr habt dann aber auch was natürlich gespendet, aber trotzdem,
sie meinten, sie dürfen wieder mal aus Dollargründen, welcome to Germany,
dürfen sie kein Postwertzeichen verkaufen.
Aber das ist beim VOG und beim ZERT auch, also ZERT hat jetzt Merch,
dürfen sie offiziell nicht verkaufen, sondern es kann,
es wurde gegen Spende abgegeben und es kann jetzt eventuell irgendwie gegen
Spende erworben werden, da weiß ich noch nicht, wie sich das nun letztendlich
äußert, aber das ist bei den, bei vielen.
Peter Hannes und sein dummer Bruder, die einen Kiosk betreiben,
verkaufen dir eine Briefmarke. Warum können die mir da auf dem Camp da nicht
eine Briefmarke verkaufen?
Das hat sicherlich irgendeinen Grund, den ich aber jetzt auch gerade nicht kenne.
Aber ich bin mir sicher, dass es einen Grund gibt.
Ich komme nachher noch zum Thema, wo du dir echt einen Kopf fasst,
wie einmal Deutschland, Deutschland galore.
Sehr schön, ich freue mich jetzt schon drauf. Ja genau, dann hier,
Chad erwähnt es auch gerade, dann gab es Liebesbriefe mit Parfüm.
Also man konnte parfümierte Liebesbriefe verschicken, was sich wohl als nicht
so eine geile Idee herausgestellt hat, weil sie dann beim Briefe sortieren irgendwie
alle massenhaft in diese Duftwolken eingetaucht sind und das kam wohl nicht so gut.
Und,
Und ich glaube, es gab sogar Einschreiben mit Rückschein irgendwie.
Also du könntest jetzt sozusagen auch was verschicken und es dir danach auch
nochmal bestätigen lassen, dass es zugestellt wurde.
Ich weiß auch, dass es diese Future-Post gibt.
Genau und du kannst dir oder anderen Leuten Post auf kommende Veranstaltungen schicken.
Das ist super.
Das ist allein die Idee. Das ist viel geiler.
Wenn man in die Vergangenheit welche schenkt. Es gibt auch Berichte da.
Ich habe fast Post gekriegt, denn während ich auf meinem Kongress in Stockholm
war, auf irgendeinem Messenger-Kanal hat mich einer angefunkt und gesagt,
hier ist das C3-Post-Office.
Hier ist Post für dich. Wo finden wir dich? Und ich so, hier,
so link geschickt. Und die so, äh?
Wie, du bist gar nicht in Leipzig? Nein, bin ich nicht. wie so, hm, okay.
Und dann?
Und dann schrieb mir zwei Tage später Roddy eine Message, hat gesagt,
hier ist was abgegeben worden für dich, ich nehm's mit nach Berlin und bring's
dir mit in die Meta-Ebene.
Der leider heute krank ist und deswegen nicht auszustellen konnte.
Ja genau, die Dinger finden immer irgendwie ihren Weg, das ist,
das finde ich auch wirklich krank.
Gibt's da nicht eine Story, dass man mal versucht hat, was an Alexander Gerst
zu schicken, als er da oben rumflog? Wie, keine Ahnung?
Kann ich nicht ausschließen, aber ich weiß es nicht.
Chat, bitte suchen Sie. Such. Computer.
Irgendwie gab es da mal eine Story, glaube ich, dass sie dann irgendwie versucht
haben über ESA und dann das eingescannt und irgendwie frage mich.
Ich weiß es nicht. Auf jeden Fall ist es ein tolles Projekt und ich finde es
super, mit welcher Intensität das betrieben wird.
Ich war dann irgendwann mal bei diesem Verteilzentrum und war total geprellt, was da alles ging.
Die Karte ging zum DLR.
Das ist das Einfachste.
Ja, okay, ein bisschen mehr Effort, eine kleine Rakete bauen wäre schon,
oder Feridast hochschicken wäre jetzt schon cooler gewesen, aber naja, okay, eben.
So, wollen wir uns noch auf den Kongress inhaltlich stürzen?
Ein paar Talks empfehlen zum Gucken?
Also ein tolles Erlebnis hatte ich noch, was ich jetzt endlich nach dem,
ich weiß nicht, wie lange sind wir jetzt in Leipzig? Weiß ich nicht, schon länger.
Dritte Mal war das jetzt.
Ich habe es endlich geschafft, mit dem guten Nikolas eine Runde um das Leipziger
Messegelände zu laufen. Das fand ich auch ein...
Nein, du hast Sport gemacht?
Ja, natürlich habe ich Sport gemacht.
Super.
Sie macht Sport, ich arbeite. So ist die Arbeitsteilung.
Ey, diese beschissene Apple Watch, die erkennt das Inlineskaten nicht als Sport. Ich habe es gefeiert.
Insofern ergänzen wir uns wunderbar.
Ja, genau. Nee, das hat mich sehr gefreut, Nikolas und ich haben es ewig,
glaube ich, versucht, irgendwie mal zusammen laufen zu gehen.
Einmal ums Gelände herum.
Ja, nur eine kleine 5-Kilometer-Runde. 5 Kilometer?
Einmal rum?
Ja.
Echt? Also so Außenzaun sozusagen drumherum oder wie?
Wenn du kurz mal anhalten würdest, also du weißt ja, wo das Hotel ist.
Ja.
Und dann irgendwie einmal die
gerade Straße, die alte Dübener Landstraße entlang und dann die S9 quasi.
Und dann ja einmal um das Messegelände rum und dann wieder diese Hauptstraße,
die dabei zwischen Messe und Globus entlang Also vom.
Hotel einmal drumherum.
Genau, auf der Uhr waren halt nicht genau fünf, deswegen sind wir nochmal eine
Runde ums Hotel drumherum gelaufen, damit die fünf draufstehen,
weil fünf geht ja gar nicht.
Verstehe.
Genau, und dann haben wir da noch eine kleine Runde gedreht.
Das war ziemlich schön und so, ähm, was ist, wo läufst du denn lang?
Das ist eine kleine extra Runde um die.
Achso, nee, wir sind um das Hotel in der Tat eine Runde rum. Achso. Aber ist okay.
Kann man auch so machen. Okay, das ist ja gar nicht so schlecht,
fünf Kilometer, nicht schlecht.
Ja, was heißt nicht schlecht, also gerne auch länger ja eigentlich,
muss ich gerade laufen, aber nee, das war total cool.
Irgendwie auch, also vor allem an dem Tag, an dem wir laufen waren,
war es so sonnig, so minus drei Grad, glaube ich, und die Sonne hat geschehen. Das war richtig geil.
Sehr viel Spaß gemacht.
Guck mal, da kann man auch noch mal ein Ok draus machen. Also so Sport.
Running Operation. Ja, ich habe das Yoga-Operation-Center schon vorgeschlagen. Das Jock.
Das würden dann Michi und ich betreiben.
Gab es das nicht schon?
Weiß ich nicht.
War da nicht irgendwas? Da war doch irgendwas mit Yoga irgendwo.
Würde mich nicht wundern, es gibt es überall.
Neben der Massagebar?
Wo gab es eine Massagebar?
Ich glaube, das war bei … Ja, in der Halle 3 gab es tatsächlich … Welche war Halle 3?
Die mit der Chaos-West-Bühne. Ja, auf der anderen Seite, hinter dem Gruselhaus.
Das Hortet-Haus, genau.
Da gab es ein paar ganz interessante neue Orte, die da entstanden sind,
wo es teilweise sehr entspannt zu ging.
Da konnte man so Entspannungsübungen machen.
Also von Yoga habe ich jetzt nichts gesehen, aber ehrlich gesagt,
jetzt wo ich drüber nachdenke, ist es ziemlich wahrscheinlich, dass da was gab.
Das gibt es ja auch immer auf dem Camp eigentlich.
Und auch sowas, dass dafür auch Raum ist, ja, ist einfach mega.
Ich finde, du bist halt, egal was du auf diesem Kongress machst,
ob du jemand bist, der involviert ist oder nur Besucher ist,
du musst dir einfach die Zeit nehmen, dich rauszunehmen oder dich macht dieser
Kongress von hinten bis vorne fertig.
So muss man ja einfach mal sagen. Es ist halt einfach riesig,
es ist lang, es sind viele Menschen, viel Stress, viel Eindrücke und ich weiß
nicht, das ist glaube ich auch ganz wichtig, dass man sich da mal rausnehmen
kann und nicht immer denkt, man müsste alles mitnehmen.
Naja, klar, auf jeden Fall. Also das ist auch mein Schlüssel zum Erfolg.
Einfach schön entspannt rangehen und andererseits glaube ich gehört auch so
eine gewisse Überforderung am Anfang zumindest auch dazu.
Also man muss auch mal wild in dem Strudel gewesen sein, um da seine Grenzen
kennenzulernen, aber einfach möglichst viel von dem Wahnsinn trotzdem mitgenommen zu haben.
Ja.
Vielen Dank.
Ich kriege hier gerade noch eine Message von der Seite reingedrückt.
Dass auf dem Kongress nichts verkauft werden darf, beziehungsweise nur mit gemeinnützigen
Hintergrund im weitesten Sinne, ist der Grund, warum die Veranstaltung so geil
ist und wird von uns kontrolliert.
Sonst wäre es eine Messe mit tausend Verkaufsständen und keine Aktion von Freiwilligen
und Ehrenamtlichen. Ja, sehe ich.
Ich glaube aber, die Postler hatten mir auf dem Camp erzählt,
dass sie das nicht dürfen, weil sie ihnen die Post-it nicht erlauben würde.
Ja, glaube ich auch.
Also weil Briefmark ist jetzt ja nur wirklich, Da kommen ja jetzt nicht Leute
hin und machen tausend Stände auf, wo sie Briefmarken verkaufen.
So, lass uns über Talks reden, über Content. Contento.
Talks, die ihr gesehen habt auf dem Konkurs.
Jetzt möchte ich erst nochmal andere Logistik-Sachen. Letztes Mal warst du ja
stramm da mit Wohnwagen und so. Warst du auch wieder mit Wohnwagen da?
Und eine ganze Family rein und WLAN-Antenne aufs Dach oder wie?
Dusche?
Man kann, man kriegt da alles und ich war ja auch nicht alleine da auf dem Platz.
Wo ist denn dieser Platz, wo die Wohnwagen stehen?
Das ist blöd für die Hörer.
Aber du kannst ja mal kurz mit deiner Maus über die E auf dem Bildschirm prangende Karte fahren.
Ja, wenn man sich das Gelände mal anschaut, dann sieht man, dass die Messe halt
nicht nur aus Hallen besteht, sondern auch noch ein großes Freigelände hat.
Ja, es gibt ja auch einen Parkplatz, der bis kurz vor Dresden reicht.
Ich weiß, da haben sie viel Geld.
Ein Ausstellungsgelände sozusagen. Also nicht ein Parkplatz,
sondern das ist ja Ausstellungsbereich.
Also wenn du da eine Sommerveranstaltung hast, dann hast du ja draußen,
was weiß ich, Karawanen. Wenn die da Karawanen haben, dann dürfte da wahrscheinlich
alles vollstehen. Ich war da jetzt noch nicht, aber das funktioniert da ganz
gut und die haben da eben entsprechend verfestigten Boden und da kann man Da.
Wo jetzt deine Hand da gerade ist, oder was?
Also neben Halle 2 oder neben Halle 4? Ach, oder einfach alles?
Alles.
Alles. Halle 2 und 4.
Was ich übrigens sehr interessant finde, weil offensichtlich sind die da alle
zu Hause und die normalen Leipziger, weil das ist eine relativ fiese Abzocknummer,
die, wenn da sonst so Messe ist oder sonst so was, dann ist dieser Platz da
draußen vermietet über irgendeine Vermietungsfirma, das heißt,
das wird gar nicht von der Messe betrieben, sondern es sind irgendwelche anderen
Leute, die dann sagen, Alter,
hier stehst du mal, das kostet dich halt für eine drei Tage Veranstaltung,
kostet dich halt mal 200 Euro oder sonst so was.
Und deswegen wundert mich das, warum die jetzt das plötzlich aufgeben und sagen,
da könnten wir jetzt doch ordentlich die Nerds abkassieren.
Du redest von einer anderen Fläche, das ist hier dieser Außenbereich?
Ne, ich rede von den, da wo jetzt deine Hand da ist. Neben der Halle 2 und neben
der Halle 4. Das ist normalerweise eine coole Abzockfläche.
Weiß ich nicht, drüber ist es generell so, dass diese Messe Leipzig mit diversen
Unterorganisationen und Subkontraktoren ausgestattet sind.
Verschiedene Dinge, die wir dort brauchen, müssen wir von diesen Subkontraktoren,
beziehen und nicht alles aus einer Hand.
Catering ist so ein Bereich, der ohnehin immer komplex ist bei allen Veranstaltungen,
das ist hier auch so, aber es betrifft auch so Security Aspekte,
es betrifft Miete, Stühle, Tische, so ein Kram.
Also da sind so diverse Dinge sind in andere Unternehmen ausgelagert,
aus welchen Gründen auch immer.
Ich persönlich habe immer die Erfahrung gemacht, dass eigentlich so ein Veranstaltungsort
für einen als Teilnehmer besser funktioniert, wenn das nicht so ist.
Aber da steckst du halt nicht drin. Das ist halt da einfach so,
damit muss man irgendwie klarkommen.
Was jetzt das Außengelände betrifft, weiß ich überhaupt nicht,
wie das sonst so ist und ich weiß auch jetzt nicht genau, wer da noch mit ins Boot gezogen ist.
Ich habe ja da 10 Tage verbracht im September, um da was zu basteln. Und auch auch in Halle 2.
Und wir haben die ganze Zeit während des Aufbaus da gestanden und klar,
wir haben auch Material da rein und rausgebracht, hat keine Sau interessiert,
aber als denn die eigentliche Veranstaltung war, kamen dann diese externen, diese nicht,
diese nicht Messe Leipzig Typen an und meinten so, das ganze Gelände hier draußen
ist jetzt von uns gemietet, wenn du jetzt hier stehen willst in der Veranstaltung,
dann rück mal rüber den Hunni.
Ich so, okay, verstehe.
Ja gut, ich meine, ein bisschen was bezahlen musste man ja auch,
wenn man ein Wohnwagen ist.
Es gab ja auch diverse Infrastrukturen. Es gab da irgendwie Klo,
Dusche, alles, volles Programm.
Aber die Nachfrage war auch hier mal wieder größer, als bedient werden konnte.
Camper-Tickets waren alle komplett weg und jeder Platz war voll und hätten mal
locker nochmal 50% mehr Leute da.
Wo hast du jetzt nämlich standen? Da, wo jetzt daneben den Hallen oder da kurz vor Dresden in dem Teil?
Nein, es gibt hier nur diese eine Außenfläche. Das ist der eingezäunte Bereich
und da sind die ganzen Also neben den Hallen. Genau, neben den Hallen.
Und da schmeißen sie dann noch irgendwie einen Duschcontainer hin vom Camp oder
was? Oder wie so aus der Richtung was?
Nicht vom Camp, sondern halt einen Duschcontainer. Sowas kann man ja mieten
und das steht dann da halt. Und dann kannst du es benutzen.
Verstehe.
Das ist schon echtes Winterglamping.
War jetzt aber auch nicht so kalt, ne?
Es war auch nicht so furchtbar kalt, aber es hätte mir jetzt auch relativ wenig
ausgemacht. Ich war entsprechend vorbereitet.
Ich glaube, die meisten Leute waren das im Wesentlichen.
Und ich finde einfach diesen Luxus, da direkt an der Veranstaltung dran zu sein, einfach mega.
Weil das spart ja im Prinzip, je nachdem, wurde untergebracht bis halt nochmal
eine Viertel, halbe Stunde oder Stunde pro Tag. und das ist natürlich kein Fehler.
Sieben Minuten vom Hotel mit den Inlineskates zur Messe.
Mit Inlineskates?
Fünf Minuten zu Fuß, mit Umweg.
Und ich bin aber nicht schnell gefahren.
Ja, sieben Minuten klingt jetzt auch nicht besonders schnell. Nee.
Aber jetzt reden wir über Inhalt.
Nö. Wie seid ihr denn hingekommen? Du klar mit deinem Camper und Auto dran und ihr?
Zug.
Ja, mit über Umweg, über die Family. schön einmal Sachsen mitgenommen.
Das machen ja die meisten, das in irgendeiner Form mit Weihnachten zu koordinieren.
Bis halt auf die Leute, die halt da über Weihnachten sind und irgendwie Container.
Ich wollte jetzt die Kongressen meiner Familie aus dem Weg zu gehen.
Ach, du brauchst mit Aal auf die 30 Tage.
Nee, nicht ganz. So viel Urlaub kann ich mir nicht nehmen.
Die Funktion hatte der Kongress schon immer irgendwie für bestimmte Leute.
Das war die ganz geschickte Überleitung zum Content, weil nämlich einer der
besten Vorträge, die ich gehört habe, war nämlich der über diese Zuggeschichten,
bahnbrechende Mathematik.
David Kriesel heißt der, ne? Kriesel? Kriesel.
Als auffälligstes Fangirl dieses Talks, Letti, erteile ich dir das Wort.
Du hast das nicht heraldet, das wüsste ich, aber das waren zwei Heralde sogar, kann das sein?
Achso, ja, ja, das waren Skripti und Puppe. Ich habe den aber erst im Nachgang
gesehen, weil der zu einer Zeit lief, wo ich, glaube ich, am Späti stand.
Aber sehr geil. Ich mag es ja ohnehin, wenn Leute Vorträge halten,
die mal einen kompletten Satz sprechen können. Das kann der Mann durchaus. Absolut.
Und ein Mathematik- oder ein Statistik-Thema, der hatte ich geil zu präsentieren.
Hut ab, finde ich schon. Okay, hat Spaß gemacht.
Ich werfe fix mal noch den Link zum Talk hinein.
Alle wissen, worüber wir sprechen.
Er sprach nämlich über Bahnfahren. Deswegen war jetzt da die Überleitung von Wie kommt man da hin?
Genau, ach, wo ist denn der Slack? Da ist er, da haben wir ihn.
Genau, wir sprechen vom Bahn-Mining-Talk, in dem David auseinandergenommen hat,
was der Aufhänger ist, fand ich auch ganz interessant, dass er die Statistik
der Deutschen Bahn gesehen hat und sich gedacht hat, wie 76 Prozent der Züge sind pünktlich.
Was heißt das denn eigentlich und was ist mit dem Rest?
Und ist das meine eigene Experience?
Genau, das ist die eigene. Und er hat den Vortrag halt echt spannend aufgebaut
mit diesem reinen, ich sag mal, den Analysen, was ist so in seinen Daten drin.
Also er hat die Daten ja auch gescrapt von der Bahn, beziehungsweise sich aus der API rausgeholt.
Aber nicht in einem Schrank runtergeladen, sondern hat halt seit fast einem
Jahr diese Dinger alle Stunde mal gepollt, diese Bahn-Reserver und die Daten
daraus gelutscht und so hin gespeichert.
Er hat sie halt selber gespeichert und dann hat er halt auch erklärt,
wie geht man eigentlich daran, überhaupt an so eine Projekte ran.
Also dass er halt zum einen zeigt, so hier, das sind meine Daten,
das habe ich gemacht, das habe ich drinnen gesehen.
Und das ist im Übrigen, wie man da rangeht. Und was ich halt auch super cool
fand, dieses glaubt nicht, also man kann den Daten prinzipiell eigentlich nicht
so direkt trauen, ohne man hat eine Referenz, dass man sieht,
ja okay, das wird schon so stimmen, was da drin sind.
Und er hat halt dann einfach gesagt, ich weiß nicht, ob ich meinen Daten vertrauen
kann, mache ich doch einfach mal die Reverse-Statistik zur Bahn-Statistik.
Und was sagt mir das denn dann?
Sind die Daten, die ich da rausbekomme, ähnlich? Und das war ja auch sehr ähnlich.
Man hat irgendwie auch so einen Überblick bekommen, wie geht man an so ein Thema ran?
Was muss man sich nämlich auch rechtlich da reinholen? Und das fand ich auch
spannend, dass er sagte, ey, wenn ihr nicht wisst, ob ihr die Daten nutzen dürft,
so ohne weiteres, und ob ihr sie automatisiert wegspeichern dürft,
dann holt euch verdammt nochmal einen Anwalt, der die AGBs liest.
Und David hat sich ja dann auch das Einverständnis der Deutschen Bahn geholt,
dass er die Daten überhaupt abspeichern kann.
Und das hat auch schön transparent mal aufgezeigt, wie das funktioniert hat
und dass sie damit jetzt auch fein waren, dass er, wie hat er es gesagt,
einen kleinen Community-Vortrag darüber hält.
Das fand ich war so ein bisschen...
Ich fand ja den Wort mit der Bahnbrechen in Mathematik fand ich viel besser.
Den kann ich mich gar nicht mehr erinnern.
Die Bahn hat ja, pass auf, einer der Knackpunkte und was ich übrigens sehr schön
fand an diesem Vortrag war, dass er halt kein Bahn-Bashing betrieben hat.
Er hat gesagt, guck mal, wir rechnen das jetzt aus und das kann auch bei mir
falsch sein und das Einzige, was ihn halt so ein bisschen angeprangert hat,
ist, dass die Bahn ihre Statistik wohl ganz ordentlich macht,
theoretisch, aber dass sie halt ihren Datenbestand nicht so pflegt,
wie man sollte und zwar mit einer ziemlich hanebüchenen Begründung.
Was die Bahn nämlich macht und das ist so der Knackpunkt oder der Höhepunkt
von seinem Vortrag, den spoiler ich jetzt einfach mal, ist, dass sie sagt,
die Bahn die Bahn berechnet ihre Pünktlichkeit nur auf den Dingern,
wo auch wirklich ein Zug angekommen ist.
Wenn ein Zug oder ein Halt ausfällt, dann fällt der aus ihrer Statistik einfach raus. Komplett.
Und zwar mit der Begründung, sie wüssten nicht, wie man das mathematisch abbilden würde.
Da gibt es eine schöne Folie von ihm, wer sozusagen die bahnbrechende Mathematik
dort einführt und meint, also ich würde das ja so machen, dass die einfach als
unpünktlich berechnet werden. Aber okay.
Er hat auch einen schönen Vortragsstil. Das ist wirklich einer der schönen Vorträge
dort, der mir sehr gut gefallen hat.
Also will man jetzt nicht mehr spoilern, aber schaut euch den mal an,
auch wenn ihr jetzt nicht direkt geil drauf seid, weil er eben ist auch nicht
so polemisch, so scheiß Bahn und hin und her, sondern er sagt zum Beispiel, dass die Bahn,
also die offiziellen Bahnstatistiken, die du sagst mit den 75 Prozent,
ist ja so bundesweit alles.
Das ist ja Quatsch. Er hat gesagt, dass die Bahn zum Beispiel,
auf seinen Daten, dass die Bahn in Ostdeutschland viel pünktlicher ist als zum
Beispiel in Köln oder in Hamburg.
Und dass zum Beispiel Regionalzüge auch wesentlich höheren Pünktlichkeitswert
haben, als die ICs, die quer durch die ganze Republik kacheln und so.
Aber das finde ich halt eben, also war informativ und er hat auch noch ein paar
schöne Gags am Ende, die ich jetzt nicht spoiler, aber ganz am Ende gibt es
noch den, was kann man jetzt mit solchen Daten praktisch anstellen?
Stichwort Flex-Ticket.
Und,
also jetzt kann.
Ich wirklich nur empfehlen das.
Ding hat mir gut gefallen ja und vor allem auch was er zum Schluss gesagt hat so generell zu,
politischen Lage der Zeit und so zu Data Science an sich fand ich sehr sehr
geil, also das lohnt sich auf jeden Fall mal anzuhören Tim, ich habe im Übrigen
das Gefühl, dass man einer, der ist aus,
Einer der Kopfhörer ist aus bei mir.
Ja, die ist taub.
Ja, ich habe mich gerade gewundert.
Dann wackel doch mal hier an
diesem Kabel. Vielleicht ist da gerade ein Wackelkontakt oder am Stecker.
Du wirst jetzt nicht wissen, was es sonst ist. Du kriegst da ein Monosignal von daher.
Ich habe, naja, okay. Eingartig. Naja, irritiert auch ein bisschen. Na, wer weiß.
Aber ich kann auch eine Notoperation machen.
Oh Gott, nicht, dass die Metaebene offline geht.
Nein, die Metaebene ist natürlich auf.
Wir sind nicht steril. Wir dürfen nicht operieren.
Nein, die ist auf Redundanz ausgelegt. Nimm einfach mal dieses.
Darf ich jetzt einfach Kabel ziehen?
Du darfst einfach Kabel ziehen. Wir machen vorher mal kurz dein Mikrofon aus
und dann geht das auch irgendwie.
Tatsächlich ist der Bahntalk noch auf meiner Liste, weil ich bin während des
Kongresses irgendwie nicht dazu gekommen.
Und ich bin jetzt gerade so nach und nach dabei nachzuholen.
Letti wundert sich gerade, dass das neue Ding nicht geht, was daran liegt,
dass Tim dich gemutet hat.
Da ist so ein Schnupsi, den er reindrücken möchte.
Schnupsi reindrücken, genau. Du musst nur den Nippel durch die Lasche ziehen.
Ganz einfach sozusagen.
Ja,
du bist doch auch Data Scientist, dann ist doch das sozusagen ein...
Wenn es um Statistiken geht, kann man mich ziemlich schnell begeistern,
vor allem, wenn sie gut gemacht sind oder wenn die Daten schön sind.
Du wirst Spaß haben an dem.
Ich glaube auch und ich freue mich drauf.
Ich bin jetzt halt gerade dabei, so im Nachhinein nachzugucken,
nachzuhören, auszuprobieren, was so geht. Bist du wieder da?
Danke, aber es könnte auch sein.
Dass es… Hörst du uns jetzt wieder beidseitig?
Ich glaube, ich habe jetzt langsam die Ohrenschmerzen.
Verstehe.
Du meinst, es ist jetzt genauso wie vorher?
Naja, es ist besser.
Zert. Zert.
Ohrenspülung.
Ab ins Bett.
Mit Halswickel.
Bevor du jetzt auf den nächsten Lieblingstor kommst, nämlich den von Linus.
Kurzer Hinweis, ist, wir werden diese Sendung auch noch mit einem kleinen Ausschnitt
aus diesem Talk von Herrn Griesel abschließen. Ja, okay.
Spoiler. Ich will jetzt nur gerade kurz einhaken auf das Thema Bahn,
damit ich auch noch eins meiner Kongress-Erlebnisse loswerde.
Man kann ja nicht mehr nach Schweden fliegen.
Das ist ja verboten inzwischen. Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht,
fahre ich mal auf mein Schweden-Event mit der Bahn.
Mit dem Nachzug?
Nee, der fährt nur im Sommer. Er fährt jetzt aber wieder. Ich habe jetzt gerade
gestern gesehen, dass der Nattog nach Malmö jetzt demnächst wieder fährt von
irgendeiner anderen Bahn, nicht von einer deutschen Bahn oder sonst irgendwas,
sondern von irgendeiner anderen Bahn, irgendeiner schwedischen Bahn.
Dieses Snelltag.
Snelltog.
Ja, diesen nicht zu empfehlen.
Egal, aber er fährt jetzt wieder
Nachtzug nach Malmö jetzt ab Frühjahr wieder bis in den Sommer rein.
Ich bin auch über Malmö gefahren, weil die haben ja, den muss man ja auch leider
sagen, diese schöne Vogelflugstrecke, die es ja früher gab, nämlich mit so Fähre, was war das?
Welche meinst du denn? Es gibt ja mehrere.
Es gab früher, nee, nee, früher gab es mehrere. Früher konntest du auch über
Sassnitz-Trelleburg fahren mit der Bahn, also mit der Bahn aufs Schiff drauf,
Schiff rüber über Ostsee und drüben weiter schubbern und so.
Das ist die, die die Nachtzüge nehmen?
Genommen haben und dann gab es jetzt noch welche, die haben sie zum Fahrplanwechsel am 15.
Dezember haben sie diese Vogelfluglinie eingestellt über wie hieß sie denn da,
Lübeck oben Röttnitz, genau Röttbi,
da sind sie auch noch mit einem Zug drauf rum gefahren, das hören sie jetzt
oft, das heißt das einzige was es jetzt noch gibt ist diese,
Nuckelnummer halt mit der dänischen Bahn quer über Jütland und dann über die
Inseln rüber und Kopenhagen und über die Brücke dann nach Malmö.
Funktioniert alles. Hab mir auf dem Rückweg, hab ich mir gesagt,
nee, auf dem Hinweg, hab ich mir das angeguckt, hab gesagt, oh ja,
das müsstest du mitten in der Nacht aufstehen und dann in Hamburg irgendwie
nur eine einstellige Anzahl Minuten Umsteigezeit.
Ich trau der Deutschen Bahn, das geb ich mir nicht.
Hab also auf dem Hinweg einen Zwischenstopp gemacht in Malmö,
weil da kenn ich auch so ein nettes kleines Hotel und hab gesagt,
komm mal, du hast ja Zeit, so um die Weihnachtszeit rum kann man ja machen.
Und im Rückweg habe ich dann die ganze Nummer komplett gefahren,
so von Stockholm früh um 8 Uhr quietsch los und dann um halb elf in Berlin.
Darum geht es mir jetzt auch gar nicht. Also grundsätzlich geht es.
Was mir aber aufgefallen ist, ist mal wieder so, jetzt gerade im Vergleich mit anderen Bahnen.
es gibt, also ich bin ja auch ein Freund dieses Verkehrsmittels,
vor allen Dingen, wenn du die Zeit hast dafür, aber es gibt dann so wieder so
Sachen aufgefallen, wo ich denke,
what the fuck ich hatte irgendwie mir ein Ticket geklickt war sogar ein First
Class Ticket aber war wieder ein super,
Doppel-Hyper-Spezialpreis und der hatte so tolle Quirks drin wie,
dass ich mir da aus der Bahn ab das Ticket nicht in die Wallet laden kann,
was sonst wohl geht, aber da wieder irgendwie nicht. Und du denkst so, äh?
Was geht?
A, das geht und B, warum hängt das am Tarif, ob das geht oder nicht?
Das heißt, wir müssen jetzt Leute gängeln, die einen Sparpreis geklickt haben oder was soll das?
Und dann, was ich auch wieder interessant fand, war so diese Interaktion zwischen
diesen internationalen Bahnen.
Also du fährst halt, juckelst dann Hamburg los, ab Hamburg ist das ein Zug,
ein IC-Zug, aber einer von denen, denen.
Einer von diesen lustigen IC-3-Zügen, der so komisch aussieht,
als würde dem eine Lok vorne fehlen.
Ja, liegt daran, dass die, du hast ja normalerweise bei so Zügen,
hast ja immer diese Gummipuffer zwischen den Waggons.
Und deren Lok hat vorne auch so einen Gummipuffer dran. Die sieht halt aus wie ein Waggon.
Aber du hast halt diesen fetten Gummivulst vorne und denkst so,
hä? Da fehlt doch eine Lok. Ist die hinten dran? Nein, auch nicht.
Egal. Aber Zum Kühlschubsen. Keine Ahnung.
und dann gibt es so wieder so Späßchen, wie fährst du halt in Hamburg los und
denkst dir nichts Böses und dann fährst du irgendwie nach ein paar Stunden über
die dänische Grenze, übrigens auch, als hätte es Schengen nie gegeben,
ja, so richtig schön, du guckst, das Ding fährt ja direkt neben der Straße,
der Straße wieder fährt, Kontrollplätze aufgebaut, so wie, fast wie zu DDR-Zeiten,
fast wie vor EU oder also wie gesagt, als hätte es Schengen nie gegeben,
da stapfen auch wieder Polizisten durch den Zug und sprechen dich an,
wenn du die falsche Hautfarbe hast.
In der Tat auch wirklich so, Ja, das habe ich jetzt immer gehabt.
alle Weißen wurden nicht mal angeguckt und wer auch nur ein bisschen irgendwie
arabisch oder sonst irgendwas aussah, wurde natürlich erstmal gefilzt. Okay, schön.
Nee, nicht okay, aber ist halt so ein Gnar.
Da ist übrigens da so ein Bild, da sieht man gerade im Chat da von so einem Ding.
Egal. Und was passiert? Kurz hinter der Grenze gibt es plötzlich Tee und Kaffee.
Okay, naja, vielleicht hat es bisschen gebraucht. Auf dem Rückweg genau das
Gegenstück. Fährst von Schweden los, alles super, alles schick.
Kopenhagen, alles super schick, Tee. Kurz vor der deutschen Grenze kommt jemand
und räumt Tee und Kaffee ab.
Und du denkst, what? Why?
Der ganze Zug fährt weiter, so wie er ist, aber irgendwie gibt es wieder irgendeine
Regulierung, die irgendwie, keine Ahnung, verbietet bestimmt,
dass man irgendwie einfach Tee umsonst ausgeben kann.
Oder, keine Ahnung, du denkst so, Leute, das passt alles nicht so zusammen,
irgendwie mit dem, dann denen und Deutsche und Basteln an einem Zug und dann
darf der da nicht fahren.
Der Zug nuckelte auch von Deutschland bis zur dänischen Grenze und ich dachte,
das ist halt so ein komisches Ding, wo die Lok vorne fehlt und so und dann schleicht
der halt so nix. Hinter der Grenze trat er aufs Gas.
Oder ja, in der Tat aufs Gas, weil du denkst, du fährst jetzt extra mit dem
Zug nach Schweden, natürlich fahren die denen da mit Dieselzügen rum.
Aber solche Sachen.
Und ich habe dann auch ein bisschen rumgetwittert und natürlich gab es dann
die üblichen Erklärbären, aber so richtig einig geworden sind sich die auch nicht.
Aber ich will nur sagen, diese Zuchidee ist zwar ganz schick und ganz schön
und funktioniert am Ende des Tages auch so ein bisschen, wenn man nicht stundenlang
auf zugänglichen Bahnhöfen zubringen müsste und so, aber wir sind da noch weit
entfernt und das finde ich halt deswegen so interessant,
weil ich habe extra nachgeguckt, wir sind mit Dänemark zusammen seit 47 Jahren in der, 47 Jahre?
Egal, über die 40 Jahre sind wir mit Dänemark zusammen in der Europäischen Union
und ihren Vorläuferorganisationen. Sie kriegen es bis heute nicht geregelt,
dort irgendwie das so zu regulieren, dass das ein Ding ist.
So mit, nicht der Tuch muss durch Deutschland schleichen und wir räumen Tee
und Kaffee ab aus was weiß ich für Gründen oder sonst irgendwas.
Es geht irgendwie, aber es ist irgendwie komplett alien.
Das kommt ja vor wie vor 100 Jahren mit Grenzübertritt und Kontrolle und Dramen,
blubb und so. Und da muss man sich dann echt fragen, was hat die EU uns hier gebracht?
Also vielleicht wartet ja mal Schengen oder sowas.
Aber das ist ja erst seit 2014 2014, dass sie wieder kontrollieren.
Also das ist mir halt aufgefallen.
2014, 2015, erst seitdem kontrollieren sie wieder in den Zügen.
Ja, aber trotzdem. Ich meine, das war eines der Features, für die ich mich als
Europäer mal gefreut habe. Ich habe gesagt, guck mal, jetzt haben wir hier so einen Quatsch da weg.
Und wir haben immer noch jede Menge europäischen Blödsinn, wie Cookies klicken
und so weiter und so fort.
Aber das, was mal so ein Feature war, das ist jetzt aus doller Gründen wieder weg.
Ja, kann man jetzt so diskutieren und hin und her und bla bla.
Aber wenn man mal so richtig rauszoomt, das war einfach so komisch,
dass das alles nicht zusammenpasst.
Und dieses Bahnsystem ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass sie jetzt Bahn erst vor fünf
Jahren erfunden hätten, wie das Internet. Ja, dass man sagt,
oh, das ist ja schwierig.
Neuland.
Wie man das koordiniert, Neuland oder sowas.
Sondern das betreiben die ja seit Jahrzehnten oder Jahrhunderten.
Und dass das so eine ruckige Angelegenheit ist, fand ich ein bisschen befremdlich.
Absolut.
Wohin ging denn, wie gesagt, Schweden, Malmö, Rhin, X2000, das ist deren Variante
von ICE, der schnurrte da pünktlich auf die Mikrosekunde da und schnurrte da
von Malmö einfach bis Stockholm zentral durch und fertig und fertig.
So, zack, einfach so, ging einfach so, so ohne Probleme.
Kam auch keiner, der mich irgendwie anpaulte, weil die haben,
die machen sozusagen das, was die Deutsche Bahn ja extra bewirbt,
nämlich mit diesem komischen Komfort-Check-In, dass wenn du da sitzt,
was dann bei mir natürlich erstmal auch nicht ging in Hamburg,
ja, aus doller Gründen sagte die ab wieder, nee, du kannst hier,
okay, gut, dann kann ich da halt nicht. Das ist bei denen Default.
Wenn du einen reservierten Platz hast und du musst einen reservierten Platz
haben im X2000, sonst kannst du ja gar nicht mitfahren, und du sitzt da auf
deinem Platz, dann kommt keiner vorbei, der dich nochmal nervt mit Ticket.
Hier hat einer Ticket bezahlt, Sitzplatz reserviert, sitzt einer drauf,
mir doch egal, so fertig, mach doch.
Und das fand ich wirklich schön. Der hat Spaß gemacht.
So, wollen wir nochmal auf andere Talks zu sprechen kommen? nach dem Ausritt nach Schweden.
Ich wollte das nur mit den Zügen einschmeißen.
Ist ja in Ordnung, aber jetzt müssen wir noch mal talks.
Linus hat mir noch gut gefallen, der Vortrag.
Hirnhacken.
Ja.
Sag ich jetzt auch, weil ich weiß, dass er uns zuhört. Wenn wir mal ein bisschen
bei ihm einschleimen. Er hat mir wirklich gut gefallen.
Mach mal. Schleim dich mal richtig ein.
Naja, er hat, Linus hat einen schönen Vortrag darüber gehalten,
der mit ein bisschen, die hatten irgendwie alle so ein bisschen reißerischen,
Titel, diese Vorträge?
Da gibt es mittlerweile ein eigenes Ogg dafür, um reißerischere Titel zu machen.
Das Hollywood Operations Center.
Wo er sich halt mal eben so dieser Thematik,
wenn man so Leute hacken will oder zum Beispiel Phishing-Texts,
wie sowas aussieht, wie man das,
vom Prinzip von ein bisschen von der Psychologie her betrachten kann,
wie man dann solche Sachen so gestaltet, dass Leute trotzdem irgendwo hinklicken,
wo sie nicht hinklicken sollen.
Und er hat auch selber schöne Beispiele gebracht, wo er Sachen ausprobiert hat.
Im Rahmen, ich denke mal im Rahmen irgendwelcher Aufträge, die er so in seinem
anderen Leben vollführt.
Das fand ich sehr schön. Er ist ja auch jemand, der mal einen vollständigen
Satz sprechen kann, im Gegensatz zu mir, wie man gerade hört.
Und der, genau, Hirnehacken hieß der und das hat auch Spaß gemacht.
Will ich jetzt nicht zu viel spoilern, aber auch da, die haben auch beide,
wie der Krisel auch, haben auch beide durchaus humoristische Anteile,
aber auch sehr informativ mit schönen Beispielen und so.
Ja, der Linus, der liefert immer. Das macht er sehr konsistent in den letzten Jahren.
Wolltest du da nicht noch einen Ausschnitt zuspielen?
Ne, das war Davids Vortrag.
Achso, Davids.
Ganz am Schluss. Wenn alles schon fast vorbei ist.
Ich bin im Prinzip jetzt am Ende vom Kongress einmal durch die App gegangen und hab mir alle,
Talks und Videos runtergeladen, die ich eigentlich hören wollte und irgendwie
spannend klangen und bin jetzt gerade am aufholen und das auch eher als Podcast konsumieren.
Auf dem Handy so auf Arbeitsweg hin und her.
Also ich habe noch eine Empfehlung und ich glaube, Letti, dass du den vielleicht
noch gar nicht zur Kenntnis genommen hast. Das weiß ich natürlich nicht.
Vielleicht hast du den auch schon gesehen.
Aber der wird dir auf jeden Fall sehr zusagen. Aber du wolltest, du hattest...
Ich habe jetzt halt schon ein bisschen gehört, noch nicht die langen großen,
sondern ich habe mich halt erstmal auf die etwas kürzeren fokussiert,
weil die schneller wegzuhören waren.
Ich war, ich bin einfach komplett ohne Erwartung an den feministischen Jahresrückblick,
also den reichlich Randale rangegangen und war echt positiv überrascht.
Worüber?
Wie ja, einfach wie angenehm die Personen waren, was sie alles so an Themen gecovert haben.
Also ich mag Ich mag Jahresrückblicke, weil ich halt sonst nicht so über meine Bubble hinausgucke.
Management Summary.
Ja, es ist halt einfach eine schöne Zusammenfassung des Jahres.
Ich nutze sowas, um eher über den Tellerrand herauszugucken und mich an Sachen
zu erinnern, Sachen an die ich sonst vielleicht nicht herangekommen wäre.
und gerade so Feminister Jahresrückblick, ich krieg ein bisschen was mit,
ist halt auch so Schnittpunkte mit meiner Bubble, aber ich würde jetzt nicht
sagen, dass ich da irgendwie aktiv in Themen drin stecke und ich fand den tatsächlich Aber.
Meinst du den.
Oder den anderen? Nee, ich mein den Reichlichrandale tatsächlich.
Das ist der Podcast von Becky, der Gender-Boy-Trag auf Twitter,
das war auf der Sinne Zentrumsbühne.
Genau, also alles sympathische Damen, Coole Themen.
Also ich hatte keinerlei Erwartungen und war positiv überrascht.
Und das fand ich, vielleicht Leute, die sonst nicht so den auf dem Schirm haben,
guckt einfach mal rein und vielleicht seid ihr auch positiv überrascht.
Es gab auch einen Jahresrückblick der Hexen, der war auch relativ engagiert.
Ja, den hatte ich auch geguckt. Den fand ich spannend, interessantere Zahlen.
Der hat mich aber nicht so extrem positiv beeindruckt wie der Podcast in dem Sinne.
Das ist ja auch ein Podcast.
Ja, ist auch ein Podcast. Hat sich vielleicht auch einfach, weil ich primär
als Podcast gerade kommuniziere, gut gemacht.
Okay, ich habe einen Tipp für Letti. Mal gucken, ob du den schon gesehen hast.
Es gab einen wunderbaren Vortrag von der Kurfürstin.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ihr richtiger Name ist.
Warum 3D gedruckte Kleidung nicht die Zukunft ist.
Und das war wirklich eine ausgesprochen coole Präsentation. Hast du den gesehen?
Nee. Nein.
Wo lief denn der überhaupt? In welchem Raum? Weiß ich gerade gar nicht.
Auf jeden Fall, sie ist, ich hoffe ich kriege das jetzt richtig zusammen,
also sie hat sich erstmal mit ihrem Berufsbild vorgestellt,
also mit ihrem Beruf, in dem sie tätig ist und zwar ist sie,
ach verdammt, ist das mir wieder entfallen, Textilproduktions, verdammte Axt.
Also sie designt nicht die Klamotten, sie verkauft sie nicht,
sondern sie macht die technische Realisierung der Herstellung von Klamotten.
Das heißt ihr Job ist sozusagen alles von, taugt das überhaupt für Massenproduktion,
was für Material muss da genommen werden, welcher Stoff wird da jetzt wirklich konkret genommen etc.
Katztrainer etc.
Sie füllt sozusagen einen hochgradig technischen Job,
eben in dieser Bekleidungsbranche und entscheidet am Ende irgendwie,
ob irgendwelche ausgefallenen,
Designerwünsche denn überhaupt realisierbar sind und wenn ja,
zu welchen Bedingungen, um da einfach eine konkrete Produktion draus zu machen.
Massenproduktion wahrscheinlich am Ende. Also eine Masse, was anderes funktioniert
dann wahrscheinlich nicht.
Weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob sie darauf festgelegt ist, also es ist auf jeden Fall Teil des Ganzen.
Mir erschien es mehr sozusagen so eine Rolle, die überhaupt die technische Möglichkeit,
also das hat auch was mit der, es hat nicht nur was jetzt mit den Maschinen
und mit der Produktion zu tun, sondern es hat auch was damit zu tun,
funktioniert der Stoff so?
Ja, ist er überhaupt für den Schnittmuster?
Ja, bollt der aus, ist das irgendwie flexibel genug, etc.
Und dann hat sie sich dieser 3D-Druckertrends angenommen, weil da gab es natürlich
so ein paar Leuchtturmprojekte, wo Leute so mit einem 3D-Drucker irgendwie,
naja, Bekleidung im weiteren Sinne geschaffen haben, die so ein bisschen prototypisch daher kamen.
Und sie hat das so alles analysiert und so haarklein dargelegt,
welche Aspekte sie sich da alles angeschaut hat, hat dann auch ihre eigenen
Experimente, wie man mit welchem Druckertyp, mit welchem Material,
welche Strukturen bauen kann und wo es da hakt und so weiter.
Also super geiler Vortrag, richtig toll, total begeistert, einfach straight weggetalkt.
Man merkt ja, die Kompetenz in diesem Feld quillt auch wirklich aus jeder Sekunde.
Ja, schon unterwegs.
Und auf jeden Fall interessanter Vortrag und danach weiß man auch ganz genau,
warum 3D gedruckte Kleidung nicht die Zukunft ist.
Super, also das ist auch so eine Art Talk, wie dafür liebe ich den Kongress.
Also so ein Thema überhaupt erstmal so präsentiert zu bekommen, top.
Ich hätte auch noch einen, den ich auch selber geheraldet habe und mich auch
absolut darüber gefreut habe, dass das jemand gemacht hat.
Und zwar haben Kai Biermann und Maha zusammen das Tool vorgestellt,
was bei der Zeit entwickelt wurde, bei Zeit Online.
Ich schmeiß mal dazu den Artikel in den Chat,
wo das Tool auch drin ist, dass es jeder benutzen kann, wo sie sich die Bundestagsreden
seit 1949 genommen haben und eben analysiert haben,
sodass du selber auch Begriffe reingeben kannst und schauen kannst, was korrelieren würde.
So. Und darüber haben sie halt einen Vortrag gemacht, wie sich so die Reden
im Bundestag verändert haben, wie haben sich die Themen verändert,
haben sich Themen verändert, sind es andere Begriffe geworden,
wie muss man auch zum Beispiel bei der ganzen Recherche dann da rangehen,
weil früher war es vielleicht irgendwie Umweltschutz und jetzt ist es Klimaschutz.
Also halt auch die, wie sich ein Fokus verändern kann von lokal auf global.
Und der Vortrag dazu, jetzt muss ich, wo ist jetzt der, das ist,
den habe ich schon, schon perfekt, ja genau, vom Ich zum Wir.
Ach, das ist der.
Das ist der Vortrag, genau. Den fand ich super schön.
Das hat mich halt auch selber interessiert, so was sind denn so Themen,
die besprochen werden und zu welchen Zeitpunkten werden Themen besprochen oder
das hat halt Kai auch ganz schön gesagt,
es gibt halt so ein paar Euphemismen, die dann eben benutzt werden,
wenn es um Bundeswehreinsätze geht und so. Also von Krieg wird ja nie geredet.
Und was dann halt stattdessen genutzt wird. Also schaut euch den mal an, schaut euch das Tool an.
Das ist auf jeden Fall sehr spannend, Ach, das ist der. Und zu welchen Zeitpunkten
welche Begriffe irgendwie hochploppten.
Und sie haben halt auch ein paar Zusammenhänge erzählt, was woher kam.
Genau. Sehr, sehr spannend.
Mich sehr gefreut, dieser Vortrag.
Ich habe da noch, wo wir vorhin schon so viel über OX geredet haben,
eins der auffälligsten OX von allen war ja schon immer das POG.
Und das POG hat sich mittlerweile so dermaßen...
Sagst du mal für die Leute, die das nicht wissen, was das jetzt ist,
welches von den vielen? Phone Operations. Ich weiß es auch, aber.
Ja.
Also die mit den Telefonen.
Die mit den Telefonen, genau. Das Phone Operations Center macht halt seit Jahr
und Tag, also angefangen haben sie mit diesen.
Telefonnetzen. Mittlerweile gehört da noch sehr viel mehr dazu.
Insbesondere hat ihre Telefonanlage immer unglaubliche Features.
Man kann sich halt vorher da eine Extension reservieren. Es gibt alle möglichen
Ansagedienste und sonstigen Verkoppelungen.
Und vor allem ist es natürlich organisatorisch auch, das gehört wahrscheinlich
vor allem auch das ZERT zu den Power-Usern.
So mit Gruppenrufen, Notruf, Schaltung, Schicht, wer ist jetzt sozusagen unter
welcher Nummer, zu welchem Zeitpunkt erreichbar.
Das ist so eine Funktionalität, die einfach extrem viel enabelt.
Und ist auch schön zu sehen, wie auch beim POC so ein Generationswechsel mittlerweile,
stattgefunden hat, dass sozusagen die beiden, die eigentlich am Anfang alles
gerissen haben, sich jetzt, also der eine ist schon länger raus,
der andere hat sich extrem zurückgelehnt auf diesem Kongress,
was ich auch mit großer Freude gesehen habe.
Wobei beim POC bedeutet das dann immer, wenn die dann auf einmal Zeit haben,
dann kümmern die sich ja um unheimlich viel anderen Unsinn.
Bevorzugt machen sie wahrscheinlich am liebsten Filmchen.
Musikvideos.
Zum Beispiel auf dem Camp, das hatten wir ja schon, Freakshow berichtete,
beziehungsweise in zehn Anläufen habe ich es dann mal geschafft,
dieses Video auch abzuspielen.
Insofern ganz interessant, ihr Talk diesmal, wo sie dann eben diese,
aktuelle Deck-Telefonanlage, die sie jetzt seit zwei Veranstaltungen nutzt,
also seit dem letzten Kongress, nutzen und das sozusagen die alte Telefonanlage
abgelöst hat und damit auch endlich diesen ganzen Kram wieder,
skalieren lässt, das haben sie sich jetzt mal ein bisschen genauer angeschaut
und es ist auch wieder ein wunderbar launischer, lustiger Vortrag geworden darüber,
wie sie sozusagen diesen System mal,
aufs Herz geklopft haben.
Ist auch ein klassischer Security Talk, aber eben weil Pock ist natürlich sehr unterhaltsam.
Kann ich auf jeden Fall auch empfehlen.
Was ich nicht ganz verstanden habe, also ich habe halt kein DECT,
weil ich es nicht so mit Telefonen habe und angerufen werden,
ist sowieso total creepy,
aber ich habe das nicht verstanden mit diesen Rechnungen.
Achso, ja genau.
Leute haben Rechnungen gepostet.
Ja, das wollte ich eigentlich noch dazu sagen. Sie haben das Pocker,
wie gesagt, das Pocker hat einfach zu viel Zeit.
Die müssen eigentlich unter permanentem Stress stehen, damit die sich nicht
so viel Unsinn einfallen lassen.
Und der Unsinn, den sie diesmal gemacht haben, ich bin mir ziemlich sicher,
ich überblicke das nur zur Hälfte, aber sie haben sich da sozusagen Spaß draus gemacht,
auch noch ein eigenes Pre-Talk-System, also so ein Content-Planungs-System,
mit dem man so Talk-Planung macht für Veranstaltungen, damit wird der Kongress
noch nicht gemacht, aber viele andere Veranstaltungen werden schon damit gemacht.
So ein Ding haben sie sich aufgesetzt.
Und ich habe nicht so viel Zeit drin verbracht, aber so nach dem Motto,
ja hier kannst du dann sozusagen auch ein CFP machen, du kannst dich sozusagen
für Telefonanrufe bewerben und kannst dir dann Zeitplanung machen,
wann du denn einen Telefonanruf durchführen möchtest.
Es war also einfach alles nur Irrsinn und dazu haben sie dann sozusagen auch
noch in ihr Guru-System,
also in ihr Telefonplanungstool, wo du so sagst, ich hätte gerne die und die
Durchwahl, haben sie jetzt auch ein Rechnungswesen eingebaut,
was natürlich ein Joke war,
das heißt sie haben dir so Rechnungen als PDF generiert für ihre Dienstleistung,
die immer so auf 0,0087359 Euro hinausliegen.
Wir haben die aber auch mit Papier produziert und dann war da C3 Post abgeschmissen.
So sieht es aus. Das war nämlich dann der nächste, dass alle Leute,
die sich ihre Rechnung nicht per PDF runtergeladen haben, kriegen das natürlich dann per Post.
Und dann sind sie in die Chaos Post gegangen und wollten die halt damit trollen
und waren auch eigentlich der Meinung, dass sie damit irgendwie alles komplett dedossen würden.
War aber nicht so, weil die Chaos Post mittlerweile schon so skaliert,
dass es irgendwie nur 15 Prozent des Post-Traffics ausgemacht hat.
Aber es sind halt mehreren Leuten auf dieser Veranstaltung Rechnungen der Pockenhöhe
von einem Cent zugestellt worden.
Es ist einfach wirklich alles so unfassbar lustig.
Du musst es nicht bezahlen.
Ja, genau. Das war für mich, dadurch, dass ich das noch nie in Anspruch genommen
habe und im Vornherein nur Leute.
Guck mal hier, Rechnung.
Genau, es war einfach.
Ja, ich hab mich einfach getrollt. Das ist einfach eine Betrollung des gesamten
Kongresses, der Chaospost und so weiter.
Was richtig getrollt wäre, wäre, wenn sie irgendwie ein C3 in Kassel gegründet hätten.
Das kommt.
Wie so eine richtige Telco, die muss natürlich das weitergeben.
Ich hoffe, niemand von denen hört zu. Das endet doch in einem Inkasso.
Die dich dann in Mate einkassieren oder was auch immer.
Die nehmen dir die Mateflasche weg oder so.
Oh Mann.
Genau, hier gibt es einen Link sogar noch hier. Presaleventphone.de,
Ja, also du kannst so Business Packages, Extensions kaufen, irgendwie SIM-Karte
für irgendwie 5 Euro pro Tag.
Pro Stunde. Also pro Stunde sogar, ah ja genau. Inklusive 23% Chaos-Tags.
49,99 pro Stunde SIM-Karte-Rente.
Was auch schön ist, steht daneben, daneben steht 41,99.
Ich hoffe, es hört keiner von der Telekom zu. Bitte?
Daneben steht 41,99, jetzt nur 49,99. Das ist auch sehr schön.
Und 23% Chaos-Text.
Ja, ja, das ist sehr gut.
Genau, mit Call Plans und kannst deine Extension kaufen hier.
Dann gibt es noch ein Stern OC Business Packages mit 10 Standard-Extensions
und einer Call Group. Nur 199 Euro.
Aber ist natürlich alles nur ein Scherz.
Ah ja.
Denn dem Pock geliebt ist zu scherzen.
Mhm.
Aber ist der nächste logische Step Billing einführen?
Die sind der Sache halt einfach immer schon irgendwie voraus.
Das heißt, die haben aber dann auch ordentliche Logs geführt,
sonst hätten sie darauf keine Bills erstellen können.
Nein, das ist eine Scherzrechnung. Nein? Nein?
Was denn mit deinem Einzelverbindungsnachweis? Waren da keine Einzelverbindungsnachweise dran?
Nein.
Nein?
Nee, nur welche Extension und Callgroups man so gekauft hat,
also das, was du da ausgewählt hattest.
Beim nächsten Mal werden sie mit Sicherheit diese Random-Fake-Daten auch dafür einbauen.
Und in Kassel losschicken.
Also Logs haben sie nie gemacht, es gab eine Ausnahme und das war auch die Grundlage
für diesen Security-Hack, den sie da gemacht haben,
weil das hat sie sozusagen in die Lage versetzt, diesen Fehler dort zu finden
und das haben sie aber mit Ansage gemacht auf dem letzten oder vorletzten Easter
Egg in Würzburg war das glaube ich,
wo sie quasi vorher allen gesagt haben so wir machen jetzt mal was was wir normalerweise
nicht machen wir machen jetzt mal Logs aber nur wenn jeder einzelne auch,
Einverständniserklärung gibt und mit hoch und heilig wir werden dieses Logs halt sozusagen nur,
nutzen um verschiedene Dinge zu optimieren unter anderem ist es ihnen jetzt dadurch gelungen,
bisher nicht supportete Handsets, die sich nicht so richtig an die Standards
halten, durch ein paar Tricks auch noch zum Laufen zu bekommen und ein paar andere Sachen.
Und genau darüber handelt auch dieser Talk. Also das kann man sich da irgendwie alles anschauen.
Und dann haben sie aber die Daten dann in ihrem Feuerwehr-Video vom Camp,
was du vielleicht gesehen hast, irgendwie diese Festplatten,
die sie da zerstört haben.
Da waren halt diese Logs drauf.
Cool. Also das ist immer alles sehr rund beim Pock. Ich bin ein großer Pock-
Fanboy. Schon immer gewesen.
So, gibt es noch weitere Talks?
Weiter bin ich noch nicht geschaut. Gekommen beim Schauen, so rum.
Ich habe eine Talk-Einschlaf-Empfehlung.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das in die breite Masse tragen sollte.
Ein Talk, der so langweilig ist, dass man da einschlafen kann. Du warst ja kein Herald.
Deswegen.
Also ich habe noch einen Tipp, habe ich auf jeden Fall noch.
Was Politisches und zwar wirklich sehr interessant. Oder sagen wir mal eher
was gesellschaftliches.
Let's Play Infokrieg, das sollte sich wirklich jeder von euch mal anschauen, diesen Talk.
Hervorragend auch in der ganzen Präsentation, also wirklich toller Flow in diesem
Talk und hervorragend zusammen recherchiert.
Und das ist so eine Zusammenfassung der ganzen Netzdebatten und Gates,
die in den letzten Jahren zu dieser ganzen Radikalisierung im Netz geführt haben.
Also auf bestimmte Sachen wird da konkreter eingegangen, unter anderem eben
auch Gamergate, wie das alles entstanden ist, aber eben nicht nur jetzt so eine
reine historische Herunterleihung,
was da wann wie wo passiert ist, sondern eben auch mit diesen ganzen psychologischen
Faktoren und wie das dann eben von dieser neuen Rechten auch ausgenutzt wird
und über welche Mechanismen das dann irgendwie funktioniert hat.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall wirklich ein ganz toller Talk und den werde ich
mir auf jeden Fall auch nochmal ein zweites Mal anschauen, weil der einfach
die Sache wirklich mal interessant in Kontext bringt über einen längeren Zeitraum,
wie die radikale Rechte ihre Politik gamifiziert.
Was haben wir noch?
Nichts mehr?
An Talks?
Alles leer geguckt?
Nee, noch gar nicht so weit angefangen. Das dauert jetzt erstmal noch ein bisschen.
Ja, ist ja noch Zeit. Wir können ja auch noch was noch nachliefern.
Das Schöne ist ja, dass die alle online und verfügbar sind auf Ewigkeiten.
Ja, warum werden die eigentlich nicht depubliziert? Ich finde, die prangern das an.
Was sollen denn die armen privaten TV-Sender jetzt noch, wo sollen die jetzt
noch mit Geld verdienen, wenn ganz Deutschland da die Talks guckt?
Die müssen unbedingt depubliziert werden.
Das ist jetzt polemisch gemeint.
Das ist bei den beiden glaube ich gerade nicht angekommen.
Ja, das ist mir schon klar. Der Gesichtsausdruck, Richtbände.
Ich habe auch gerade eben versucht darüber nachzudenken, was wir vielleicht noch vergessen hätten.
Vielleicht sollte es mehr Bullshit-Talks ohne Sinn und Verstand geben,
dann hätten die normalen Fernsehsender tatsächlich Konkurrenz,
um noch ein anderes Spektrum des Publikums abzubilden.
Auch mal alternative Wahrheiten.
Reality-Shows live auf der Bühne.
Fakten, ja.
Oh, das war auch sehr schön, das Bild.
Im Chat ist uns gerade ein Bild aufgetaucht von der Cyberpolizei.
Bis ich geschnallt habe, wer die Person in dem Kostüm war, hat es ein bisschen
gedauert, aber dann fand ich das auch sehr lustig.
Es gab eine Person auf jeden Fall auf dem Kongress, die sich eine Polizeiuniform
angezogen hat, aber Cyber hinten noch drauf geschrieben hat.
Und es sah halt im ersten Moment auch sehr glaubwürdig aus. Die Person lief da alleine rum.
und dann, ich kannte aber die Person, die im Kostüm steckte deswegen ist mir
dann so aufgefallen, so ah ja, okay, da hat jemand seinen Spaß ähm,
also das fand ich sehr lustig so dieses getrollt werden mit dieser Polizei mit
diesem Polizeikostüm ich weiß gar nicht, was er da in dem Schlagstock Ding,
sie hatte irgendwas so aus wie Pfeifendraht, irgendwas sehr lustiges.
Hier gibt es eine YouTube-Statistik von den Kongress-Videos.
Media-CCC.de, der YouTube-Account, wo das offiziell publiziert wird,
vermeldet in dieser einen Woche Januar 78 Jahre View-Time.
So viel Kongress-Videomaterial wurde da schon geschaut. Das ist ganz ordentlich.
78 Jahre.
78 Jahre View-Time. Also wenn du alle Views quasi zusammenrechnen.
Ich denke trotzdem eine Menge.
Das klingt auf jeden Fall nach einer Menge.
Die ein oder andere.
Okay.
Ja. So.
Vielleicht noch mal einen kleinen Nachtrag. Ich fand ja auch,
die Kunstsachen auf dem Kongress sehr schick.
Also ich habe beileibe nicht alles gesehen, beziehungsweise ich habe jetzt im
Nachgang schon wieder festgestellt, anhand von Videos, die gemacht wurden,
was ich alles nicht mitbekommen habe.
Oh, und mir fällt ein, oh verdammte Axt, das muss man auf jeden Fall auch noch erwähnen.
Ich fand ja das Opening und das Closing dieses Kongresses ist es extrem würdig und großartig.
Also dafür gibt es auf jeden Fall mal ein Lob. Das fand ich wirklich cool.
Unser Opening und Closing ist so ein das ist irgendwie so der Punkt an diesem
Kongress, der in all den Jahren am wenigsten gereift ist.
Da hat sich irgendwie immer noch nichts eingefunden, wie das so zu sein hat.
Wie eröffnet man diese Veranstaltung? Macht man jetzt eine Keynote oder nicht?
Ist die Keynote Teil der Eröffnung? Gibt es gar keine Keynote?
Ist die Keynote nur irgendein ausgewählter Talk, der dadurch geadelt wird,
dass er direkt nach der Eröffnung gepackt wird? Ist die Eröffnung lang?
Ist die Eröffnung kurz? Ist die Eröffnung pompös oder nicht?
Okay, in den letzten Jahren gab es dann immer mal Video und es fängt irgendwie
immer halbwegs pompös an.
Aber was kommt dann? Redet man über Orga? Redet man über was anderes?
Redet man über das Motto? Redet man über die Zeit, über die Welt oder was auch immer?
Unklar. Es ist einfach unklar. und das ist ein bisschen verständlich auch,
aber es ist auch irgendwie verwirrend.
Also das ist etwas, das muss ich irgendwie entwickeln. Naja, wie auch immer.
Das war doch mal dein Job. Ziemlich lange, oder?
Ja, also mein Job. Ja gut, ich habe das...
Also früher, ich könnte mir gar nicht vorstellen, wie das früher war.
Früher gab es irgendwie sowas überhaupt gar nicht so richtig. Damals TM.
Naja, als wir alle noch irgendwie rauchend in dieser 200-Leute-Aula rumsaßen.
Da war das halt so, ja hallo, wir sind da. Ein bisschen Orga-Talk.
Da gab es in dem Sinne kein Publikum, keine Audience, keine Leute,
die das erste Mal da waren oder sowas. Das war immer ein Heimspiel.
Ja, es hat einen ganz anderen Zweck erfüllt und am Schluss war dann halt eigentlich immer nur so,
Feedbackrunde wie war es, was sollten wir nächstes Mal anders machen,
man quatschte halt so ein bisschen miteinander,
unter sich mit ein paar Leuten und das wurde dann schon mit dem Umzug nach Berlin
schon ein bisschen schwieriger und da wurde es irgendwie auch immer komischer,
weil in dem Moment, wo du dann so einen Saal hast, wo wie groß war das 600, 700 Leute,
reingepasst haben, glaube ich, im Haus am Kölnischen Park.
Da konntest du dann so ein Format schon gar nicht mehr so machen.
Aber weil man es ja immer so gemacht hat, hat man es erst mal so gemacht und
es waren die totalen Trainwrecks.
Also es war wirklich so eine Veranstaltung, wo ich mich extrem unwohl gefühlt
habe, weil irgendeiner hatte wieder irgendwas zu meckern und die anderen wollten
aber eigentlich eher schon so den schönen Kongress,
ausklang feiern und dann kam wieder irgendwie, man hatte an allem irgendwas
rum zu meckern und dann wurden da irgendwelche persönlichen Fights sozusagen auf die Bühne getragen,
wie das eben so ist mit diesen ganzen Hahnenkämpfen die da teilweise noch stattgefunden haben,
weil es ja eigentlich noch eine sehr viel kleinere Szene war und man merkte
so richtig diese Anpassungsschmerzen an den Fakt dass der Kongress jetzt nicht
so ein kleiner Pissevent ist wo ein paar Leute rumhängen,
sondern dass hier gerade etwas zu so einer Konferenz,
heranwächst mit einem ganz anderen dann Appeal an Teilnehmer.
Wie sieht denn das jetzt eigentlich aus? Das heißt, das findet dann auf der
einen Bühne statt und wird auf die andere mit übertragen oder was?
Auf der größten Bühne findet es statt und als ich glaube ich,
also ich habe Bühne 2 gleich danach gehabt, deswegen auch nicht gesehen,
da war es aber im Stream drin, würde ich meinen. Als ich reingekommen bin.
Dass es noch gestreamt wurde. Du hast ja keine Bühne für 17.000 Leute.
Wenn da 17.000 Leute rumhupsen. Es sind auch keine 17.000.
Leute mehr da.
Selbst wenn jeder Dritte da hin will, hast du immer noch 5.000 Leute,
die dir irgendwo bespaßen müssen.
Ich würde meinen, dass es auf jeden Fall gestreamt wurde noch.
Also.
Wollt ihr jetzt nochmal wissen, wie viele Leute da jetzt eigentlich...
Ja, du hast jetzt mehrere Fragen gefragt. Ich wollte ja nochmal kurz sagen,
wie sich das entwickelt hat.
Als das dann so beim ersten Mal so merkwürdige Formen annahm,
da habe ich das irgendwann mal übernommen und habe gesagt, wir machen jetzt
mal eine richtige Eröffnung.
Weil ich wollte einfach, dass das mal begrüßt wird. Also diese ganze Vorstellung
mit, da kommen dann so viele neue Leute hin.
Der erste Kongress in Berlin war eine Vervierfachung. Also es waren sozusagen
extrem viele Leute da, die da noch nie da waren.
Und die mussten halt irgendwie begrüßt werden. Und später war es ja dann auch
so, dass Jahr um Jahr der Kongress immer mehr so diesen Glow entwickelt hat,
hat den wir jetzt hier auch schon alles schon mehrfach so zum Ausdruck gebracht haben,
dass das einfach so eine Veranstaltung ist, die echt vielen Leuten echt viel bedeutet.
Das ist nicht irgendwie sowas, wo man mal hingeht und ja, war ganz nett,
sondern das ist so, das Ereignis im Jahr und man gestaltet das selber mit und
gerade am Ende dann auch, wenn man irgendwie merkt, es ist mal wieder richtig
toll geworden, dann muss man auch einen Weg finden,
wie man das Ganze zu so einem Abschluss bringen kann. Aber die Art und Weise, wie ...
Getan werden soll, ist schwierig zu finden. Und mit den Eröffnungen habe ich
halt damals überhaupt erstmal versucht, diesen Punkt zu machen.
Lass mal eine Eröffnung wirklich machen als eine Begrüßungsveranstaltung, dass das erstmal da ist.
Und bei einer Abschlussveranstaltung, dass man da halt einfach den Dankesreigen,
abwirft, das war damals auch noch relativ einfach,
sozusagen allen zu danken oder zumindest den irgendjemand vergisst man ja immer,
aber halt in irgendeiner Form auch so dieses Community-Feuer überhaupt auch
erstmal so richtig zum Brennen zu bringen.
Das war sozusagen die Aufgabe. Das hab ich dann halt irgendwann nicht mehr gemacht.
Man wurde eben verschiedene Sachen ausprobiert. In den letzten Jahren ging es
immer irgendwie hin und her. Mal war es pompös, manchmal war es langweilig.
Manchmal saß da nur ein Nerd hinterm Tisch und rappelte irgendwelche Orga-Notizen runter.
Also es ist einfach nichts hat mehr Diskontinuität als das Opening und das Closing.
Also da waren epische Sachen dabei, und es waren tolle Sachen dabei.
Naja, kommen wir zu diesem Jahr und dieses Jahr und das ist für mich eigentlich
eine ganz schöne Sache, dass einfach die Talks, die Openings und Closings in
den letzten Jahren halt in zunehmendem Maße Vertretern und Vertreterinnen der,
neueren Generationen im Club übergeholfen werden und diesmal fiel die Wahl auf,
Sabine, die ja hier auch schon mal in der Freakshow war dieses Jahr, Bliebtrack und Blinry.
Und sie hat ja auch das Design dazu gemacht.
Genau, muss man auch noch dazu sagen. Und Bliebtrek hat ja auch das Design gemacht,
was, wie ich finde, auch super funktioniert hat.
Also was diese zerbrochene Schriftkultur fand sich wieder mal überall.
Also wie schon im letzten Jahr, wo ihr Generator ja quasi extrem schnell steil
gegangen ist von allen Leuten benutzt wurde, war es halt diesmal quasi mit dem
ganzen Kongress-Design alles aus einem Guss und hat eigentlich auch super funktioniert. Ja.
Ja, und dann gleich obendrauf, weil es ja wahrscheinlich sonst nichts zu tun
hat, wurde sie dann eben auch noch ins Opening und ins Closing delegiert.
Und ich muss sagen, ich war da schon so ein bisschen gespannt,
was dabei rauskommen würde und jetzt muss ich erst mal fragen, wer hat es gesehen?
Das Closing habe ich gesehen und das war wirklich sehr, sehr gut.
Opening steht noch auf der Liste.
Genau, also es war beides toll.
Ich fand das Closing hat wirklich nochmal einen oben draufgelegt,
aber sie haben es lustig gemacht, sie haben es charmant gemacht,
sie haben es kurz gemacht, also es war eine Viertelstunde oder so,
also relativ einfach wegzukonsumieren.
Ich persönlich hätte mir beim Opening gerne noch ein bisschen mehr ich hätte
gerne noch ein bisschen mehr Fleisch gehabt, was dieses Motto,
weil ich finde es schon, wenn man sich so ein Motto wählt.
Dann muss man das auch mal kurz thematisieren.
Allein schon, weil die Presse halt zuhört.
So, der Kongress fängt an, am ersten Tag, Presse da, alle wollen darüber berichten
und alle wollen irgendwie da ein Quote haben.
Da eignet sich das ganz gut, das rüberzubringen. Ist aber jetzt auch nicht so schlimm.
Dafür war es halt wirklich cool gespielt, lustig gemacht und einfach ein paar
nette Jokes gebracht, aber vor allem halt so ein Flow drin gehabt und das Ganze
auch gestalterisch ganz gut gemacht.
Das Closing, ich will jetzt überhaupt gar nichts groß vorweg nehmen,
aber es war einfach extrem komisch, weil sie, kurz gesagt, äh,
so eine Art Tagesschau oder Tagesthemen gemacht haben, um diesen Kongress abzuschließen.
Also es war sozusagen so, es hieß dann die Chaos-Show und darin war dann sozusagen
alles, was so auf diesem Kongress passiert, also nicht alles,
aber vieles, was auf diesem Kongress passiert ist so als Meldung,
teilweise auch als Postellions-Style,
Kurzmeldung mit wirklich einem super komplizierten Nerd-Humor,
der aber echt wirklich komisch war, rübergebracht mit Wetterkarte und Und das
volle Programm. Kommen wir zum Sport.
Ja, das ist das erste Mal, dass man, also, das ist lange nicht passiert,
dass Leute mich wirklich aktiv angesprochen haben.
Ja, hast du die Opening gesehen? So, nee, dammit.
Heraldschicht. Und da war das erste Mal so, wow, es wird wieder aktiv.
Also ich fand, dein Opening war halt eins, zu dem Tuvert, was halt echt einfach
gesessen hat, so von der Informationssache her, für alle irgendwie,
von dem Thema her, das hat supergeil gepasst.
Und danach hat irgendwie niemand nochmal über so ein Opening gesprochen oder
ist aktiv zu denen gesagt, ey, hast du das Opening gesehen? Das war immer sowas, was...
Ja gut, seitdem gab es ja nur eins.
Ja, genau, aber es fällt halt schon auf. Aber auch die Jahre davor,
also ich erinnere mich an diese peinliche Nummer, wo dieser Alec-Empire-Heini
da gestanden hat und man sich einfach nur noch fremdschämen konnte. Und auch andere.
Also Opening war halt immer was, wo ich gesagt habe, sorry, ich bleibe im Hotel
liegen und wir sehen uns später.
War immer, in Hamburg war das immer so. Ich glaube, du hast mir das sogar gesagt.
Ach nee, das kam dann im Stream und so.
Nein, das habe ich dir nicht gesagt.
Nee, das war was anderes. Genau, und das war jetzt halt wirklich das erste Mal,
dass jemand, nicht nur eine Person, irgendwie mein erstes Opening gesehen hat.
Okay, okay. Da ist was passiert, was richtig gut ist.
Ja. Nee, haben sie super gemacht. Es gibt auf jeden Fall ein Sternchen.
Ja, ich freue mich da schon drauf, das mehr anzuschauen.
Ein Bienchen. Ein Bienchen. Ein Bienchen und fünf Sterne, würde ich sagen. Gerne wieder.
Ihr habt den Job.
Ja, ich hoffe, ja, also das ist glaube ich schon mal auch was,
worüber die Community mal ein bisschen mal drüber nachdenken muss,
weil das bleibt immer so bei manchen dann irgendwie so ein bisschen hängen,
aber ich sehe nicht so eine Diskussion, diese Frage mit was soll eigentlich ein Opening leisten?
Und es ist Es ist schwierig, weil es jedes Jahr auch mal so ein bisschen anders ist.
Mir hat es damals immer sehr geholfen und das war auch so ein bisschen mein Spiel an der Stelle.
Dadurch, dass ich eben die ganze Vorbereitung des Kongresses begleitet habe,
wusste ich halt irgendwie alles.
Also ich wusste, wo die Schwierigkeiten waren und ich habe halt auch mal viel
über den Kongress selber geredet und welche Neuerungen es gab und jetzt auch
mit WLAN und jetzt haben wir sogar Videoaufzeichnungen oder zumindest probieren wir es mal.
POC-Notfallnummern als diese Hacker-Hotline das erste Mal hatten.
Das gibt es mittlerweile gar nicht mehr.
Das Problem scheint irgendwie weg zu sein. Wir hatten ja so ein paar Mal so
auf dem Kongress, dass irgendwelche Webseiten gehackt wurden,
weil sich irgendwelche Kids nicht im Griff hatten.
Und dann war das immer so die News. Der Chaos-Communication-Kongress und jetzt
hier das und das und das ist irgendwie alles komplett aufgemacht worden und
so weiter und wir müssen alle Angst haben Und das war dann halt immer so ein bisschen schwierig,
wenn dann irgendwie so die Herren vom LKA dann irgendwie immer im Kongress standen
und so, ja und so, wir haben da einen Vorfall und so und wir müssen jetzt hier
den Täter finden und so weiter.
Leute, wir erklären euch das jetzt mal hier kurz so,
aber ihr werdet hier mit leeren Händen wieder rausgehen und das waren halt immer
so Gespräche im Hinterzimmer,
die man eigentlich auch gar nicht haben wollte und man wollte ja auch nicht,
dass dann Leute Probleme kriegen und so.
Und deswegen haben wir dann immer diese Hacker-Hotline, Frank hat das irgendwie eingeleitet, gemacht.
Wo man dann halt, also eine Decknummer, wo man halt anrufen konnte.
Von außen?
Nee, von innen. Also wenn Leute auf dem Kongress saßen und irgendeine Tür hat
sich geöffnet oder war kurz davor oder man könnte sie jetzt aufstoßen.
Achso, diese, ja, ja.
Und dann gab es halt eine Beratungshotline, wo man anrufen konnte nach dem Motto,
ich hab jetzt hier folgenden Fall.
Hab dir einen Tipp, wie wir jetzt damit umgehen sollen, weißt du?
Weil auf der einen Seite willst du halt diesen Hacker-Fame irgendwie haben.
So, guck mal, jetzt müssen wir nur noch hier und so und dann fällt Das Tor so,
aber auf der anderen Seite eben auch so dieses und das wurde dann auch tatsächlich
genutzt und sowas habe ich dann halt in die Eröffnung mit eingebaut und Joke
und wieder das war das erste Mal,
dass ich diese lange Notrufnotruf Nummer von von IT Crowd benutzt habe.
Es war natürlich dann irgendwie ein guter Joke so, also das war sozusagen das
Ziel, den Leuten gutes Gefühl geben.
Sachen, wichtige Sachen, Neuerungen des Kongresses vorstellen.
Heutzutage ist es mehr so dieses Erstteilnehmer aufwärmen.
Gut, kann man irgendwie sicherlich auch zusammenbringen.
Und aber im Wesentlichen einfach allen so das Gefühl geben, so ja,
es ist wahr, Kongress fängt wieder an.
Ihr könnt ab jetzt euch alle super fühlen. Wir werden jetzt eine tolle Zeit
miteinander haben. Jetzt geht's los.
Zack, go. Go. So. Und am Schluss halt das Ganze quasi in die andere Richtung,
weil du merkst es einfach schon, sie kommen so, kommen dann irgendwie beim Closing,
kommen so alle rein und dann so, wie geil war das denn jetzt bitte?
Und dann gibt es immer diesen unheimlichen Wunsch, sich so dann auch gegenseitig so zu beklatschen.
Es ist einfach toll zu finden, was stattgefunden hat.
Enorm war das zum Beispiel beim 30C3, wo alle wussten so, okay,
krass, das war jetzt Kongress-Version 4.0 irgendwie, wir waren alle dabei,
wir haben es miterlebt. Wie geil war das bitte?
Das war der erste Hamburger, oder was?
Das war der zweite. Wo das erste Mal die Party war, mit dem Wasserwerfer und
so weiter, wo alles so irre war.
Da waren die Leute einfach schon, als sie schon hinkamen und sich umgeschaut haben,
man merkt ja einfach schon, vom ersten Herumlaufen und den ersten Gerüchten,
die sich da rumsprachen, was sozusagen für Features aufgefahren wurden.
Das war das erste Mal, wo das ganze Gebäude genutzt wurde.
Also man merkte einfach so, hier passiert was, das ist jetzt auf jeden Fall
der nächste große Schritt, den dieser Kongress gegangen ist.
Und das, dann musst du einfach irgendwo hin mit deiner Begeisterung.
Dann musst du das irgendwie kanalisieren und brauchst einfach so einen kurzen,
Moment eines gepflegten Wir-Gefühls, wo man die Leute einfach so abholt und
sagt so, ja, jetzt ist es soweit, Jetzt können wir uns alle mal so richtig lieb
haben und ab geht der Peter.
Und dann funktioniert das und dann ist dem auch schon Genüge getan.
Also man muss da auch gar nicht so eine große Angst vor haben.
haben. Ich kenne viele Leute so, Eröffnung und so weiter.
Ja, dass das irgendwie so schwierig wäre oder so.
Ich finde, eigentlich ist es ganz einfach. Man muss halt einfach im Wesentlichen
einfach nur das so kanalisieren und sagen, so ja, super.
Aber das ist halt auch was, selbst wenn du es dir nicht vorstellen kannst,
dass es für andere schwierig ist, es ist halt für manche nicht so einfach und
das ist auch irgendwo eine Typsache.
Manchen fällt das leichter, wie dir, anderen fällt das schwerer, andere brauchen Übung.
Das darf man halt nicht immer vergessen.
Was ich aber ganz spannend finde, also ich finde es eigentlich ganz cool,
wenn halt so unterschiedliche Sachen aufprobiert wird, weil wenn tatsächlich
jedes Jahr neue Leute sind,
ist halt einfach von der Natur der Dinge aus, jeder geht das Ganze anders an
und es werden Dinge ausprobiert und klar, man kann dann irgendwie rausfinden,
das hat jetzt nicht funktioniert, das hat funktioniert.
Das Konzept von dieser Chaos-Show finde ich halt so cool, das würde als Closing-Zeremonie
jedes Jahr nicht unbedingt funktionieren, aber einen festen Slot als Chaos-Show,
so einfach 20 Minuten in Ada,
so jetzt ist Chaos-Show, ja das wäre doch super.
Das könnte passieren, dass die den Job sich jetzt eingetreten haben, ja das stimmt.
Ja, also das finde ich halt das Schöne, wenn das so ein bisschen einfach durchrotiert
und man kann sich ja auch einfach ausprobieren.
Das ist ja das Schöne am Kongress und einfach Dinge probieren.
Chaos Show ist jetzt einfach wie Hacker Jeopardy Fest.
Genau. Also Sabine, falls du zuhörst.
Den Job hast du auch.
Den Job hast du jetzt auch noch. Du hast so wenig zu tun bisher immer.
Oh Mann. Super.
Oder dass das Wok und Pock tun sich zusammen und machen jetzt Chaos-Show,
aber dann richtig mit vorproduzierten Don't.
Nein.
Ich meine, wenn es eh schon diese Tradition gibt, irgendwie wirklich jede verkackte
Quizshow, die im Fernsehen halbwegs populär ist, irgendwie hier in Kongress-Style
zu bringen, dann kann man ja die ganzen anderen Fernsehsendungen auch noch machen.
Aber dann will ich auch, dann will ich auch, wie heißt das hier?
Great British Hack-Off Volksmusik Musikantenstadel Hackerstadel Oh nee,
Was denn mit den Greatest Hits Like the Drone Operator Nee,
Hacker-Karaoke Nee.
Besser nicht Da könnte ich jetzt meinen Ohrwurm wieder einbringen.
You're a pilot, you're a drone operator.
Deutschland sucht einen Superhacker.
Ja, da geht noch einiges.
Apropos da geht noch einiges. Wie siehst du denn die Zukunft von dem Ding?
Welchen jetzt?
Immer größer, immer höher, immer schneller. Soll jetzt Leipzig noch ein paar
Hallen anbauen? oder wie ist das?
Ey, nur wenn es ein paar mehr Tage gibt. Das ist, glaube ich,
so meine größte Kritik für die meisten.
Meinst du, wenn du nicht mehr an einem Tag drum rumjoggen kannst,
dann ist es zu groß geworden?
Nee, nee, nee. Eher so, wenn, also viele Leute haben einfach was zu tun und
wenn die meisten, also ich weiß jetzt so, dass in der PL auch so ein bisschen
was geändert wurde, dass auch jeder mal die Chance hat, diesen Kongress wirklich
zu erleben. Also das ist, glaube ich, so,
Das Einzige, wenn man viel zu tun hat, hat man gar nicht so viel Zeit,
alles zu sehen und manchmal wünsche ich mir so einen Tag oder vielleicht zwei
mehr, dass auch jeder mal wirklich alles gesehen hat.
Kann überhaupt. Ich weiß nicht, ob es funktioniert.
Das ist mir gerade scheißegal, ob es funktionieren kann oder nicht.
Also ist ja halt einfach nur, das wäre mal was, was cool wäre,
damit jeder die Möglichkeit hat.
Ich glaube, das ist eher educating the people, dass die halt vorher die Strukturen
schaffen, um sich auszuhalten.
Das geht nicht. Also es geht halt gar nicht in einigen Stellen.
Man kann sich auch einfach mal damit abfinden, dass man nicht alles gesehen haben können dürfen.
Ja, vielleicht, vielleicht.
Ich habe ja ein ähnliches Problem bei meinem Kongress jetzt.
Snowball nicht, das ist sehr eng, aber es gibt auch andere Tanzveranstaltungen,
wichtige Dinge für Lindy Hopper ist ja zum Beispiel auch das Summer Camp da
oder das Summer-Ding in Hereng und jeder, der das erste Mal hingeht,
versucht alles mitzunehmen.
Jede Party, jede Klasse, jeden Taser und all so einen Scheiß und das macht dich
aber total knülle und Und irgendwann hast du dich damit abgefunden,
hast gesagt, guck mir jetzt dieses Jahr nicht an, guck mir nächstes Jahr an
oder so. Vielleicht ist das auch eine Möglichkeit.
Nee, so einen Tag länger.
Also ich verstehe dich ja sehr gut.
Ich habe ja seinerzeit auch angeregt und durchgesetzt, dass wir von drei auf vier Tage gehen.
Also die Verlängerung auf den drei. Früher war es ja nur sieben.
Also ursprünglich war es sogar nur 27.
und 28. Dann kam der 29. dazu. Dann kam der 30. dazu.
Tast ja, 31. auch nicht mehr war.
Ja, jetzt läufst du aber in mehrere Probleme rein.
Dass das überhaupt geht, das bezweifle ich auch definitiv. Also da bin ich auch realistisch.
Kannst ja früher anfangen, kannst ja am 26. anfangen.
Am 24.
Naja, das ist ja de facto schon so. Also einen halben Tag extra hat es in den
letzten Jahren sowieso schon gegeben.
Wenn du mal guckst, wie viele Leute am Tag 0 da waren.
Klar, da ist halt noch nicht alles hochgefahren. Das Problem ist auch,
dass es in zunehmendem Maße auch Probleme macht mit dem Aufbau,
wenn schon so viele Leute da sind, weil du dann einfach nicht mehr groß rangieren kannst etc.
pp. Aber diese Verlängerung auf Silvester, die ist natürlich extrem schwierig.
Also erstmal ist der Verschleiß natürlich enorm.
Hauptproblem ist aber, Silvester ist halt kulturell so abgespeichert bei vielen
Leuten mit irgendwas, wo sie immer die Party feiern, wo sie da nochmal mit der
Familie und wenn du schon Weihnachten so früh abhaust, dann aber nochmal Silvester
und so weiter und so fort.
Und das heißt, egal wie du es drehst und wendest, du wirst einen extrem großen
Teil der Teilnehmerschaft am 30., spätestens am 31.
sehr früh verlieren und damit zieht sich dieser ganze Abbauprozess.
dass entweder bauen Leute sehr früh ab oder Gruppen verlieren die Leute,
die sie brauchen für den Abbau und so weiter.
Dann ist natürlich Silvesterparty feiern auch immer so ein bisschen...
Kriegt nochmal so eine extra Dimension, so, gut, bei uns glaube ich nicht,
dass die Knallerei jetzt irgendwie da so ein Problem darstellt,
aber dann ist es auch gleich wieder eine ganz andere Security-Nummer,
dann muss er halt für sowas dann auch nochmal ganz andere Zert-Kapazitäten bereitstellen.
Alles, also niemand hat die Kapazitäten eigentlich.
Also da hängt so ein Shitload an Problemen dran, dass ich sehr gut verstehe,
dass wir bei diesem Modus irgendwie bleiben und man muss diesen Kacke auch mal
abgebaut bekommen. kommen.
Ja, absolut. Also genau, ich weiß, dass es total unrealistisch ist und das geht
eigentlich überhaupt nicht, weil alle auf Zahnfleisch streichen.
Ich will eigentlich auch noch einen Tag mehr haben. Zahnfleischlaufen.
Ausfallen lassen. Achso, 21. geht ja auch nicht.
Tja.
Ja, bleibt schwierig. Aber du wolltest irgendwas über die Zukunft wissen.
Ja, was du jetzt, weil du ja gesperrt hast und Community und hin und her und
du hast ja jetzt so beschrieben wie eine Evolution findet statt.
Was würdest du dir jetzt denken, vermuten, wünschen, was da noch passiert?
Weil du fällst von Jahr zu Jahr von einem Superlativ ins nächste und irgendwann...
Ja, ich bin einfach begeistert.
Ja, aber es war jetzt nicht vorwürfig gemeint, sondern es ist eher so die Frage, wie...
Es wird ja nicht weiter...
Wann dieser Höhenflug stattfindet.
Ja. Also ich habe da überhaupt gar keinen Zweifel daran.
Also derzeit sieht ja alles danach aus. meine dies jahr war für den club finde
ich überhaupt mit also das was veranstaltungen betrifft,
das dieses Jahr war like no other.
Also ich meine, das Camp war definitiv das schickste und tollste und entspannteste
Camp von allen und der Kongress war auch super.
Drei Monate danach mit einer extrem hohen Doppelbelastung und,
unisono, also mag Einzelfälle gegeben haben, wo es irgendwie Probleme gab,
davon habe ich jetzt wenig Kenntnis, aber ich habe halt aus sehr vielen Teams
gehört, hört, auch den Teams, die eben sehr unter Belastung sind.
Also ZERT ist ja auch so ein extrem unter Stress, also potenziell im Stress stehende,
Truppe und das gilt auch für diese ganze Lager-Crew und die haben auch viel
zu tun gehabt, aber die Stimmung war einfach gut.
Es war einfach alle meinen, wir hatten uns alle lieb.
Man sah es halt einigen Leuten auf jeden Fall an, auch wenn sie vielleicht sagen
wollten, ja, dem ist alles super.
Geh doch nochmal ein Stückchen weg. Aber das stimmt.
Ja, so. Also das finde ich jetzt erstmal ein extremes Achievement.
Also es ist einfach, dass Ja, das ist ja unbenommen. Es gab vor einem Jahr.
Soll das Ding noch weiter skalieren? Oder ist 17.000 jetzt das Limit?
Sag ich gleich was dazu. Aber vielleicht nochmal dazu. Vor einem Jahr gab es
tatsächlich eine Abstimmung intern, ob man nicht den Kongress vielleicht ausfallen lässt.
Wegen des Camps. Und das war auch nicht so eine 90 zu 1 Abstimmung,
sondern das war so eher knapp.
Knapp, weil es viele Gruppen gab, das war knapp und war aber dann eben so eine
knappe Mehrheit für, ne wir machen das.
Eine Abstimmung innerhalb des CCC?
Innerhalb der Leute, genau dieser Orga-Wolke.
Also alle Gruppen, alle Ox und so weiter, die da irgendwie nennenswert beizutragen
haben, hatten da sozusagen eine Stimme und letzten Endes fiel das so knapp aus.
Und so. Und ging dann. Und hat auch wieder, glaube ich, auch wieder viel so Situationen erzeugt.
Man wusste, okay, bestimmte Ressourcen, bestimmte Leute werden so beim Kongress nicht da sein.
Und das sind dann wieder so Momente, wo dann eben aus der zweiten Reihe nachgestoßen
wird, so nach dem Motto, oh super Vakuum, da expandiere ich mich jetzt mal rein.
Und das ist so eine Konstante in diesem Modell und nur dadurch existiert dieser Konkurs.
Das hat ja auch was.
Zur vernünftigen Evolution gehört ja auch eine Änderung des Genpuls.
Richtig, genau. Und insofern bin ich da ganz entspannt.
Was die Größe betrifft, klar, viele klagen über, ach ist ja so groß geworden
und die weiten Wege und so weiter, aber ich habe nicht so den Eindruck,
dass das irgendwie ein Faktor ist,
der jetzt die ganzen positiven Entwicklungen, die sich dadurch jetzt wieder.
Herausgestellt haben irgendwie nennenswert einschränkt weil wenn man sich jetzt
mal den Kongress auch anschaut, wie der sich jetzt entwickelt hat,
also in Berlin war das ja noch es gab im Wesentlichen die Talks und dann so
ein paar Tische drumherum oder im Keller war noch ein paar Tische,
da konnten irgendwie nochmal 10 Gruppen irgendwie sitzen und das war's,
also Also da war nicht viel Fläche für Projekte.
Da haben wir so ein paar Airfars und dieses und jenes Projekt hatten da irgendwie
einen Tisch und der Rest rannte eigentlich die ganze Zeit im Kreis und traf sich in der Cafeteria.
Da war auch tolle Stimmung und natürlich war es irgendwie der Irre Kongress.
Aber es war nicht zu vergleichen mit der Situation, die wir dann ab dem 30C3
in Hamburg hatten, Wo dann all diese ganzen Etagen und Flure voll waren,
es größere Räume und ganze Hallen gab,
wo es ja ein Hackcenter gab, wo es Tische gab, für Assemblies gab,
die immer alle ausgebucht waren.
Kein Problem, jeglicher Quadratmeter, der in irgendeiner Form mit freiem Tisch
besetzt werden konnte, war voll. Und so hat sich dann eben dann ja auch dieser
neue Begriff herausgebildet. Es gab ja dann diese Assemblies.
Das gab es so vorher nicht. Das ist quasi so die Kongressvariante der Villages auf dem Camp.
Und dadurch wuchs es irgendwie an und dadurch wurde der Kongress auch besser.
Dadurch wurde er bunter, denke ich mal.
Du bist rumgelaufen überall, war Wahnsinn. Es sind halt einfach Assemblies.
Wo nicht alte weiße Männer mit Lötkolben rumsaßen, sondern eben andere Sachen gemacht haben.
Ich meine, beim 31C3 war ich ja da. Ja, aber dann fand ich schon gerecht beeindruckend damals.
Es gibt auch alte weiße Männer mit Lötkolben, ist auch okay so.
Es gab auch junge.
Nicht so weiße Männer mit Lötkolben und Frauen und alles war irgendwie da.
Alles ganz zwischen und drumherum und anders.
Genau, es hat sich einfach immer mehr herausgestellt. Und der Move nach Leipzig hat jetzt nochmal...
finde ich das Ganze nochmal in so eine andere Situation gebracht,
weil jetzt ist es so, was sich vielleicht in Hamburg nur angedeutet hat,
ist jetzt einfach der Fall.
Der Kongress ist nicht mehr nur der Treffpunkt der Hacker-Szene,
sondern du hast da extrem viele andere Gruppen, die ihre eigenen Subspaces dort machen.
Also Halle 2, da hast du unter anderem so.
Zusätzliche Universen wie diesen Open Infrastructure Orbit, wo dann halt so
Gruppen wie Sea-Watch, Kados, etc.
Also Leute, die quasi politische Arbeit machen, Flüchtlingshilfe, was auch immer.
Teilweise nur technische Projekte, teilweise einfach auch politische Aktionen machen,
aktivistische Aktionen machen und die nutzen den Kongress als Treffpunkt Und
sind in der Lage, dort ihren eigenen Space zu machen und verschiedene Gruppen
zusammenzubringen in so einem Kombi-Space.
Und das geht einfach nur, weil wir diese irren Flächen dort haben.
Und bereit sind, die Investitionen in Tischestühle und so weiter,
was man dafür braucht, die ganze Infrastruktur, Miete, Heizung zu leisten.
Aber das bringt was, weil jetzt läufst du da durch diese Hallen und irgendwie
alle 30 Meter bist du wieder in einem komplett anderen Kosmos,
wo andere Gruppen unterwegs sind.
Das ist ein riesiger Vintage-Bereich und irgendwie da diese Bitcoin-Freddys
und dann, also permanent rennst du in irgendein anderes Universum rein und ich finde,
das hat den Kongress nochmal erheblich aufgewertet, weil wir eben jetzt,
auch eine Plattform sind für andere Gruppen die auf eine ganz andere Art und
Weise arbeiten, aber letzten Endes dieselben gesellschaftlichen Ziele verfolgen
wie der Klub sie immer hat.
Vier Tage Arschloch-Freie Zone spielen wollen.
Genau und eben auch dort einfach sich vernetzen wollen und,
Leute finden wollen, die weiterhelfen können. Und es ist auch so für die Hacker
irgendwie ganz cool, weil es einfach jetzt noch mehr Möglichkeiten gibt,
wo man seine Expertise auch mal konkret in was hilfreiches, sinnvolles reinkanalisieren kann.
Also nicht, dass jetzt vier Tage Spaß haben und seine Skills,
teilen und aufwerten auf dem Kongress nicht schon Sinn genug wäre,
aber zusätzlich kann man jetzt eben auch noch an solche Projekte andocken und
das irgendwie zu einem anderen Nutzen noch mitbringen.
Und das nimmt irgendwie gar kein Ende.
Zweiter Aspekt ist auch dieser ganze Kunstbereich. Also, weiß nicht,
diese großartige Art-and-Play-Area da vorne in der Halle 2, habt ihr die mal
irgendwie so ein bisschen betrachtet?
Da waren also auch wirklich ein paar ganz fantastische Exponate drin.
Die teilweise von außen kamen, teilweise von außen innen, weiß ich nicht,
diese Begriffe greifen irgendwie nicht mehr so richtig.
Sehr schön ist dieses Flip-Dot-Display, was war das?
So 30, 40 alte ausgediente Flip-Dot-Displays aus BVG-Bussen,
Trams, die so aus dem Lager rausgekauft wurden, teilweise schon so ein bisschen
im Eimer, teilweise haben sie aber auch noch funktioniert.
Zusammengebaut zu so einer dicken, fetten Wand aus vertikal stehenden Flip-Dots,
andere Elektronik, um die Dinger,
anzusprechen und dann lief dann irgendwie Kram. Sah einfach super aus.
Installationen, mit denen du rumspielen kannst. Also es ist einfach auch so
viel dazugekommen, wo man sich so sensorisch auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise
mit Technologie beschäftigen kann.
Kannst da rumlaufen, es gab irgendwie Silent Discos, Kopfhörer auf,
Klangerzeugungs-Setups, Wirdes-Zeug und einfach auch extrem viele Freaks und andere Wahnsinnige.
Die einfach auch auf den Geschmack gekommen sind. Ich habe auch wieder so eine
Truppe getroffen, die das erste Mal auf dem Kongress waren und die waren auch
einfach völlig entflammt und völlig so, was ist denn das bitte jetzt hier für ein Ort?
Weil die einfach mitkriegen dann eben so, ja okay, das war zwar bisher nicht so auf meiner Agenda,
aber offensichtlich gibt es noch die guten Orte, wo alle so einen völlig auffälligen,
guten Umgang miteinander pflegen.
Ich finde, das ist ja auch eines der Hauptmerkmale dieses Kongresses geworden.
Das war schon immer so, aber ich finde, es ist gerade im letzten Jahr noch sehr
viel mehr so geworden, dass einfach ein exzellenter Umgang miteinander gepflegt wird.
Das sollten aber auch einige Eltern ihren Kindern beibringen,
die mit den Rollern irgendwie aus dem Weg schreiend in diesen engen Glasteilen hin und her rennen.
Und die Eltern lachen mit einem Roller hinterher von welchen Mengen.
Genau. Jetzt kurz das Beinchen stellen.
Die Verkehrswende muss auch dort geübt werden. Aber ich finde es auch schön,
dass man auch das ausprobieren kann.
Wie nach und nach die Verkehrsschilder in den Glasgängen aufgeploppt sind.
Ich glaube, das ist auch der einzige wirkliche problematische Teil an dieser
Messe, diese schmalen Röhren.
Also das ist wirklich der eine Teil, der so von der, vom Benutzerflow wollte
ich gerade sagen, wie heißt das? Menschenflow.
Da halt schwierig ist, wenn viele Leute durch diese schmalen Glasröhren gehen.
Das ist wirklich, ich würde sagen, das ist so einer, ich glaube,
das ist für mich der einzige Nachteil an dieser Messe.
Ja, ist leider ein Problem.
Aber jetzt nochmal zurück, ich will jetzt hier keine Insider-Infos,
ich weiß doch gar nicht, ob die überhaupt schon jemand hat, aber normalerweise
ist es ja wie nach dem Kongress, vor dem Kongress, so planungsmäßig für manche
Leute, soll es jetzt noch größer werden, wollt ihr noch mehr Hallen besetzen?
Es gibt noch irgendwie ein Viertel, was nicht gemietet wurde oder so.
Wir haben noch fünf Hallen da hinten. Ihr habt doch nicht alle fünf Hallen gespielt
dieses Jahr. Echt? So richtig auch komplett bespielt.
Weil ich war ja letztes Jahr einmal kurz mal da, einen Tag lang und da war zum
Beispiel Halle 5, da stand irgendwie was rum.
Zu drei Vierteln war die Lager oder sonst was.
Du warst letztes Jahr da oder vorletztes? Beim ersten Mal in Leipzig oder jetzt
letztes Jahr? Letztes Jahr war ich mal einfach da.
Da stand was rum, naja da war die Lounge.
Ja, aber das war ein so ein Ja.
Es war die Hälfte Es war ein Achtel der Halle Ein so ein.
Squash Court und der.
Rest war hinten so sage Halle Dieses Jahr war es ein Viertel Jetzt war es auch
wieder Launch aber nur ein Viertel von der Halle oder insgesamt Hälfte glaube
ich gebucht also da ist noch minimal.
Also jetzt war es ein richtiges Achtel würde ich sagen also von der gesamten
Halle Also von dem abgetrennten Viertel die Hälfte.
Ja und 4 ist Lager, ne? Also die Halle 4 ist komplett Lager.
4 ist, ne, ist 3 Viertel Lager, 1 Viertel ist Talk.
Wird also auch schon bespielt.
Wird auch schon bespielt. Weil Halle 3 Ja.
Dann ab nach Hannover. Wenn Leipzig nicht mehr war.
Nee, Hannover waren wir, haben wir uns angeguckt.
Riecht aus dem Mund?
Das würde ich jetzt nicht sagen, aber Aber dafür, dass du da...
Die halten zu weit auseinander, ne? Die sind nicht so geil verbunden wie der
Glaswurst, wie in Leipzig oder so, ne?
Richtig. Unter anderem. Also dafür, dass du im Prinzip erstmal ähnliche Probleme
hast, weil Messegelände, ist Leipzig da deutlich besser zu handeln.
Und während man in Leipzig auch schon beklagen kann, dass man da so ein bisschen
am Arsch der Welt ist, ist es irgendwie in Hannover, gerade was die Eingangssituation
betrifft, noch ein bisschen schwieriger.
Ja, also, ja, wir haben uns ja verschiedene Standorte angeschaut, wir waren in Dortmund,
wir waren in Berlin und du musst halt schon mehrere Sachen zusammenbringen,
also du brauchst vor allem viele kleine Organisationsräume etc.
pp. da ist einfach messe leipzig viel flexibler also
hast du einfach mehr mehr das
was was wir brauchen uns hat sich auch gezeigt dass wir eigentlich alles haben
was wir brauchen einzige wasser wünschenswert wäre aber was halt nicht so ist
ist dass man diese hallen noch flexibler teilen kann als man sie teilen kann
jetzt um noch mehr draus zu machen aber das ist halt so wie es ist und in deiner
eigentliche frage zu beantworten dieses wo will man hin.
Also erstmal vorweg, ich bin da jetzt irgendwie weder die Autorität,
so eine Debatte irgendwie zu leiten oder zu führen.
Ich habe da eine Meinung zu oder eine gewisse Erfahrung so, aber ich bin,
will jetzt hier nicht den Eindruck erwecken, ich würde diese Debatte jetzt irgendwo
hinführen wollen oder so.
Mal so als Standard-Disclaimer vorneweg.
Wir sind jetzt hier off the record.
Klar, wir sind ja unter uns. Hört ja keiner zu.
Ist schon so spät.
Was sich in den letzten Jahren meiner Meinung nach immer gezeigt hat,
ist, immer wenn man den Kongress hat wachsen lassen, hat es ihm gut getan. Immer wenn wir dem Druck,
der nachwachsenden Szene und der höheren Teilnehmerzahlen nachgeben haben können
und mehr Leute empfangen können, ist der Kongress besser geworden.
In diesem Falle.
So würde ich es nicht formulieren wollen, aber es ist einfach so,
wenn du es umdrehst und sagst, du machst da jetzt den Deckel drauf und du machst
die ganze Zeit so eine Begrenzung,
dann fängst du an, den Kongress an einem ganz kritischen Punkt zu zerstören,
weil der Kongress lebt von dieser permanenten Weitergabe des Wissens und dieser
Evolution und die kann aber nur stattfinden,
wenn du auch immer die alten Leute, Anführungsstrichen,
Und die neuen Leute mehr oder weniger gleichzeitig und parallel immer wieder
in so einem konstanten, natürlichen Versorgungsflow drin hast,
um diesen Genpool zu mischen.
Was ich zum Beispiel in Berlin gezeigt hatte, also ich weiß noch,
der letzte Kongress in Berlin, das war schlimm, weil da war dann wieder mal,
Ticketsystem war alles noch nicht so ausgereift, das kam ja später erst in richtig
gut, war dann natürlich wieder alles Server down,
alles überlastet und am Ende war es so ein Lotteriespiel, wer überhaupt ein
Ticket bekam oder nicht.
was dann dazu führte, dass eben sehr viele Leute neu da waren,
was an sich erstmal nicht.
Falsch war, aber dann eben auch viele Gruppen so gesagt haben,
so hier eine Person aus unserer Gruppe und wir gehen ja immer alle zusammen,
hat kein Ticket bekommen, gehen wir jetzt alle nicht und dann merkt es auf einmal
so, man lief so rum und dann so, irgendwie fehlen dieses Mal wirklich also diese,
Schlagzahl von bekanntes Gesicht, bekanntes Gesicht, da ergibt sich so eine
gewisse Frequenz, du gehst über diesen Kongress Und wenn du so ein paar Jahre
dabei bist, dann willst du einfach so eine gewisse Erkennungsfrequenz haben.
Nicht, dass du mit allen redest oder so, aber du siehst einfach so,
ah ja, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack und dann stellt sich halt ein entsprechender
Heimlichkeitskoeffizient ein.
Und der ging irgendwie so in einen kritischen Bereich für mich,
wo ich so das Gefühl hatte, so, oh.
Werden wir jetzt überhaupt noch in der Lage sein, neuen Leuten zu erklären, was der Kongress ist?
Weil wenn der Kongress nicht aus dem Alten heraus immer wieder diese Power entwickeln
kann und diese Heimlichkeit entwickeln kann, wie sollen dann andere Leute davon begeistert sein?
Weil es dann halt auch auf einmal nicht mehr so ist und dann reißt er diese
Kontinuität ab und das ist ganz schlimm. Und deswegen bin ich ein großer Freund
davon, diesem Druck so weit nachzugeben, wie man kann.
Es gibt natürlich in die andere Richtung auch Belastungsgrenzen.
Mehrererlei Art. Also erstmal rein organisatorisch. Jetzt sieht es gerade mal
wieder so aus, als ob wir das in irgendeiner Form in den Griff bekommen haben.
Dadurch, dass einfach so viel nachgewachsen ist und jetzt auch durch diese Repetition
des letzten Kongresses, man hat ja in Anführungsstrichen so einen Copy-Paste-Kongress gemacht,
man hat die alten Pläne genommen, nichts neu aufgeteilt, haben sich zwar ein
paar Sachen naturgemäß auch verändert, aber es mussten jetzt nicht alle Wege nochmal komplett,
es wurde nicht alles komplett neu reingeniert, dadurch hat man schon mal einen
Monat oder zwei vielleicht sogar auch gespart in der Vorbereitung.
und deswegen wussten noch mehr Leute so, ah ja, Abbau wird wieder in etwa so
laufen, diese Wege, diese Reihenfolge, letztes Mal haben wir es aber so gemacht,
das war scheiße, lass diesmal anders machen.
Es wurde irgendwie besser und
jetzt war es halt mal smooth und das ist so genau so, wie es sein sollte.
Jetzt kann man natürlich darüber
diskutieren, okay, wie viele Leute verträgt das Gelände jetzt noch?
Ist nicht auch öffentliche Anforderungen und Begrenzungen, Also es kann ja jetzt
nicht, also selbst wenn.
Ja, aber da sind jetzt 17.000 wieder, die spielen ja ihre komische Buchmesse
oder so einen anderen Quatsch da auf dieser Leipziger Messer,
die haben höhere, auf dem Gelände haben sie schon höhere Teilnehmerzahlen.
Ja, aber trotzdem muss es ja irgendwo offizielle Auflagen geben,
die nicht nur über den Raum. Die sind nicht unendlich.
Genau, es gibt da Grenzen. Ich bin mir da jetzt nicht ganz sicher.
Ich habe jetzt ein bisschen Hörensagen, deswegen will ich jetzt mal keine Zahl
sagen, aber ich habe von einer Teilnehmerzahl, wenn wir die erreichen würden,
würden sich halt Feuerwehrauflagen nochmal signifikant ändern.
Dann musst du halt nochmal genauere Pläne abgeben und nochmal höhere Sicherheitsauflagen
erfüllen und dann bist du in so einem Bereich,
wo du dann irgendwie anfängst, dich in diesem bürokratischen Wahnsinn,
den solche Großveranstaltungen sind.
Genau, dann wird es irgendwie schwierig. Also das ist so ein Faktor.
Dann musst du natürlich auch eine Skalierung wählen, wo eben diese ganzen Gruppen mitkamen.
Also am Anfang war halt, Zert ist ein gutes Beispiel,
hast dann so große Halle, mehr Luft, alles auch potenziell ein bisschen kühler,
vielleicht so Warm-Kalt-Wechsel,
dann werden dir mehr Leute krank und dann hast du dasselbe Team wie letztes
Mal mit 12.000 Leuten auf einmal mit 15.000 oder 17.000 Leuten.
Das heißt, du hast automatisch einfach mal 50 Prozent mehr Einsätze,
Versorgung, Leute, die irgendwo mal sich ablegen müssen, Zuspruch brauchen und
so, das kannst du ja viel besser einschätzen, Thaler.
Und dann muss das halt mit skalieren. Wenn ich aber jetzt höre,
so, ja, wieder viele neue Leute dazu gekommen, Orga gefunden,
erstmal Leipzig war ja auch schwierig, ja, was haben wir für Wege,
wie bedienen wir das alles,
wie planen wir hier unsere Schichten, wie machen wir hier unsere Rundläufe,
wo packen wir was, wo in welche Räume hin, sind wir hier irgendwie am richtigen
Ort oder brauchen wir andere Räume, brauchen wir weitere Kapazitäten,
das sind alles so Sachen, die sich erstmal wieder finden müssen.
und jetzt kann es sein, dass wir das so haben.
Alles in allem finde ich, ist Leipzig jetzt so, hat sich in diesen drei Jahren
als ein guter Ort für uns herausgestellt, funktioniert,
ist ein guter Event und wir haben sehr viel neue Möglichkeiten geschaffen und
auch genutzt und so kann es meiner Meinung nach bleiben.
Oder so kann es, auf der Basis kann es sich weiterentwickeln.
Also zu Stoßzeiten beim Zert, sowohl Nachmittag.
Wir haben halt irgendwie fünf Liegeplätze plus zwei weitere Räume und die sind
dann halt auch teilweise voll.
Voll. Und auch abends teilweise Personen, die längerfristig betreut werden müssen.
Also das ist schon nicht ohne. Und das ZERT ist ja nicht die einzige Support.
Es gibt die Outie-Räume, die Quiet Rooms, die irgendwie runterkommen Räume.
Also da ist schon echt viel an Betreuung nötig.
Silent Hackspace war jetzt dieses Jahr auch irgendwie ein großes Ding,
ich habe da leider nicht viel Zeit verbracht.
Ja, es gibt ja seit ein paar Jahren diese Bewegung von Autisten,
die sich sozusagen selber darum gekümmert haben, dass der Kongress für Autisten
erträglich ist, weil Großveranstaltungen, Autisten, das passt nicht unbedingt
immer so super zusammen,
aber natürlich ist das Interesse da und deswegen wurden da halt Teams gebildet
und eben auch jetzt Räume geschaffen.
So gab es halt dann diesen Silent Hackspace.
Wo nicht dauernd uns im Hintergrund läuft.
Keine Musik, da ist einfach ruhig und stellt sich raus, ist auch nicht nur für Autisten geil.
Es gab auch durchaus ein paar Hacker, die es einfach voll geil fanden,
sich da einfach mal hinzusetzen und einfach mal eine Stunde in Ruhe,
aber so richtig in Ruhe, ohne aber jetzt ins Hotel laufen zu müssen,
in Ruhe irgendwo was machen konnten.
so und ja, ist dann auch so, denkst du so ja, warum sind wir da nicht schon eher drauf gekommen?
Ja, weil wir den Platz gar nicht hatten, die Frage hat sich irgendwie überhaupt
gar nicht gestellt so einen Ort zu schaffen und derzeit ist es so,
dass man in Leipzig vielleicht nicht mehr aus dem Vollen schöpfen kann und man
muss sich immer überlegen, wo genau ist das jetzt?
Aber es gibt noch irgendwo eine Ecke.
Es gibt sogar noch eine ganze Batterie von leeren Räumen, aber die sind relativ weit weg.
Das Messerhaus ist inzwischen auch.
Das Messerhaus wird teilweise schon benutzt, es sind aber glaube ich nur so
drei Räume von Seminarräume und in dem Übergang.
Ist halt unten der Quiet. Also kleine Räume gibt es sicherlich noch.
Also kannst du ja mal noch Zelte auf dem Parkplatz aufstellen.
Haben wir auch schon.
Für Vortragsdinger reicht das auch. Wenn du auf dem Camp aufbauen kannst,
kannst du auch ein Zelt einstellen, da deinen Vortragssaal reinmachen.
Ja gut, ein Vortragsselen, das ist jetzt nicht die begrenzte Ressource.
Es ist immer nur so spezielle Räume für spezielle Antworten.
Ja, aber die nehmen Spaceback auf der Halle.
Die Vortragsziele, die halt rausverlagerst Ja.
Aber aus einer Halle kriegst du halt keinen Silent-Hack-Space oder sonstige
Spezialräume Du brauchst immer so kleine, teilbare Organisationenräume von irgendwie
10 bis 100, 200, 300 Leuten Damit kannst.
Du irgendwie was machen Also ich hab mir jetzt in den 10 Tagen im September
extrem die Hacken abgelaufen auf dem Gelände, alter Scheiter.
Ja, aber da gibt es ja auch fahrende Sofas.
Nur mit den Kanten aufpassen.
Alles mögliche. Man lebt da auch Elektromobilität auf eine ganz neue Art und Weise.
Manche Leute sind einfach auf Mate-Kisten unterwegs.
Man merkt auch am Anfang, dieser Verkehr war letztes Mal, glaube ich,
sogar noch mehr ein Problem.
Jetzt waren auch relativ viele Scooter unterwegs.
Also nicht nur mit Elektroscootern, auch mit den normalen Scootern.
und es gab jetzt ein richtiges Parkplatzproblem.
Das hat sich schon vor der Veranstaltung abgezeichnet. Das war schon im Lok
so, weil natürlich im Lok, also im Lager, jeder einen Roller hat,
weil natürlich alle die ganze Zeit über das gesamte Gelände fahren müssen.
Wenn du einen Monat Logistik machst, dann läufst du nicht.
Führte dann dazu, dass sich sofort diese großen Pools von übereinandergestürzten,
Rollern bildeten, wo alle irgendwie ihren abstellen und dann fiel einer um,
fiel alle um und dann wurde halt erstmal eine Lösung gesucht für das Problem.
Hat sich einfach jemand Holz genommen, macht man mal was mit Holz und so einen
Rollerparkplatz Ständer gebaut.
Einfach so eine lange Leiste, wo so viele kleine,
Abstände dazwischen sind und dann kannst du deinen Roller einfach gerade reinschieben,
dann steht er so und muss auch keinen Ständer ausklappen oder so.
Die wurden dann an mehreren Stellen auf dem Kongress gebaut und haben dieses
Problem wieder gleich eine Steckdosenleiste dran.
Das würde ich mal sagen, der nächste hat.
Auch gut für Skateboards funktioniert die man da so reinklemmen kann die kann
man auch super da reinstellen genau.
Also der Kongress findet auch da wieder Antworten, das mag ich so also wir werden
auch diese Verkehrsproblematik in den Griff kriegen mit all seinen Auswirkungen
also sowohl die Unfallgefahr muss gebannt werden als eben auch die reine,
aber es ist klar, es gibt den Bedarf an den du kannst jetzt nicht sagen,
Roller verboten oder so.
Man sollte halt das Gefährt, was man wählt, auch bedienen können.
Das ist eine Sache, die mir aufgefallen ist.
Demnächst vorher nur Fahrschule.
Führerschein, genau.
Man sollte das Gerät schon bedienen können.
Genau. Naja. Hier werden schon wieder ganz viele andere Städte vorgeschlagen.
ÖPNV.
Ja, wir brauchen so einen Zug.
So eine U-Bahn.
Ja, oder ich meine, man kann ja aus diesen ganzen Elektrofahrzeugen die derzeit
individuell unterwegs sind, so Zugbildungssysteme bauen.
Also dass man vielleicht diese ganzen Mathe-Kisten, dass die sich automatisch
hintereinander einreihen und dann wie so ein Zug fahren und einfach so reihum fahren.
Ich meine, hatten wir auf dem Camp auch so ein Zug. So was, ne?
Ja, und es gab einige Unfälle mit dem Zug auf dem Camp.
Ja, der war auch ein bisschen groß und schwer. Also diese kleine Mate-Kiste
ist nicht so das Problem.
Das Problem ist eher die Geschwindigkeit, dass die unterschätzt wird.
Sowohl wenn man außerhalb des Zuges ist, als auch wenn man auf dem Zug ist.
Naja, aber das ist dann vielleicht das Problem des Verunfallens.
Also auch Glasflaschen, ich habe keine offiziellen Zahlen, aber das größte Problem
sind halt irgendwie Schnittverletzungen.
Naja gut, aber Mateflaschen sind noch nie dafür bekannt gewesen,
dass sie gerade sich zurückhalten, wenn sie umfallen. Die explodieren halt zu schnell.
Ja, wir hatten ja jetzt auch Wasserglasflaschen.
Ich erinnere mich noch daran, wie sie die mal in Hamburg, weil sozusagen die
Krönung von ihrem Rohrpostsystem, haben sie ja bei der Rommi gespielt und dann
kam irgendjemand auf die Idee, dann kann man ja auch mal eine Mateflasche reinschieben.
Das hab ich gesehen, das war das war ein beeindruckender Moment.
Der brach aus der Kurve aus dem Rohr aus so viel Power, dass die Kurve nicht
mitgenommen hat sondern einfach gedacht hat, nee ich setz mal meine Masse in
die richtige Richtung weiter fort, durchs Rohr durch.
Das war aber ein schöner psychologischer Moment so, weil es war so, es machte so,
und du merktest richtig so alle Beteiligten so so.
Ups.
Hätte ich doch mal Physik aufgepasst. Ja, es war so, sie haben sich in so einen
Wahn irgendwie, sie haben halt alles mögliche ausprobiert, bis halt einer diese
Flasche reingemacht hat.
Aber es war dann auch schön zu sehen,
wie sich alle so mit diesem Blick anschauten, so okay, das war zu viel.
Wir müssen uns zurückhalten. Also es war einfach der Lerneffekt,
war sofort da, also es war nicht so Gejohle, so guck mal jetzt hier.
Diese Dinge machen,
Seidenstraße gibt es noch, aber nicht mehr geländewald oder was?
Weil da würde es sich ja echt mal lohnen.
Hallenweit, du kannst halt die Übergänge immer schwer machen wegen Feuerwehr,
Feuerschutztüren und so weiter, da ist es immer schwierig, das zu überbrücken.
Wollen wir es packen? Meine Stimme, also mein Hals wird immer schlimmer.
Ja, du siehst schon sehr krank aus.
Danke.
Nee, wir machen jetzt auch Schaluss, weil Zeit ist durch.
Ja, Leute, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören.
Jetzt gibt es wieder Freakshow. Mal gucken, Termine in den nächsten Wochen müssen
wir nochmal ein bisschen auskäsen.
Dann wird es auf jeden Fall nochmal einen kleinen Häuperer geben,
aber wir sind wieder da und wir freuen uns, dass ihr auch wieder alle da seid
und gebt mal ordentlich Feedback hier zum Kongress.
Ich hoffe, wir haben uns hier nicht im Kopf und Kragen geredet.
Wird es ja dieses Jahr wieder eine Tim-Auszeit geben? Barcelona 2?
Nee, nicht ganz im Gegenteil. Es gibt eine totale,
Tim-Extra-Zeit.
Tim ist langweilig. Der muss beschäftigt werden.
Tim hat seine Steuer. Ich habe viel vor, aber dazu später im Jahr.
Jetzt ist erstmal Schluss und insofern Gute Nacht.
Gute Nacht.
Genau. Wir müssen hier nochmal, wo ist denn hier unsere Musik?
Du wolltest noch irgendwas spielen, ne? Von dem einen Talk.
Das mach ich auch gleich noch. Aber jetzt machen wir erstmal hier unser normales
Tschüss sagen und so weiter, ne? Also, bis bald.
Tschüss.
Well, that's what we have for you today.
Thank you for coming.
And we'll see you soon.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
zum nächsten Mal.
Einen habe ich noch. Das hier ist der letzte Vortrag, den ich in diesem Jahrzehnt halten werde.
Ich lasse euch jetzt mal ein paar Sekunden in Ruhe und wünsche mir,
dass jeder kurz darüber nachdenkt, was für ihn in diesem Jahrzehnt die maßgebliche
gesellschaftliche Entwicklung war.
Glaube hat jeder was. Für mich ist es der Aufstieg der Empörten.
Und damit meine ich ausdrücklich jede politische Richtung.
Ich habe in diesem Jahrzehnt tausendmal an jeder Ecke gehört,
wie wichtig heutzutage technische, naturwissenschaftliche und analytische Skills
seien, angeblich mit anderen Worten Rationalität.
Und auf der anderen Seite aber reicht es heute im öffentlichen Diskurs als Totschlagsargument,
wenn jemand empört ist. Und ich finde das Paradox ist das Gegenteil von Rationalität.
Man kann nicht beides gleichzeitig propagieren.
Und ich möchte anregen, dass wir für das jetzt kommende Jahrzehnt zu einer Kultur finden,
in der es ungern gesehen wird, einfach nur alles Mögliche anzubrangern und in
der es ganz umgekehrt bewundert wird, wenn man sich die Datenlage anguckt,
und sie sich gegenseitig präsentiert mit seinem Kontrahenten und sich dann zusammensetzt.
Und wer soll das starten, wenn nicht wir hier?
Verlassen wir uns nicht auf die Medien, denn die leben vom Aufruhr,
auch wenn es positive Gegenbeispiele gibt.
Verlassen wir uns nicht auf irgendwelche Stars, die leben von Likes und die
kriegt man am besten durch Zuspitzung. In der Regel sind die Teil des Problems.
Verlassen wir uns nicht auf Politiker, die achten wegen der Shitstorm-Kultur
nur noch darauf, bis zur nächsten Wahl nicht anzuecken und zu viele von denen
haben ohnehin niemals außerhalb der Politik gearbeitet. Was soll da schon kommen?
Und das ist der Grund, warum ich das hier mache.
Ja, ich versuche euch zu inspirieren, eure eigenen Analysen zu strittigen Themen anzustellen.
Denn in meinen letzten Vorträgen, meinen beiden hier, habt ihr ein paar Instinkte
davon bekommen, wie das geht und ich hoffe, ich habe euch bewiesen,
dass das absolut keine Raketen ist.
Und ich frage nochmal, wer soll das machen, wenn nicht wir hier?
Wenn wir es gemeinsam schaffen, dass wenigstens manche, die heute echt nichts
Besseres zu tun haben, als sich im Internet zu empören,
im nächsten Jahrzehnt zur engagierten Analyse übergehen und dabei auch anerkennen,
wenn was rauskommt, das sie vorher nicht gedacht hätten, dann haben wir gesellschaftlich
unglaublich viel gewonnen.
Und heute Abend stehe ich hier in einem Saal mit 5000 Leuten,
voll belegt, da sitzen sie noch neben der Tribüne,
mit 5000 Leuten, die sich am Samstagabend zwischen Weihnachten und Silvester
hier hinsetzen, also da, wo die allermeisten Menschen einfach gar nichts tun
und sich die Flasche Wein an den Hals anschließen.
Und warum tun die 5000 Leute was? Um einen Statistikvortrag zu hören.
Das gibt mir Hoffnung. Ich werde glücklich heimfahren, da kann die Bahn mit
mir machen, was sie will.
Und ich bedanke mich, dass ihr hier wart und wünsche euch ein schönes neues Jahrzehnt.
Applaus.